These people are so deranged. It's
actual derangement.
>> Tell me if this is not true. Have you
not doxed people on stream before? Soy
pill is literally like, "Bro, can you
not destroy my whole reason for like why
I think I can interact with you?"
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know why we're playing. The word
games here are really funny tonight. I
don't know if this is intentional or
not. Like not so erodite is here. Okay.
How are you a woman? You do this to
other women. How have I become the guy
who notices this and points it out?
Okay. Hold on. Let's just we'll check
this out real quick and then I might
roll back to see what he's getting
pressed on.
>> One, Destiny, I already get so many
DJers in my DMs telling and not because
you told them to, by the way. I know
that's not it, but just because of like
just disagreements that you and I might
have, but two, like tell me if this is
not true. Have you not doxed people on
stream before?
>> Yeah, pe people related to I don't know
who or why. It doesn't matter what your
justification is. My point is that like
you've done things that I would say I
>> Dude,
it's so funny. Oh, I'm allowed to dox
those people. Don't you understand?
Those are the rules. We're allowed to
dox those guys, dude. Okay. All right.
>> I think that's okay. And I'm sure you
could find all
>> I'm not trying to make these things.
>> He actually he actually just SSRI sighed
at soy pill over being like, "Don't you
dox people?" Oh, whatever. You don't
even know what you're talking about. You
serious?
What's wrong with this guy?
>> I'm saying is like if you're saying,
"Oh, well now I can never ever ever do
anything with this person because it's a
tacid endorsement of everything they've
ever done." Whether that is
>> not No one even said that. No one was
making behavior. It's about
collaborating with people that are
actually trying to destroy the other
people in your space.
>> Yes.
>> Like that like that's a very simple
thing. It's not like somebody said a bad
thing and now you're
that's way different. Destiny would
never try to destroy somebody in this
space ever. He would absolutely
never do that.
>> Like they're actively Hassan will
actively.
>> It's way different. Don't you know that
Hassan is trying to destroy people?
>> Trying to destroy people in this space.
Like you were on argue. Well, not at the
same time, but Dylan Burns was on there.
Okay. A guy who we've all watched. I
think we all are personally friends with
or at least I I am friendly with call
this guy a war tourist. Okay. A war
tourist. All right. And was regularly
roasting him. And then why do you think
Dylan was on it?
probably because Dylan had some he
wanted to talk about the Ukraine issue
because absent
matter that Dylan went on there and
promoted good messages despite the fact
that Hassan was on that panel.
>> You just totally touched up what I
brought up though. I'm just saying that
Hassan is like will personally try to
destroy using personal not like these
are just political
>> the whole thing is you're criticizing me
for potentially working with him.
>> Wait, Wick called Wait, Wick called
Dylan Burns a war tourist.
That's crazy. That's like got to be
insane panel verse jealousy, right? That
has to be
>> him, which was being on a panel that he
was on as well. Dylan was as well. Dylan
has even more personal beef because of
what you just described and yet said,
"You know what? I think I can do more
good introducing a liberal pro- Ukraine
message, especially with all the
anti-Israelit that panel." It's like,
"Hey, look, I'm actually like talking
about other anti-war things that matter,
and I think he did more good doing that
than I would have if you said, "Oh,
Hassan Hassan was really mean to me. I'm
not going on this mean to me."
>> Yeah, but just just real quick. I want I
want I don't know like maybe maybe I'm
separating myself from Destiny here, but
I am not criticizing you or Dylan for
still working with Progressive Victor.
You do what you
>> So I think this panel is just them the
far left a parasite on democracy.
Dude, by the way, Soy Pill, just watch
what happens to Soy Pill because he's
like saying these things because he's
just like saying totally regular normal
things. Okay.
I would love I I hate that it has to get
litigated, but I'd love for Soy Pill to
just go, "Why do you justify doxing
these people again?
What did What did Supreme do to you?
What did What did any of these people do
to you? You know, the history of Kraut
and doxing others. I know that there was
something to do with a police thing with
him and bad empanada. That's it. That's
all I know.
>> You think is best for your goal,
>> but I mean Wick clearly doesn't care
about people doxing, right? Wick if
Wick's having panels with multiple
people who do it. No, by the way, like
not even at at some point you could
forgive somebody for doing something
bad, right? But like there's no remorse
whatsoever. There's nothing like this.
Arerite is about to join too. Fantastic.
Let's go back. Let's just roll with this
right off the bat. Why not do this right
off the bat? We can just cover this for
a little bit. We'll do this panel. You
just know that Soy Pill joins up and
he's going to say some things to defend
like progressive victory and associating
with leftists. So someone's got to be in
there immediately, right? Immediate. How
dare you? How dare you say that? How
dare you say that leftist might not be
poisonous scum? How dare Oh my god. What
does Hassan Pika do online? What does he
spend his time talking about? It's
either spreading disinformation or his
personal vendettas. That's literally all
he does.
>> You That's That's not all he does. I
spreading disinformation and going after
his personal vendettas.
I like I'm sorry
you are describing somebody in the space
and they are on the panel with you but
you're it's not quite Hassan even like
even for um even for Destiny that would
be totally misleading right like and I
don't I obviously don't like Destiny but
even if I if I said the only thing
Destiny does is go after people covers
personal vendettas I do think he rolls
his personal vendettas into his politics
but Hassan's the guy who's been like the
socialist democ like socialist type for
a long time. Desi is the one who will
flip on issues because these people,
okay, but in any case, he still does
political advocacy. He still went to
like an event and tried to do something
with the National Ground Game people,
right?
To try to say that, oh, all they do is
do the um like misinformation and and
attacking people based on personal
vendettas. That's that's just not true.
People always forget that there's like
these these two stream Well, Hassan
streams eight hours a day, right? or
seven six seven hours a day you you see
like.1%
of it and then you're like I have a good
idea of who this is. No, you're looking
at this distorted lens. You have no idea
who the person is. You don't know what
the content is like at all.
>> Usually the left also, right? I feel
like that's a thing. I think it'd be
weird if I spent all this time attacking
conservatives and then people just spend
all their time attacking your son. I
think it'd be really strange. But I
don't know. When I look at that
movement, it feels like they're more
concerned with attacking other Democrats
than doing anything against Republicans.
>> Yep. No, I don't disagree. But my issue
is this is how how much are they able to
hurt the left versus the right is and
that's what I think the proportionality
should be dedicated to. Like don't get
me wrong, these people are actively
announcing their
>> WHICH ONE WHO IS HASSAN obsessed with.
Is he obsessed with Democrats or is is
he obsessed with Asmin Gold? Cuz I was
told that he can't stop talking about
Asmin Gold ever. Some people how how do
we run both narratives at the same time?
Hassan literally is so obsessed with
Asmin Gold he can't stop thinking about
as gold. Or is he obsessed with I guess
Democrats?
I I actually don't know, but I see two
different communities running with that
same thing. And then they'll post clips
of like which could to a total Julian
look very compelling that make it look
like he's only obsessed with one of
these groups, but somehow they're from
the same period of time. How does that
work?
>> You know, ideals to subvert the
Democratic party, subverting better
candidates, like pushing someone like in
my opinion a platner over a Collins,
which I don't think is good. Um is it
Collins? No, doesn't matter. Point is,
uh like that sort of excuse me, thank
you. Um
>> that should have and should be talked
about. Uh but when it's like all right
and then let's focus on the fact that my
day-to-day life is materially worse
every day because of MAGA. Uh that
deserves a lot more energy right now and
how we can like fight back against that.
That's all I'm saying.
>> Most people Well, I think most people
agree that MAGA is bad. That's not a
disagreement. The disagreement is that
the people in Assan camp are saying that
Democrats won't do anything better for
it, which I think is problematic when
the right can cast them as our figures,
which they do. They love to do that.
>> That's not true. That's literally not
what that like literally if you listen
to the talk between what is it? um
Mockler and Hassan. It's like not true,
right? Like Hassan says, "Oh, Hassan
agrees that the outcomes for certain
groups are going to be way better with
Democrats rather than Republicans." He's
just saying it's more of the same
managed decline. That like things will
continue to go in a bad direction until
there's a paradigm shift. But if we are
going to go in a bad direction, pick the
Democrat bad direction and not the MAGA
bad direction. It's not an equating of
the two. Um well, they do it in a way to
just damage us and never damage those
people, right? There's a reason why when
they bring Hassan up on Fox News, it's
kind of like the laugh and make fun of
him and then they make fun of all of us.
But they're never ever trying to cancel
these guys cuz these guys are invaluable
to the right. And then, you know,
meanwhile, when it comes to us
evaluating our own movements, there's
this huge apparently genuine rift right
now with some people in the party for
like should we welcome with open arms
people into our movement that want to
destroy the entire political party,
which is what Hassan and other want to
do, but nobody seems to understand or
won't recognize even though basically
explicitly said this across multiple
platforms.
>> Yeah. And it's not something this is
what I want to try to get get across to
you, soil, right? into the audience
listening and I see a lot of you guys um
who disagree in chat and that's fine
right but
>> Odashara super chat soy pill which group
of creators in the uh in these political
projects would do more advocacy for the
democrat in general in the general
progressive victory or digital ground
game there is your answer to where well
it's literally national ground game I
don't know why you said digital you
think DG I guess okay there is there is
your answer as to where to spend your
time
>> and unless someone stands up and says
hey this is a really bad idea to let
these people in positions of influence
in the Democratic party uh because
they're going to push us away from good
policy liberalism in general. And also I
I personally think it's going to be
>> Oh, are they doing a thing where they're
renaming it so it's like DG? Oh, that
would be funny.
>> A gift to MAGA, right? They're going to
just run ads about how look at the far
left and how they're cozying up with
Assam [__] and they'll be able to put
together some really just like of all
these clips of him calling all sorts of
things, right? Of him going off on these
misogynistic.
>> Can I You have to say the things, man.
It's just so disingenuous. Calling all
sorts of crazy things. Okay. Well, Wick,
I'm going to say that you've called
blacks all sorts of crazy things because
you called irrelevant articulate once on
a panel. Okay. Like it you called people
in Oh, it's just of him doing all these
like awful.
>> It just always feels like it's set up to
be misleading in the exact right way.
>> Awful things. It's saying these awful
things and they'll put pictures of him,
right, hanging out with Roana and all
these other kind of politicians, Bernie
Sanders, AOC. I think we just don't like
that's going to hurt us immediately.
fighting on in my opinion, but go ahead.
>> That progressive victory thing is going
to be one of the most ridiculous things
that we've seen in years. I can
guarantee you that like he usurped that
he was everyone who was in there,
including I think
>> Oh, I I would love to hear Kraut defend
this. He us So, if you guys have are
just catching up now, if you're just
getting in now, this guy keeps saying
that Hassan usurped or took over
progressive victory. Uh I know we
watched Hassan comment on this the other
day. I was sent the clip of Hassan
commenting on it. I would love to see
what evidence there is of this because
this is as far as I know
>> by the way not but apparently this is I
didn't even know this was a progressive
victory event until they released it.
They've been constantly uh asking me to
be a part of it for like the last week
or so and I was like [__] it. Why not?
Sure. And Progressive Victory has uh
revealed
totally took over that organization. He
totally took it over. That sounds like
that. Doesn't that sound like he took it
over, guys? Doesn't that sound like a
guy who's got some machinations going
on? He's scheming behind the scenes. He
totally took it over, man. HE TOTALLY
TOOK IT. COME ON.
I I'm pretty sure like if you want to
say somebody took it over, it's probably
like uh Crystal Crystal Ball and Emma
Vigland seem pretty involved. Seem like
core parts of that, right? I feel like
Hassan just got asked to show up on a
stream and he was like, I guess so.
Anyway,
>> Gary, do two of you in here that
organization, right? And he he accused
you all of being like black money,
scionist, conspiracy, whatever the he
user this organization. The first thing
they do with its account is beef with
people for his personal vendetta. He
subverted a policy or just so he could
use it for his personal vendettas. Oh.
Oh, dude. Destiny is about to explain
that this guy sounds totally deranged.
He subverted a policy OR JUST TO JUST
FOR his personal vendettas. No. And I I
said, "Dude, can anybody
>> can anybody think of a reason
Progressive Victory might not like
Destiny?" Like when he basically agreed
and backed up Hassan that it was his own
personal slush fund and all of these
people were so ungrateful because he got
them all paid by Progressive Victory.
Could it be that they don't like that?
Could it be that he consistently has
talked about them for the past six
months? Could it be that? Could it be
any of these? No. No. It has to be that
Hassan took it over and made them start
talking about Destiny for his personal
vendettas. This dude is actually a total
[__]
Why?
Why did people even know who this guy
is? This guy is brain dead. First thing
they did with it that I saw was they
made an excuse for why Hassan openly
docked people that were part of that
organization, which is something that he
was going to write up and not a video
that had the public filings of the
addresses of a bunch of people that were
part of Progressive Victory. Assan went
over it and then the PV account came out
and they did like an apology tweet for
Hassan saying that it was actually their
fault or something. It was ridiculous.
But
>> well, let me I don't want to defend the
what Hassan did because I think that's
an unexcusable to show all those boxes.
But the what PB did specifically was say
and this was their fault in the first
place. This is the reason it was out.
They paid out of the wrong org. It was
supposed to be I think it was the LLC
instead of the pack and they paid out of
the pack and because it was pack you
have to then disclose all of the
addresses and names of all the people
you paid out to. And that was someone in
their or that up. Now Hassan capitalized
off that and then made it worse by
broadcasting it. So it's like oh you
can't say oh it's public therefore it's
not a big deal that now I have a
So Zoy Bill corrects the record and well
we don't like that.
>> Old man Lingre did that. Not Hassan.
Wellre did it too. Hassan No, Hassan did
it. If you're amplifying a docs, if
you're amplifying something somebody was
under the impression that they had
hidden that you are digging up and
finding or even just having it broadcast
to you and you're amplifying it, you are
doing something that's not quite as bad
as finding it yourself, but you're doing
something like that. So I don't want to
minimize what Hassan did. It was doxing
and for I think some of the people
specifically it was quite bad. Not for
Hutch. Hutch got zero information
published on him that was not openly
available on the internet. Okay. That he
had published intentionally himself
like knowing to public like
intentionally publicly attaching to his
persona as a streamer. Okay. So for
Hutch that was totally fake but for
other people it was real and and there
were some there's information on them
that shouldn't have ever been shown on a
stream by Hassan. Pick might have made a
mistake, but Hassan was aggressively and
maliciously using that information to
other political
obvious like if Hassan's mistake was
100, PV's mistake was like like five or
10. Like it wasn't that
>> sure. That's the thing is he was able to
amplify that into a much worse thing
because despite the fact that it's
public, it's like yeah, I can find
someone's public information, but if I
then broadcast that even though it's
public, no, people aren't already
looking for that. Like he's the one who
made that much. I don't think he should
make that excuse and they're using the
clout of Assan on that panel that I was
on to be like, "Oh, well, now we can use
this big, you know, platform to promote
our policies, which to them seems like a
better trade-off than dealing with the
fact that
>> malice would imply intent.
Um, it's hard to say for Hassan what the
intent is like necessarily.
I think the unfortunate thing is not for
me the intent isn't that he wanted to
dox people. The intent to me would be
you're like being willfully reckless. I
know if if I know this then Hassan
definitely knows this. I'm not going to
watch a bad empanada video on my stream
without pre-checking it. I might someday
watch a bad empanada video on my stream,
okay? But I'm never gonna do that
without knowing the content of that
video and knowing that I'm not going to
publish somebody's information when I do
it, right? And I if I know that Hassan
definitely knows that. And so to me,
it's like you're being so reckless.
Maybe he you could argue. I don't really
care to argue like to try to mind read
them.
>> This person abused their mistake and
turned it into a bad thing for all their
creators. So yeah,
>> even after Hassan had abused the people
the Progressive Victory were working
with, right? its creators that they had
worked with and uh had made contracts
with and had promoted and had you know
um the creators had promoted progressive
victory as well to to excuse the abuse
that Hassan did is a betrayal. It was a
betrayal, right? It was a betrayal and
it is a betrayal and that is something
to watch again.
He abused them. I yeah I guess like
it is kind of rough
given
the percentage of those people
I don't know how to say this without
sounding like an um h it was I would say
it seems kind of weird for progressive
victory to come out and say like oh this
isn't a problem because we were the ones
who originally leaked it right yeah this
is
it's just like okay Wick
that don't you think it's a betrayal to
people you've streamed with people who
have been on your stream to platform
somebody who openly like gleefully doxes
them like you are doing something very
similar yourself right now it's it's a
little weird now I think that that that
doesn't necessarily answer the idea that
for progressive victory I do think it's
weird for them to come out and say like
oh this isn't a big deal. But I think
that was fundamentally just somebody
dumb running the account. I think some
people are under the impression that
doxing is just the first time. Like if
you look up somebody if if somebody
finds a doc, they collect it and they
publish it, that's the bad person, and
it's all like located on them. It's all
on them. But that's not really what it
is, right? There's a lot of other
downstream effects. And Hassan amplified
that docs and he did it in a way that
was reckless to people that he doesn't
like.
So, it's very difficult for me to go,
"Oh, well, he had no negative intention
there at all." Now, for a lot of that
info, I do think it was like not a big
deal. But, there are some people who
were quite affected and I don't think
Hassan had any concern to reach out to
them, make sure they were okay, make
sure that and that that's where like the
the politics is at online, which is
just, right, like a thing to do. But
Wick seems to be more angry at
Progressive Victory than he is at
Hassan, which is kind of interesting. an
organization that saw a man
>> abuse its members, call it dark money
shills for Israel, spread all sorts of
malicious hate and lies about it, which
we had to deal with every day just to
kind of crawl back on their knees and
beg for a crumb of clout for him. Wick
Wick was angry about the progressive
victory hate he was getting way before
any way before Hassan was aware of it.
Way before anybody he's he's putting all
of that on Hassan, which is hilarious.
He was already indignant about the
progressive victory stuff when all of us
were saying, "Hey Wick, you should
disclose this. Hey Wick, it's
inappropriate to do political content
for money. Like you're getting paid by a
political or for your political content
and you don't disclose that. That's up."
And he was indignant about that
criticism for months, right?
>> Is I don't I don't know the word. It's
kind of disappoint.
>> Yeah. Suck my suck my off. That's the
only thing you have to say to someone
like that. He can off. He can take his
little pack of idiots and ride off into
the sunset. I have no doubt about the
fact he's going to destroy that
organization, that progressive victory
group. That's done. He's going to burn
it in the into the ground to serve his
personal indebted. And the the only
lesson that people like me and others
here may have to learn from it is next
time around when people like that come
around, you always say no. I It's so
interesting to me. I are the only people
that will go
this guy's like an actual [__]
Like this guy has no idea what he's
talking about at all. nothing.
>> You tell them to off right away. Don't
engage them. Don't have any illusions
about working like people like that with
people like that.
>> I'll say this, the reason I still work
with them and uh I'm not sure how long
that will be depending on where they go,
especially considering I'm seeing where
Tanky and Hassan type stuff coming from
them is that they do promote candidates
that I like and I have yet to encounter
and this might be a naive from me uh
better organizations that take what
they're doing and move and mobilize
people with audiences like me in ways
that I'm okay with. Like for example,
when they did work do work in the past
and I do like the work they did in the
past and I do know people that have been
in charge of that stuff and have left
the organization since. Uh, for example,
Destiny's campusing events that helped
flip Georgia. Uh, those are the things
that I have been like screaming for.
And, uh, the as soon as a better
alternative exists, I think I could
absolutely snap up on the opportunity.
>> You want to know the best thing about
that? All of that was basically that if
you like that stuff, I'm just telling
you, there's like an Asian dude that you
should go hire, okay? Who made sure all
of that stuff happened, who made sure
all of it, who actually did work, who is
actually somebody who can do work. All
right? You should go find that Asian guy
who was super neurotic and got
everything done cuz that was like the
whole that was all of it. All of those
every DGG event every It's Sagon. It is
Son. Okay. All the DG events all the
that other people helped. But I'm
telling you the core of the nucleus of
that stuff was Son. That Son was the
person who was like actually getting
stuff done there. He was the person who
was actually doing work. Destiny wasn't
doing work. I do know that. So other
people went and other people did help
significantly at those events. For sure
they did. So I don't want to make it
seem like nobody else helped at all.
Lots of people helped at those events,
right? But in terms of getting it all
organized, the the actual like
professional person there who who acted
and and worked and got done with Sedon
the whole time. So if you like that if
you like that Soy Pill, you should go
figure out where Sedon is.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I don't This would
just be like a mean 4v1 against you Soy
Pill, but
>> like it was against me.
>> Okay. No, my criticism is a little bit
different. Um, even though liberals and
socialists, they're not really
ideologically aligned. Liberals and
socialists are more ideologically
aligned than liberals and MAGA are. So,
I do think that even though MAGA is the
greater threat and most more liberal
time should be spent critiquing MAGA,
um, the more that you interact with
socialists on a friendly manner, I think
it's more dangerous. It's more toxic.
It's it's more corrosive to to the
Democrat party long term. I know
leftists who really had enough of him.
Like I am friends with leftists who
they're mostly involved with him. And
one thing that I know from talking to
them, the thing that they all
universally tell me when I talk to them
is there is fear in leftist circles of
talking speaking up against the sun. But
he's completely huge like
guy
>> I can't do it.
>> We should forget that either.
>> I will say you're going to have to be
careful. You're giving Hassan way too a
lot of credit there. It's not
necessarily Hassan that's done it. It's
Hassan has kind of been the recipient or
the beneficiary of this huge like online
weird lefty ecosystem that's been set up
that he's now just
Whoa, whoa, whoa. It's almost like
you're trying to Oh, hold on, Kraut.
You're giving falsifiable points. And
so, let me step in and give a totally
unfalsifiable theory that is just me
skits posting. Okay, let me make it
totally unfalsifiable so that when
people come in and try to argue with us,
we go, well, look, Hassan Hassan said
some bad things. That's unironically
what we're about to watch. I I bet five
subs on it, okay, to myself. to enjoy
the benefit of being part of that.
>> It's also possible that he's just the
smartest grifter. I'll give you that as
well.
>> Yeah.
>> Kind of pioneered the field of like
politics of video games on Twitch. So
like that was all right.
>> But I'm saying like all the weird like
obsessive like snarky dramatic like
doxing like the people that are swatting
me over and over again didn't
necessarily come from just community.
It's like this weird peripheral online
tanky movement that has like so much
influence in so many different online
places. Oh, there there are tankies
swatting Destiny. Dude, everybody
everybody swatting these people
apparently. All swatting, all doxing is
all the same group of people. That is
everybody who dislikes Destiny. Do you
know what a far more explicable thing
is?
A way better explanation. Way better.
Okay. Destiny's an inherently unlikable
person that a lot of people can just
dislike without coordinating in any way.
That that's actually just way it
explains everything way better. Turns
out he's just a far less he's just a
totally unlikable totally irredeemable
person who a lot of people hate.
irrespective of anything else and
without coordinating in any way.
>> He does seem to be kind of like their
figurehead though, like their chosen
avatar, if you will. At least from my
perspective.
>> Yeah, it's like ahead weapon for sure.
Yeah.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> People always cringe when I say that,
but it's like a a parody of Stalin's
personality cult the dear leader. Like,
how many times have you encountered
people say, "But he's such a great
symbol of
>> Dude, it's so funny because listen, I'm
sure I'm sure everybody here loves the
hatred that Kraut's bringing. He's just
so
that
he's got a Dude, you gotta you gotta go,
man. You're saying the dumbest thing.
He's such a great representative of the
left. The dear leader this basically.
And I'm here Stalin.
>> Yeah, he's Himbo Stalin.
>> I think we're mostly in alignment of the
things that need to be fought against,
especially with someone like this
subverting a leftist movement. I guess
maybe Destiny you can speak on this
because I think you even maybe said this
before. Do you think, and I'm going to
on Dan a little bit, but just because
he's like a prime example of this, some
people do have like Hassan derangement
syndrome. We were talking about things
that you just don't need to and spending
a disproportionate amount of time on
things that are not, hey, this is an
important uh push back against this
movement of the left wing, but like oh
boy, look at this silly little thing he
did that we
>> Whoa, who is Dan? Desi doesn't even know
who Dan is. What the
>> call out for a week, right?
>> Yeah, a little bit. But whatever Dan
went too far on Hassan does that on a
regular basis and you guys all give him
a passport. I'm not entirely sure about
that. But you do though cuz you're
willing to work with him.
>> When am I willing to work with him? In
what capacity?
>> Was that a serious question?
>> Yeah. Like do you mean like being on the
panel with him?
>> Hassan said I will start an or to Sorry.
>> Yeah, just one day ago. I mean, what do
you all the progressive community were
there when he was on that panel and Mike
was and all those people that I didn't
like. I'm on them in chat. I'm like I
don't like these people but I'm willing
to like if there's like an operation
Barbar Roa type thing where Hassan says
I'll pour $2 million into a camping
event for Senate Democrats in general
races. Absolutely. I'd work with him.
But like the question is about the
oneway street, right?
>> I don't think he will pull $2 million
for obviously
pill. Soy pill you're just one disavow
away. Okay. You just disavow Hassan one
more time. These people will not
You're right there. Just one last
disabel and it'll all be fine
>> to work with you. Like Assan is never
jumping on a liberal project ever.
>> Yeah. If I thought that working with
Assan could get
>> Oh, this is interesting. It is true.
This is actually true though. Yes. All
this discourse about the candidates
needing to avoid Hassan is the same
arguments that were used to argue that
Dems shouldn't platform Joe Rogan. It's
wrong to go on Joe Rogan is Camala
Harris, guys. It's wrong. Yes. Now, I
wouldn't say that's the majority of
people, but those these are the
arguments they used. Yes. Michael
>> has done better than
Is it bad for politicians or political
actors to go on to a platform where
people hate them and to just like shill
their ideas and try to be likable? And I
thought that was like sort of the key
thing that you're supposed to do. You're
supposed to go anywhere, talk to anybody
and go, "This is why I think we see this
is where we see eye to eye and I like
you guys and here's like some stuff we
could work together on and maybe come
watch my stuff or come look at my
right." You're trying to pull people
from that audience into your audience.
This was like a thing that we all agreed
was was good.
Wasn't this why?
Wasn't this why he talked to Lauren
Southern and Nick Fuentes? Was Wasn't
this the point back in the day? Wasn't
that it? I thought that was it.
>> Not did I not do it? And I guess they
that's that's my question.
>> It's It's strange how when all these
conservatives wanted to talk to Destiny,
that was the way it was. And then when
they all decided they hated Destiny and
they don't want to talk to him anymore,
now it's actually bad for everybody else
to do it. Isn't it funny how that works?
As the opportunities come and go, the
justifications change over time.
Well, when all these people do want to
talk to Destiny, when they all do want
to hang out, it's totally fine to go and
talk to them and debate them and and
whatever, even just go for ice cream
with them. But then, as soon as those
opportunities start receding, they start
going away. Well, actually, guys, it's
just wrong for you all to do that.
You're all terrible people. Actually,
that's not
>> here. I mean, like, so the counter
question would be, let's say that
tomorrow, okay, Fentes is really upset
about everything that Trump has done.
They, you know, he's joking about
talking about building Democrat. Let's
Fent starts up like a pro moderate dem
coalition or whatever to fund raise,
whatever. Would you be part of that
panel thing, or thing, speaker thing?
Um, would VM be speaking out against
him? But if he's giving us money, uh, it
would hard to turn that down.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. Like if Elon Mus wanted to donate
to the Democratic party right now, I
would probably accept the money and work
villar's
coming from actually. Yeah, it's
definitely
made like a speaker panel and he called
it progressive destroy Trump victory or
whatever. Would you join it and
participate in the same manner?
>> I guess not. But also to be clear Hassan
didn't make this panel. Hassan was
invited on that panel.
>> Also that panel was uh it was taking the
the side that Soy Pill supports on an
issue, right? And broadly I think that
org is trying to help certain Democrats
get elected that Soy Pill supports,
right? If if Fuentes was supporting in a
truly in a non like here's the problem
is Fuentes in a genuine way is never
going to support a candidate that Soyill
likes, right? That's the issue. Hassan
will Hassan is actively supporting
candidates that Soyill likes. So it's a
totally disingenuous comparison because
Soyill wants to get certain people
elected. He likes them as candidates. Is
that not what what's going on here? He
wants certain candidates elected. Hassan
is working towards getting those
candidates elected and they can
basically butt heads over the on the
things they disagree with and and take
the, you know, the good and the bad.
They can agree on things. They could and
then Soy Pill will basically go, "Hey,
Hassan, you you went after some of my
friends. I don't like that." Right? As
long as he's doing both, I just don't
understand what the problem is. What is
the issue?
You bring up Nick Fuentes, but it's not
the same. If if Fentes somehow had a
genuine change of heart and was
genuinely going out for candidate soy
pill liked and causing positive motion
in their direction, he was trying to
help them, right?
Then yeah, you would work with him, but
it's just it's not real.
>> Okay. Well, if the Okay, Grapers made
the panel and then Fentes went in the
same way that Tankies made this panel
and then went.
>> See, that's my issue is like if you
could tell me that PV was primarily made
of tankies. First, when I joined PV
before, they had a lot of like regime
change stuff. Um, it was people that
explicitly when asking me about my
politics said, "As long as you aren't
anti-electoral, we'll work with you."
And I'm like, "What do you mean by
that?" And they're like, "Hassan,
right?" So, that was the previous like
admin of this group. And now it seems
>> that was not so
>> sh a little more of Vashi. Uh, which I'm
not as happy with. But, if they're like
partnering with Han on a panel to be
anti-war versus Hassan is a primary and
member figurehead of this group and we
are endorsing all of his politics, I
think those are two different things.
So, if it was Hassan's audience
primarily making this panel, I would
agree with you in the same way that that
would be analogous to Griers doing it.
But when it's people that would like
invite him on, I think that's a little
different.
>> Oh, he he literally
I think the framing is just totally
disingenuous. But it's hard to
especially when it's 4v1 think of how
the framing is disingenuous when you go
to argue
>> so like like do you believe that your
interaction with with this group is
better overall for the liberal project
than it is for the socialist project?
>> Yes. I think I think
>> oh the answer should be I think that the
social the socialist project is not very
powerful at all and so while I have a
hard time I have a hard time even
gauging how much it helps them it helps
liberals like pretty massively and so
I'm willing to risk helping them more
because I don't think basically we're
like we're at 99 and they're at one and
so I'm not worried about getting to like
955 that's not scary to me. I've got so
much runway here that I don't care. And
then they'll go, "But Hassan's like
Hitler. He's like the Nazi party. He's
like Hitler in 1932."
No, he's not. But no,
>> the candidates that are being endorsed
and given money to overall are people
I'm happier with. Uh like I like Oliver
Larkin. I like Roana, but Oliver Lin
does go on Hassan stream, right? And
then they have people like Mike from PA
and Hassan on this panel. I'm like not
happy with this. They have some
candidates on there that were saying
some pretty wild [__] that I'm like, not
really happy about this. And that's why
actually when people are posting that
link, it's like the hey, go donate. That
stuff is distributed equally to those
candidates. And I said, "Guys, if you if
you like a camera on here, don't donate
to that. Go find that Canada and donate
to them. Don't do it equally."
>> I don't know. I uh I'm not.
>> So Soy Pill won. No response from
anybody. So pill is literally sitting
here. Hey, I actually I actually don't
even like those candidates. Let's go and
let's go and donate to some other guys.
I'm
>> sure that I can support a candidate
willing to work with Hassan. Um frankly,
so any of these people who are going on
his stream and having
>> What would you for Bernie Sanders? Um,
DUDE, WHAT IF GAVIN NEWSOME GOES ON HIS
STREAM AND THEN WHAT IF he's the WHAT IF
HE'S THE CANDIDATE? DUDE, WHAT IF GAVIN
Newsome talks to Hassan? What are you
going to do? AOC, you hate AOC. You hate
Roan. You hate Bernie Sanders. You hate
all these people. What the
That's wild. That's insane.
He's He's now
>> I would vote for Gavin Newsome over JD
Vance. Unless Gavin Newsome went on
Hassan [__] stream, in which case,
listen, I might just have to give it to
JD Vance. Guys,
this level, by the way, this level of
hysteria is why I can't take these
people seriously. It's why all of the
Hassan history is like totally
disingenuous. like pretending that he's
close to Nick Fuentes, pretending that
he's close to Stalin, pretending that
there's like some some communist
movement that's very close to a
revolution in your country and needs to
be like totally abolished, totally done
away with. It's all insane.
You are insane for suggesting this.
>> I had multiple appearances with
>> I did actually now would you?
>> Uh, probably not. No.
>> Okay. It would depend who's running
against I want to be very clear. any of
these outright endorsing Hassan now. Did
you hear the thing I said?
I feel like you're trolling Jorge the
First. Outright endorsing Hassan now.
Hassan is not Nick Fentes. Hassan is not
Hassan is not Stalin. Oh, you're just
outright endorsing Hassan now. E.
Uh-huh. Opposing JD Vance. I'm voting
for them, right? Like JD Sure. But in
the primary, let's say it's Bernie
versus like
>> Wait, hold on. Now, would you
>> uh probably not
depend who's running against like I want
to be very clear. any of these opposing
JD Vance, I'm voting for them, right?
Like because JD
>> Okay. Okay. No, it's not quite
>> sure. But in the primary, let's say it's
Bernie versus like the most like center
left possible, probably farther away
from your politics than than Bernie
would be, right? Like Bernie has worked
with Asan. He's buddy up with Asan.
Yeah. That's not enough for me to say
I'm never going to vote for this person
who aligns with me all these other
>> again. It really it really depends on on
the you have to it's like fact-based
question you're asking me, right?
Because I have now that I'm talking
about and all his views. I'm not going
to vote for them. But just real quick,
as a rule of thumb, I am saying that if
you are willing to work with Hassan
[__] then you are probably not on my
team, right? You are probably uh more
than likely going to be against a lot of
the things that I stand for because
you're willing to put up with a level of
anti-semitism. You're willing to put up
uh with a level of harassment. You're
willing to put up with a level of just
communist brain rot that I think would
if we accept it in it's it's like a it's
like ingesting poison. It will
eventually kill us. It might make you
feel good at first, but it's eventually
going to kill you. I just this is to me
unfortunately and I don't want to make
all these things things seem equal
because they are not. I think that's
politics are like really bad but like
this is to me like every time it's not
just politics are really bad. His
personal behavior and everything is
deplorable. It is the worst.
>> No no shot. No
shot.
Dude, how how how
in the world do you get the G to come on
this panel and say those words as
destiny
pot kettle? But it's not pot kettle.
It's not. It's like the pot calling the
stainless steel frying pan black. It's
not. You are covered in grime. You are
gross. That that is a brand new
stainless steel frying pan compared to
you. Okay. It's not the same.
>> I'm going to get into that. But that's
less bad for me than the politics which
are like I think are going to
disruptive.
>> I feel like more harassment easier than
almost any other.
>> There's no way. There's just no way.
There's actually no way. Destiny
repeatedly came. Okay, I got to collect
myself. I got to collect myself for two
seconds. That's insane. That was an
insane thing to say. That was a totally
insane thing to say. I had to be chill.
>> I'm saying if I had crowd then go ahead.
>> I don't know what that say. I'm not
saying they're good. Right. If I were to
say, you know, this guy went to murder
your dog to cut his throat and say,
"Well, I wouldn't say that behavior
because you see that behavior is
plural." I think I think I think it's
probably been responsible for more
harassment for anybody like at the
center of probably maybe any other
single individual.
>> Destiny, the thing I was about to bring
up was like whenever I appear on screen
with you, I get so much for all of the
accusations against you. The
>> Destiny actively harasses people he's
like openly victimized.
actively harasses, actively goes. He is
a totally deplorable piece of [__] I
have no idea
how in the world he could say things
like this. It's so crazy.
>> Doc stuff like any and all the other
thing is I'm willing to say real quick.
Who do you think that comes from though?
>> It might be Assad's community.
>> Yes, it is. That's the point. You're
making my point. Yes, correct.
>> How much I don't know how much of this
is legitimate criticism or not, but my
issue is I value your politics and your
movement far more than I do potential
accusations and how true any of these
things are. And so when I hear the stuff
of like,
>> dude, dude, soy pill is literally like,
bro, can you not destroy my whole reason
for like why I think I can interact with
you? Can you not like obliterate the
whole reason if you if you take this
position, I can no longer interact with
you. Can you not burn my bridge with you
accidentally? Can Hey, Destiny, I'm
trying to say I would put the politics.
I'm trying to separate the art from the
artist. Destiny, why are you saying you
can't separate the art from the artist?
Destiny, isn't that what you said? Isn't
that what you said when you came back
from the pixie allegations in the first
place? Isn't that what you said? Guys,
just separate the art from the artist
and keep watching me.
Dude, dude, Hassan is a horrible person.
It's like, yeah, in a lot of ways, I
agree with this. Like, this is just
obviously true. But how much am I
willing to use this person in the same
way he's trying to use us to promote my
goals? And it's like, if you could show
me that this is more harmful to my
movement, that's when I change my mind.
>> Hold on, Hassan. Is that
>> it's not worth saying that like the
personal behavior is bad and so far as
like there might be some misgivings
about how they conduct, whatever. Hassan
will directly attack people like in
these communities. Like, would you still
be willing to work on if you found out
that the meme messages you get when you
come on my stream are me messaging my
fan base and like another Discord? Like,
hey, you guys need to go.
>> He literally did this to Pisco. He
literally did this to Pisco. He
routinely and repeatedly did this to
Pisco. He routinely and repeatedly did
this to Taylor Loren. He was every
single time he replies to Taylor Lens on
Twitter, he's posting that in his chat
right
at like 3:00 a.m. He's fighting with
Taylor Loren on Twitter and he's posting
every one of his tweets back in chat so
people can go harass her. This is so
beyond mirror posting. This is like
looking at who you are as a human and
and assuming nobody else can exist
except in the way you function.
>> Harass the out of the story this guy.
>> I honestly would I honestly like that
honestly in this case in this case you
have to acknowledge when you're having
conversations that you are way outside
of the norm and that your opinion is not
worth
most people will not most people will
not tolerate that type of behavior. It's
an insane thing for the average content
creator, politician or whatever to deal
with as another huge content creator
that's actively and I don't mean like by
way of having a dis.
>> Lefty purity panels are back. Ker, you
just missed Destiny saying that Hassan
is uniquely bad because he harasses
people. Destiny got on a panel and said
Hassan is different than all of us
because he harasses people. He like
doxes people and stuff. Destiny got on
this panel and said these words
>> and one it's difficult to find the words
to even respond or whatever else but
it's directing their community to
directly go and harass another person.
That's like a that's a really out there
behavior.
>> No, it is first of all wait
I already get so many DJs in my DMs
telling the myself and not because you
told them to by way I know this not it
but just because of like just
disagreements that you and I might have
but two like tell me if this is not
true. Have you not doxed people on
stream before? Uh
well wait wait wait wait wait wait just
wait guys if you if you missed this we
covered this right when we started but
if you missed it okay what do you think
his response is oh well I only dox like
like nonhumans
>> yeah people related to I don't know who
or why it doesn't matter what your
justification is my point is that like
you've done things that I would say I
don't think that's
>> people related to like like people who
went on your stream for years people who
like went on your stream for years and
you were close personal friends with for
years, like people like that. Maybe
maybe
>> that's okay. And I'm sure you can find
out your I'm not trying to make these
things.
>> HE HE'S OFFENDED. HE'S OFFENDED THAT SOY
PILL EVEN BROUGHT UP HIM DOXING PEOPLE.
HE'S ACTUALLY OFFENDED, DUDE. He's like
actually exasperated sighing at Soy Pill
for bringing up that he doxes people.
>> What I'm saying is like if you're
saying, "Oh, well now I can never ever
ever do anything with this person
because it's a passive endorsement of
everything they've ever done." Whether
that is
>> No one even said that. No one was making
behavior. It's about collaborating with
people that are actually trying to
destroy the other people in your space.
>> Yes,
>> dude. I I actually I I I
>> like that's a very simple thing. It's
not like somebody said a bad thing and
now you're doing something. It's like
they're actively Hassan will actively
try to destroy people in the space. Like
you were on argue well not at the same
time, but Dylan Burns was on there.
Okay. A guy who we've all watched. I
think we all are personally friends with
at least I I am.
>> Destiny has absolutely never done that.
Destiny was absolutely not saying that
Pisco should be kicked off of Lib and
Learn and that the liberals should own
Lib and Learn again. The show Pisco
made. Destiny was absolutely not saying
that Pisco had was totally mind raped by
socialist women in his life like Joanna
and Straight Raid. He Destiny would
never do that. Destiny would never try
to totally slander Pisco repeatedly.
Right. Right. Right. He would never do
that. Is that Kouty? That is Crow. Yes.
I call this guy a war tourist. Okay. A
war tourist. All right. And was
regularly roasting him.
>> And then why do you think Dylan was on
it?
>> Probably because
>> uh by the way, if you didn't know this,
apparently Wick also called Dylan a war
tourist. So this is Was he really
claiming that about Joanna? Yeah, he
was. Yes, he was. He did that openly. He
fed that narrative to his chat. He
repeatedly, routinely leaned into it
over and over and over again.
Absolutely he did. So Wick also did
that. some a little bit here.
>> You wanted to talk about the Ukraine
issue because I've absent that on there
and messages despite the fact that
Hassan was on that panel.
>> You just totally what I brought up
though. I'm just saying that Hassan is
like will personally try to destroy
using personal not like these are just
>> dude. This is a level of mirror posting
we've never seen before. He's he's taken
it to another level. I've never seen
anything like this in my entire life.
He'll he'll just do personal attacks.
He'll just he won't even go after the
politics. He'll just go on a personal
level.
saying is you're criticizing me for
potentially working with him, which was
being on a panel that he was on as well.
Dylan was as well. Dylan has even more
personal beef because of what you just
described. And yet said, you know what?
I think I can do more good introducing a
liberal pro Ukraine message, especially
with all the anti-Israel [__] in that
panel. It's like, hey, look, I'm
actually like talking about other
anti-war things that matter. And I think
he did more good doing that. I would
have said was really mean to me. I'm not
going on this. I want to make it clear.
>> Yeah. But just just real quick, you know
what I mean? Like maybe maybe I'm
separating myself from Destiny here, but
I am not criticizing you or Dylan for
still working with Progressive Victor.
you do what you think is best for your
goals and things like that. I have to be
clear. If you can make me a compelling
argument why this is ultimately more
detrimental, I will stop.
>> Just let me finish, right? That that's
not why I'm here today. I'm not here to
like be convert you from progressive
victory. That's not that's not the point
of what I'm talking about. I I just want
people to understand what is happening
because as Kraut said, Hassan has
subverted that organization, right? Or
Hassan fans, right?
It's like Crow. It's like exactly like
this guy said when he said the exact
thing I wanted to hear. It's exactly
like that, guys. It's like the same.
Okay. It's like exactly like that. Um
Han subverted progressive victory
totally. Meanwhile, Han is like, "They
tricked me. They tricked me into joining
their event."
>> Right. Maybe not him directly, but
>> subverted basing that off of like I
Destiny, you know Jonah, right?
>> Yeah. like has he he is I'm very
trustworthy of him and know that he
knows the internals of this and to my
knowledge there's not some like tanky
subversion prohassan movement in this
thing despite some things you might see
that do come out of progressive victory
and are you have you been
>> grim right
>> this kraut guy is actually this grout
guy is making the look so
>> has been cheering the Russian invasion
from the start
>> waiting are you saying that Jonah has
come out and publicly said that
>> I don't know if he's public said that
I'm I'm asking if you've talked to him
about it.
>> Okay, I won't quote any individual
person, but that entire organization has
been completely and totally subverted.
Yes, every center left liberal has been
exised from that or it is excl Dylan
Burns.
Is Dylan Burns not a center-left
liberal? If Dylan Burns is not a
center-le liberal, who is? Is this not
explicitly wrong?
What What does Dylan Burns consider
himself? Maybe progressive.
In which case, I would wonder who the
center left liberals were from before.
Counterpoints. I don't Who are the
center left liberals? If Dylan doesn't
count, if Dylan doesn't fall in that
same category, who are the center left
liberals that could have existed there
that aren't there anymore?
>> Exclusively socialist and tank now. Yes,
I know that 100% true. I
>> I've heard I shouldn't even say that
obvious by looking. No, you haven't.
>> It's 100% tankies now. It's 100% tankies
now. I know that to be true.
>> Has been completely and totally
subverted. Yes, every center left
liberal has been exised from that or it
is exclusively socialist and tankies
now. Yes, I know that 100% true. I I've
heard
>> I mean I shouldn't even
>> I know that 100% to be true.
>> It sounds like Soy Pill is saying that's
obviously not true to him that he knows
somebody who is not like a tanky and
that he trusts that guy. No obvious
looking. No, you haven't. I I literally
am talking to Jonah right now like in
chat.
>> You don't know that soy pill. I'm
literally talking to the guy I brought
up right now. I'm literally directly
talking to that guy.
This is actually
Are we participating in kink is the
question really at this point. Does
Destiny just enjoy being humiliated
completely? Does he just enjoy being
completely humiliated? Does he want to
run this thing into the ground? I don't
know. Is he like like is he
>> So like whether or not that's true,
>> I got to I got to pause a little bit. He
does that all the time. He asserts
things as if they are facts without
knowing. I know he does. I know he does.
>> I'm not I'm not saying you're wrong or
lying or something. I was like I have
heard differently.
>> Yeah, Ryan Grim is on there. The that
guy the night the
>> this guy is so this guy is so far
>> tanks rolled into Ukraine. His nasty
lectures and how all of this was the
Americans fault. Ukrainians won't last
and should surrender. See it into my
memory. That guy.
That guy.
>> Well,
sorry.
Uh not so erodite hitting the paddle up.
Not so erodite is here. Okay, cuz 4v1
that was going pretty badly for some
people. So why not 5v1? Let's go.
This soy pill guy needs to be put in his
place.
Put this in his place now, Arerodite.
Okay, Arodite is about to cam up and be
like, "Look, I just got way more out of
the gym than you. I'm way sweatier than
you right now." Hey, soy pill, you think
you just got out of the gym? Take a look
at this. I actually don't know that.
I'll be right back. two seconds.
>> I I guess so. Paul, the way that I would
look at it is if you think you can do
good by by interfacing with these guys,
go ahead. But like if you turn around
and suddenly your community is like 80%
tanky, you should probably double think
it, you know?
>> Uh I don't think most if any of my
community is tanky, but we'll see. Wait,
Kylo, back me up here. I'm not accusing
you of that.
>> No, no, I you don't have to cuz I just
know it's not true. But even if you did,
um hey,
>> hi. What do I What do I tanky right now?
I would say so
>> if you have Ryan.
>> Yeah. Did you see my beautiful
you're saying in your chat I was just in
a meeting with Jonah 3 hours ago. It is
primarily taking or yes. Like so I don't
know what he's saying in your time but
yes 100%. I'm going to read I'm going to
read you Jonah's words verbat.
>> You are conflating tankies and
socialist. Socialist yes. Tanky no. It's
pro-electoral socialist.
>> It's democratic socialist. There are
definitely pro-electoral socialists and
>> oh so Oh. So, they're just totally
intentionally misunderstanding.
Intentionally misunderstanding again.
Total the same total intentional
misunder. Wait, hold on. I wasn't here
when she cammed up. I wasn't here when
she cammed up. Uhoh. Oh, I'm totally
correct. I'm to I'm Dude, I I said it
before she cammed up. I did not have
spoilers. I just knew that was going to
be the case. How do I know every Dude, I
could just
I see everything. Okay.
It's so funny.
>> It's democratic socialism.
>> There are definitely pro-electoral
socialists and there are definitely
probably accelerationists that would
love to co-op the socialist space.
>> Can you can you tell me what exactly the
point of democratic socialism is? If the
only thing you get to vote for is who is
on your firing squad.
>> Two purposes. Number
>> dude.
>> Oh, get this guy out of here. Get this
guy.
>> You can be a communist without uh having
to outline your power level. Number two,
it's for coward communists who don't
really actually hold up just real quick.
Jonah, we can bring Jonah on and ask
him.
>> I'm telling him you should come on and
clarify this, but yeah, he wants to.
>> Oh, boy.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, hey, there we go, buddy. That was my
favorite.
>> Hey, now that you uh now that you're
here in the in the hot seat. Okay.
>> I don't I don't want to I don't want to
be here for very long, but yeah,
basically I I I describe Tanky as uh
like pro-Russia, pro-China when it comes
to China, Taiwan. That is not the
position of the leadership as I
understand it.
>> That's what
you're not talking about leadership. We
weren't talking about leadership. One
tie. Go ahead. Destiny.
>> Wait. They absolutely Wait. Destiny
absolutely was talking about leadership
and stuff. It was org, right? The org.
There's nobody left in that org. I
thought I thought he actually So, he
actually made a differentiation. I
thought he was explicitly talking about
the org.
>> No, we weren't talking about the
leadership. We're talking about the
people they're working with.
>> Yeah.
>> Am I crazy? I could have sworn that he
was talking about the or explicitly
because it was like I was like, "Oh, he
kind of just undercut the point I made."
Maybe not.
>> No, no, no. We weren't talking about the
people we're working with. We were
talking about the organization has been
subverted by Hassan and his movement.
That's what was said.
>> Yeah. Or Hassan fans, right? When when
Wick said Hassan fans, did he mean the
creators? Did he mean like Crystal Ball
is a Hassan fan and she subverted it? I
think they're just trying to gaslight
soy pill in that he's totally vindicated
and they're trying to gaslight him into
believing that he was wrong. Actually,
we meant all the people. Even if you say
all the people, I still don't believe
you actually get tankies. You might have
Mike. You might I don't even think you
have Assan, but you might have Mike and
then I don't even know beyond that. Who
Who is that beyond Mike?
>> They're clearly working with tankies.
They're working with
>> Vos's audience more than it's Assan's
audience in PV.
>> It's It's entirely Bosch's audience.
>> Yeah, I figured. But Vos is a Bosch is a
tanky.
We're as close as you can be without
>> Bosch. Oh, I
listen. Bosch has thrown his hat in with
Hassan. So now we hate Vos again.
Remember when these guys were like we
love Vosch? Vos is like literally
cutting heads off of people who won't
vote Biden figuratively.
Remember when they love Vos and now oh
Vos has thrown his his hat in the the
ring with us on. Oh, we hate Vosch
again.
>> Is he watch
I I don't think he is. Does he want to
get rid of private property rights?
>> Well, yes, he does.
>> That's not what a tanky is.
>> I would say it's definitely moving.
Well, I didn't say that's a tank.
>> That's not what a Dude, it's so funny.
You You don't So, when when Soy pill
goes, that's not what a tanky is. I can
tell you I'll lay out exactly what's
happening there, right? He's basically
going, "Don't bring up this super
talking point that you did with like
straight raid and hutch. Do not try it
with me cuz I will I will expose you
right now." Like he's literally giving
her a warning. I like you. I don't want
to have to expose you, but if you try to
run down this dialogue tree, I will. If
you try to do this, I will embarrass
you. That's what Soy Pill is trying to
Please help me not embarrass you. I
don't want to embarrass you right now,
but if you're going to say, I will have
to. What a nice guy. Whoa, that's not
what it is.
>> But watch
I don't think he is.
>> Does he want to give away private
property rights?
>> Well, yes, he does. That's not what a
tanky is.
>> I would say it's definitely moving.
Well, I didn't say that's a tanky, but
it's definitely
>> one. You have said multiple times.
That's multiple times. That's a tanky.
You have said that multiple times. And
then what the do you even mean it's
moving in the direction of? Dude, that's
like saying a wealth tax is moving in
the direction of being a communist. You
you support a wealth tax. Well, that's
moving in the direction of being a
communist. Which by the way, probably
true to some degree, but also just a
thing to say because you're trying to
invoke use a label to invoke some
emotional thing that is not accurate and
doesn't actually help like further the
discussion. It's not accurate. It's not
informative. It's not helpful. It is a
waste.
>> Moving you in the tanky direction.
>> Oh, absolutely. Yeah, but that's
>> How are we defining? Have we done this?
>> How are we defining tanky then? A wealth
tax is moving in the tanky direction,
you stupid. Jesus Christ, man.
like USSR apologist like Communist China
is great like yeah ML's like Lenin is
good Stalin is good example there's
direct examples here there's Ryan Grim
who ever since the first Russian tanks
rolled in has been on Russia's side
>> ban this guy this guy now this guy now
give me an example you have him on
>> do you want me to speak or I I don't
work for
>> Hold on but she's literally said
outright multiple times that that is
what a tanky is the gotcha is well do
you want to get of private property
rights. Well, actually, how will you
ever do that democratically? People
won't give them up. People won't give
them up willingly. What do you do then?
Doesn't have to be violence.
That's She's literally run that exact
dialogue tree multiple times.
>> Okay.
So, so yeah, I got I I got from that. Um
but uh like for example they're
supporting cat Abu Abu Gazawa or how you
pronounce it in the uh Illinois 9th
question mark congressional race. She
had some like position paper come out
that was like
>> in the event of
figure it out in the event of uh in the
event of a Chinese invasion of Taiwan
that the US should actively support
Taiwan with weapons and whatever. Right.
>> By the way, I'm not even joking. It's
dude I've been saying it for a while and
Madag Glacius is sit on this too.
I I think people are just underestimate
I I would tell all of these people just
be like anti-Israelite. Just be
anti-Israel and liberals and we're like
down with you. I would wait like the
Israel thing rises in a lot of people's
estimation in terms of something they
have to vote against because of this war
because of how it's affecting the global
economy. if you are but because you will
expose very quickly how many of these
people are single issue voters on Israel
and are just trying to bully you out of
it. Okay, I'm not joking. They are
literally single issue voters or single
issue I guess lobbyists on behalf of
Israel, right? And they are straight and
they're just trying to bully you out of
having the same position. They will not
support any candidate, right? And it's
like this idea that the pro Palestine
anti-Israel position is only a communist
position is complete.
It's actually the liberal position. You
should say, "Oh, as a liberal, I don't
really support giving weapons to this
country so they can constantly oppress
and and destroy the way of life of
everybody around them." That's the
liberal position.
All right.
And that's what this that's what a ton
of this is about. And then you get a
whole Well, you just think it's all
about the
I don't want it to be about the just
literally no support for Israel. Make it
so nobody wants literally just give give
the left no support for Israel. You'll
get the entire left and you lose
nothing. And it's THE MORAL POSITION.
YOU win in EVERY POSSIBLE WAY. YOU'VE
SET YOURSELF UP PERFECTLY.
It's it's so perfect. How do they not
see it? That a lot of tankies online.
They were like like including Ryan Grim
who your your who I agree is is much
closer to Teny uh than the average
socialist or whatever but they supported
GA and they were like these tankies this
does not change our opinion of her at
all. We agree with her position on
Taiwan. That is what I would see as if
they were a tanky organization and from
the leadership they would not have that
position. I'm not specific people but
the lead but the leadership I know like
I'm not specific people but I know the
leadership is pro-electoral and
anti-tanky very explicitly.
>> But what I socialist she lost her
primary and then Hassan Per ripped into
her because Oh, that's because you
supported Taiwan.
>> Also I what did Hassan [__] on Cap for
supporting Taiwan?
I I somehow don't believe that to be the
case because he would sort of I don't
even I don't see how you could possibly
like think that because wouldn't that
just be Well, hold on. What is RIP into?
Cuz I could have sworn that
he still said to vote for Well, he
didn't like the position. But this crowd
is saying that after the election
happened, Hassan went live and was like,
"Oh, cat, she didn't like Taiwan or she
she didn't want strategic ambigu or
yeah, she was opting out of strategic
ambiguity." Well, no. He's saying after
Hassan did this and I'm like, well, he
spurred her before, wouldn't he look
kind of hypocritical to to go and like
be like, "Oh, actually, you totally
yourself over."
>> I feel like there go ahead big names. I
feel like it's the Israel thing that
they care more about and she was quick
to ID some APEC funded uh dark money
group that was against her as well. So,
I'm pretty sure Israel is the the big
motivating thing for a lot of these
>> totally weird,
right? Like he's an anarchist,
>> dude. It's it's actually crazy.
They're they're trying to make it so
that being against supporting like a
genocide, being against supporting
apartheid, being against supporting war
crimes is the anti-liberal position.
When people are trying to convince you
of this, just look at them, you know,
look, they're obviously lying. They're
obviously like motivated by something
else. With these people, I don't know if
it's that they're paid. I do believe it
is far more the idea that if they flip,
Hassan gets to go, I was right. Vosch
gets to go I was gets to go I was right.
Like all the people they hate get to go
I was right. That's probably what keeps
them from doing it right is the ego way
more than getting paid or anything like
that. Spitebased it is spitebased
politics because again Madaglacius said
this perfectly. This is like the best
issue that you could reach out to the
left on and it's the thing they all
want. So why aren't you doing it? It's
the math is so easy. Just give them that
you get all of the left like
enthusiastically on your side. Hey,
we're going to cut off aid to Israel. We
actually don't think it's appropriate to
aid Israel. That's the position. We are
not going to aid Israel until they show
in terms of elections, in terms of their
actual decision-m that they are going to
start fixing things that they are going
to change the way they act.
>> So simple, man.
>> Libertarian or whatever.
>> I don't quite know what to do with the
comms mostly because they've just like
abandoned reality in a way.
>> Instead of like anarchists do actually
>> instead of fixating on the weird labels
like here's the thing is will they
support Democrats in the general? I do
you do you like how this shifted
entirely away from how Soy Pill was
correct. Soy pill gets to extract zero
concessions. He was totally correct in
everything he was saying. This guy came
on supported everything Soy Pill was
saying. They are all wrong. 1v6 or
whatever. Soy pill is correct but sorry
1v5 actually 1v yeah 1v5. Soy pill is
correct but none of them none of them
will ever let him get that out. another
pontificating on how all anarchists are
actually
>> that's that's like the main motivation
thing
>> I mean literally
right why that's how many years ago was
that I don't know why that's relevant
anymore
>> tequila sunset basically soy pill came
on and explained why he doesn't think
like an organization that works with his
evil and then he was kind of winning
that argument cuz kraut and short fat
taco and so Destiny joined because he
had to show everybody that actually soy
pill is totally wrong and then he
humiliate iated himself and then Eerite
joined and I mean I guess if you want to
say the the tanky equals wants to
abolish private property argument if
that's humiliating then she also
humiliated herself and now we're in some
weird state where everybody's trying to
basically obiscate that soy bill won soy
totally won
>> well that's how many years ago was that
I don't know why that's relevant
>> maybe you won't do it anymore well the
reason I could bring you hold one time
literally said I think he wouldn't vote
for Gavin Newsome in general because of
his position on Israel Palestine.
>> Oh, okay. Well, that's stupid.
>> Um,
>> I This is the Trump stuff. Wait, do you
not say the minimizing the minimizing
language? Wait, they're like, "Oh, this
is what you want to use. I'll
>> No, no, no. You're saying it's not
words, but it's like it's indicative of
your state of mind cuz you keep doing
this over and over and over again where
anytime it's a bad thing, you're like,
"Oh, I guess
indicative of your state of mind. Yeah,
he finds you performative and obviously
you've come in and said actually you
can't separate the art from the artist
with facade and he's actually evil
because he harasses people. You Destiny
have come in and said these things. Yes,
you are cringe and he's trying his best
not to have to deal with DJers again
flooding his DMs telling him to kill
himself. So he's trying to stay away
from just saying you are obviously a
performative who doesn't mean anything
you say because he doesn't want the
smoke.
>> It's kind of bad. Oh yeah, that's not
great. Oh yeah. Okay, I guess. Like is
that a thing that
>> because I'm more aligned with people on
this side, but it's like if you're going
to be anti-electoral to say I'm not
going to vote for Gavin Newsome in
general, it's like yeah, you're not
really part of my movement then. Sure.
>> The the the point is wait and see wait
and see if if Pave is going to do
exactly that. And if they do criticize
them, call them Tanky, call them call
them, you know, no better than the DSA
or whatever. The idea the idea is that
you can take your headwake, but the idea
is that there is no proof that when
there is a competitive race, which there
will be this year, and you will see them
support the Democrat in the election in
a competitive Senate race, competitive
House races, you will see that happen
this year.
>> If you don't, then I'll I'll join you in
ADP.
If I may,
shut up.
>> Shut up. Shut up. Okay, let me finish my
thought and then we got some
>> Don't Don't comment on how Erdite's
trying to act like a child. Don't
comment on how she's adopting the Emmy
strategy and is going to act like a
child
is I don't so much care what the
leadership says they are. They are
consistently promoting overwhelmingly a
group of people who are anti-democrat.
Right. Wow. What's the difference
between then and now? Uh Wick was
getting a thousand bucks. Okay. That's
the difference between then and now.
Wick ain't getting a th000 buck anymore.
So, of course, he's got to make this
point now, right? Wow.
>> Who are you?
>> Anti-liberal.
>> I just went to their account. They're
literally retweeting Kat Fumadora. What
reason do you have as a serious
political organization to repost
Kumadora out of all people?
>> It's I'm guessing that has something to
do with the idea that he had a clip that
was compelling for the point they wanted
to make.
>> California is so compromised.
>> Yes.
>> What the is this? only one US Congress
member does not take Apac money that
what that's like a blue state that's
like entirely going after dem Dem what
the
>> and and so they can say all they want oh
I support like in the general we'll
support them but if you spend the whole
time just trashing Democrats all day and
then the day before the election or the
week before the election you're like
okay guy just uh vote for the Democrats
it's cool right quick
>> entirely to my point of
>> the the thing that gofumodor here's a
gatumodor retweet Israel is now seized a
larger percentage of Lebanon's total
land mass than Russia was taken from has
taken from Ukraine since its 2022
invasion. The latter was immediately met
with the international uproar and
unprecedented multis sectoral sanctions
while the former is barely even
mentioned. Wow,
that I can't believe you you'd retweet
what excuse is there to retweet gapumor
in well apparently they agree with this.
Apparently they agree with this seems to
be the case. why I'm willing to work
with such an organization if they do
what they did, which this is literally
the like that inspires me to like move
stuff and criticize people like for not
doing like this in the general in runoff
elections in Georgia and Senate races.
Okay, let's go put money and people out
there and make sure we win this. If
they're not doing that this year, I'm
out. That's why I'm trying to do stuff
like this. And so like the idea that
like an alternative to this,
>> I would absolutely jump on that instead
because they are half of these people
they promote are people like you said
Kraut and other people are bringing them
up, people I don't like, but half of
them I do like. I do like Rakana. I do
like Lark and I like a lot of these
people. We don't have to guess. We don't
have to guess if they're going to if
they're going to still advocate for the
person they didn't like because they No,
no. They did this already. They
advocated for someone else in the
governor race in uh was it New Jersey?
They they really did not like uh was
Mikey Cheryl. And then they still made
tons of calls for her after she won the
primary. So, and that's not even in a
competitive race. That's in a race that
like we probably were going to win. So,
they're doing that. They're going to do
it in other races.
>> Okay. I think there's one thing. So,
there's a
>> So, I I understand what you're saying
guy who's involved, but I really hate
Hassan. I really hate progress. Like,
sorry, maybe not progressives. I mean,
progressives. Yeah, I I hate these like
left-leaning people. And so, I'm going
to make some point right now that's not
going to make any sense. It's going to
be totally basedless speculation or
totally like me leaning into to tropes
that have been basically fabricated from
the ground up. Okay? To point out that
these people hate democracy. These
people would be the same as Trump.
>> Couple things to keep in mind. Number
one, the incentives, right? We need to
be aware that anytime there's a
progressive more socialist camp within
the Democrat party, the main competitors
that they will have in any type of
election is in a blue state where they
can run against Democrats. A progressive
is almost never going to be running
against a Republican. It's exceedingly
rare. I think the only time we've seen
states go from Republican to
>> I'm curious what what was Terico doing?
What is Terico doing right now? Right.
Isn't Terico didn't he just win a
primary to make a challenge in the
general or sorry in the midterms?
Isn't he a progressive that's going to
run against some candidate in the
midterms? Platiner is the better
example. Oh yeah, sure. Maine. Maine's a
purple state. Yeah. No, I know he'd beat
Jasmine Crockett. I'm saying that he is
now a progressive candidate going up
against a Republican. I assume in Texas
that's going to actually be a thing. No,
>> like socialist is Alberta with the NDP
and that was probably a fluke, right? So
the incentive
>> wait of election is in a blue state
where they can run against Democrats. A
progressive is almost never going to be
running against Republican. It's
exceedingly rare. I think the only time
we've seen states go from Republican to
like socialist is Alberta with the NDP
and that was probably
>> why would you say states and then say
Alberta
is your problem? Also, the Alberta thing
was because the rep the conservatives
split the vote or the centrist party
split the vote like that. That's a it's
obviously not a progressive place. Okay,
>> probably a fluke, right? So, the
incentive structure that we have to
remember for progressives is their main
competition is Democrats. It's us,
right? And so
>> also that can only happen in what do you
call it? That sort of fluke can only
happen in a parliamentary democracy
where you have multiple parties. That
never happens in the states, right? Like
both both sides will have their
candidate for the general election. That
does that literally structurally can't
happen in the states in the same way.
>> I'm
>> well I mean I guess in Utah it
technically can. In Utah they can run
big Mormon third party candidates.
>> Not opposed to people working with I
don't really care that much. I think one
of the things that we need to be aware
of when we're working with socialists is
we have to be very clear that we're not
in the same camp. If they want to take
away private property rights and we
don't, we can work with them on certain
aligned goals like getting a Democrat
instead of a Republican. But we have to
be aware at all times that when we're
working with them, we are conferring
them power and there are certain powers
that they would want to utilize that we
are diametrically and vehemently opposed
to and most moderates that would vote
for us are vehemently opposed to. Uh so
I think that this is something really
really important to keep in mind.
>> So easy. You know, you know what? Say it
solves everything. Just slip on Israel.
That's it. So easy. So easy.
>> My I guess to speak to progressive
victory, I think the biggest issue
that's happened here is that it in the
federal election was dominantly floated
and supported by liberal content
creators and social spaces dominantly
being Destiny's community, but a couple
of other communities as well that were
also liberal. And it so quickly flipped
hard on them and kind of denounced them
and pushed away liberals in a way that I
think is extremely distasteful. And it
is exactly what we should expect from
spaces that get captured by socialists,
which is why you can work with them, but
you need to
>> the So this is totally ahistorical. It's
totally and they're calling out some
sort of capture. Progressive Victory was
always a leftist organization. It ran
stuff before Destiny joined. It tried to
bring different groups together. It was
running. It was paying Vosch or was
collaborating with Vosch. I believe in
the 2022 midterms. No. Maybe even 2020.
Was it Was that what Vosch ran with for
the 2020 election? It's possible it was.
I'm not 100% sure, but I know
Progressive Victory was doing stuff with
Vosch, Riverboat Jack, a bunch of far
lefties on Twitch way before they did
anything with Destiny. Then they were
like, "Well, we have to make sure these
groups don't fight. We're going to try
to build an organization that gets these
different groups on the left, left of
center, to work together to get
Democratic candidates elected right
now. What is the big change that's
happened? Destiny and Aerodite are
anti-working with other people on the
left, explicitly the group that
progressive victory always was. So why
is it shocking to them that when they
start advocating for cutting these
people out of the Democratic party
entirely, why are they shocked when
progressive victory comes back and says,
"Yeah, you how is that shocking? What
part of that is shocking? It's the only
possible thing that could have happened.
That is the only thing that would have
ever happened here given any
understanding of progressive victory,
the progression they've gone through and
who they are as like who their owner is,
who they are as an organization.
It is obviously what was going to
happen.
>> To be aware that you are basically in
bed with the devil and you need to be
very cautious about it because if you're
fundamentally opposed to certain rights
being removed like property rights, they
are opposed to you necessarily.
>> Any other questions for you before I
leave?
>> Not for me.
>> All right, cool. Bye.
>> Anything else? Love you.
2022 midterms. Let's take a look.
Progressive Vic,
these were their their team members for
progressive victory. Mafia Jinx,
Caseyron, Adept, the best, the Surfs TV,
Aspect Decor, John. Every single one of
these people are adjacent to Hassan,
right? Literally, every single one of
these would be people that you would say
are adjacent to Hassan, except maybe AB
Starill. Maybe not AB Stariller anymore.
Okay, maybe not. Maybe not. But
everybody else of the people I can see,
this is 2022.
This is who the organization always was.
It's just totally adept. Yeah. I'm
guessing this was like the people who
were friends around
like Hassan, like that lefty group on
Twitch, right? Yeah, obviously. I just
It's crazy to me that people just try to
totally ignore this. Wait, John Ayola
was there. What the hell? What the
>> how many Israeli shekels did you get
paid for this showing? Ah, he's gone. I
knew he would run away into the tunnel.
>> Of course he did.
>> Into the tunnel with he
>> Yeah, it's it I think Erdike kind of uh
hit it on the nose. Um the socialists
aren't competing against MAGA. They're
competing against Democrats for the same
space. They want control of the
apparatus, the institutions that
Democrats have built and set up. And
they they can't get it from
this was never ever if you guys believe
this, why did you ever work with
progressive victory? If it's so
transparently obvious that none of you
believed this because you worked with
progressive victory in the first place
and the entire premise was we're going
to bring all these groups together. It
literally was like a dinner where Vosch
Destiny and Keles were sitting at the
same table. This is a totally new belief
that didn't exist before. None of you
sincerely believe this and you haven't
given me a reason for Hassan changing at
all. The the only thing I see here,
Hassan is the same. Hassan is the same
as he ever was. Okay? He's advocating
for the same things. He's the same guy.
The only differences I see are one,
Hassan sub some sometimes retweets
substance, somebody who doesn't like
Destiny.
And to me, if you think that's crazy
after the amount of Destiny's and
Destiny and his friends have thrown at
Hassan, I don't know. I don't know what
to tell you. Okay. And two, it's become
very clear that Hassan had the morally
correct position on Israel from the
beginning. And you would have to
apologize and or like out and say,
"Yeah, actually, no, that is the morally
correct position.
rather than than say I don't like a
genocide. I don't like I rather than say
I want to hold Israel responsible in
terms of I think they owe something back
to these communities that they've
destroyed. Rather than saying that, you
would rather say, "Oh, well, I just I
these people wanted to destroy us from
the very beginning. These people always
wanted to destroy us. They wanted to
destroy our space." This is an argument
formulated entirely to deal with
anti-Israel sentiment to deal entirely
with anti-corporation sentiment within
your party. You are abandoning the
values you claim to stand for the
everyman, the working people, right? To
stand to like shoulder-to-shoulder with
billionaires, I guess, right? The people
who fund Third Way, and say proudly, uh,
actually
Democss, they're actually bad now. We We
hate Democss now, guys.
It's crazy. It's wild. Republicans, but
they can from Democrats and they will
>> I think that might be true in some blue
states, but I'm not I'm not convinced
that this is true overall. I've um I had
conversations a while ago with uh with
someone who works in like um a policy
think tank. Um he probably hates to
bring this up um or him up. Um, so he
told me that there's a chance actually
for the first time in decimates
>> to turn a substantial amount of Utah
blue
>> because the Mormon community at this
point just completely disgusted with
Trump.
>> Just the complete moral debolter and
everything. And there's a that more and
more Mormons in Utah vote blue. And
there's a chance that you could
potentially even flip the state or
something, but you're not going to flip
that state with someone like a Hassen
[__] So it's it's varies from region
to region. You have to go from district
to district, from state to state, look
at the what local voters want, etc.,
etc. If you run a Hassan Per candidate
in Texas, in Utah, you're just inviting
yourself to lose. I mean,
>> I guess we'll see to Rico, right? It
seems to be totally insane to me the
idea that like Terico is the losing
candidate in Texas, but okay. All right.
Yeah, maybe there's a socialist who
stands a chance in a place like Maine,
Massachusetts, etc., but just they they
want everything or nothing.
>> They don't strategize everything or
nothing.
>> Here's here's my question because
obviously Kyle, I agree with the idea
that like these people's opponents are
Democrats. They're running in mostly
safe blue districts because they're
never going to win in the competitive
one. Is there a liberal alternative
group that excises people like this that
is doing the same stuff that I am
attracted to, which is mobilizing online
audiences and communities? No, because
it always gets co-opted by people like
you who always say we should work with
Hanky's a socialist.
>> People like me, dude.
>> It gets co-opted by people like you up
here doing a
>> co-opted by people like you who always
say we should work with Hanky's a
socialist.
>> People like me
in 2020. That's what inspired me to join
it, dude. Come on,
>> dude. I
>> there's two things. Number one, liberals
is dominantly especially so like yes,
Destiny, you're this like liberal
alternative like dark space that's
always been like woke and whatnot, but
the dominant liberal actual like space
has been filled with a lot of academic
types who have been too afraid to stand
up to socialists because they're very
cowardly. Liberals just like want to
stay in their institutions and be safe
and they got the best polic.
>> You give any examples of this or are you
just going to say this thing that
I do we have examples? Can we get
examples?
>> And I love liberals. They're very
cowardly, right? And so what they did is
they shook hands with the socialists
because the socialists were cool. And
then they said to everyone, "We're just
like them." And they were lying the
whole time. And that's a really big
problem. So they did get it co-opted,
but in part it got co-opted because
liberals are terrified of supporting
each other and we're terrified of off
socialists to lose that
>> terrified of supporting each other.
Where why do you think this literally
all you have to say? I I want Aeronite's
commitment now that she will support any
liberal. Okay, Aronite, tell me this
explicitly. Somebody asked her this
question. Will you support a liberal
candidate who advocates like vehemently
for defunding Israel entirely? No
American tax dollars to Israel. Will you
support a liberal candidate who says
that? That's the big question.
>> Just just to kind
smidge differently. Um because before
2016, it wasn't like this as much. There
was some, but what happened when Trump
won the first time is that liberals
legitimately got scared. They thought
they had it in the bag, right? They
thought Clinton was going to win, right?
They thought, "Okay, we have a formula."
Obama had already won twice. We know
what to do. We know how to handle these
things. We have a great pitch. The
people love it. We are going to win. And
when they didn't, it shocked them. And
they made a deal with the devil in a lot
of of ways because there was these
socialists, these kind of tanky types in
the wings who'd always been kind of
trying to get power in the space. And
they said, "You know what? You guys
failed, but we we could win for you."
and we let them into positions of
influence and we started listening to
them. But then other than that, I agree
with what you said. A lot of liberals
became scared to kind of stand up to
them and now we have a problem. Right.
Why? What do you mean? It seems like a
bunch of people have been perfectly
happy to stand up to Hassan or other
socialists for years now.
Where where was this in 2024? This lack
of a spine. Where is this? Why are you
just making this up?
Give me the evidence. Give me the
evidence. All of you people told me that
Camala doesn't support all of this
transit. All of you told me Biden had
moved past all of the woke. Where where
is that argument now? When I when people
brought this up in 2023, 2024 before the
election, you guys all went, "No,
they're not woke at all. These people
have no power anymore. No, you don't
understand. These people were you just
lying for Were you just lying?
What? Wasn't this the argument? Oh, well
these people don't have power anymore.
They've actually lost all of their power
and we don't support any of that woke
anymore. We're not like that. We're a
different party. No, no, no. When has
Kamala ever talked about trans issues on
the on the campaign trail? What has she
ever done that? What has she ever done
that guys? I got that was brought up
multiple times to me. Now all of these
people have totally abandoned that
position.
>> Huge problem.
>> A hu a huge problem. And the answer
isn't clear. Like I the answer isn't
never working with them. Obviously
>> it sounds like it is.
>> I think it is. No, it is the answer. no
other world where anybody would be okay
with a group of people who are
explicitly saying, "We want to come in.
We want to co-opt and destroy your
movement. We want to do everything we
can to funnel more people to our extreme
side and we're not going to support you
in the general."
>> And that's
that's okay. I guess that that sounds
like what Hassan said. The whole thing
where he's like, I I do think you should
take the moral position on Israel and I
will support candidates and like
ultimately I do think that the outcomes
for people are far better with
Democrats. That sounds like Yeah,
actually we're going to come in and
explicitly destroy you and never work
with you and and like literally just lie
to you to your face.
>> Okay, that sounds that's about the same
candidates in the general for
competitive districts. I'm not talking
I'm talking about Bosch if he says the
same thing about News. I'm talking about
PV that is putting this money behind
mobilizing people to get Democrats
elected.
>> Liberals should abandon PV if I'm being
frank. Like that would be my position.
>> Please give me an alternative
organization that's doing what they're
doing. I will join if you had a better
one. That's what I'm saying. What what
is what is your prescription for someone
like me who is like I don't want to I
don't like these people. I don't
>> they don't give prescriptions soy pill.
Why would they give prescriptions?
What? That's that's falsifiable. They
just want to rent without doing any
work. Why would they give you a
prescription?
>> Want to work with them. However,
>> be doing or what is what is the thing
we're looking to emulate or whatever?
>> Uh a collectivized group of
>> banking, canvasing, door knocking.
>> Did they do that much? Wait, did they do
that much once they became like
tankified?
>> I don't know what the milestone of when
that happened was, but if they're not
going to do it, but Jonah says there
already plans to do said thing. They
just did this in a governor's race.
That's what he brought up. Like, it
sounds like they're still doing it.
>> They've been doing phone banking since
before liberals joined and after
liberals have been pushed away, just to
be clear. And when I say
don't like, well, you have to work with
them. I mean, you do have to work with
some socialists. You just do. I'm not
talking about tankies. I think the fact
that people work with Hassan and the
fact that Democrat candidates are
literally slobbering at the mouth to go
on Hassan's stream is a huge part of the
problem is
>> well there's a lot of Democrats
worked with Vos in 2020 in a project I
agree with right
>> yeah but that was one that was before um
first of all that was when Vos was
willing to like kind of be more
electorally minded number one number two
if you remember back in those days
remember when I did the panel with Vos
and Emma Emma literally said this is all
a waste of time we have no influence
anyway and now she's super gung-ho and
excited cuz she's got a bunch of other
tankies on panels with her and now
they're excited to drive like uh
influence in that direction. So I mean
like we can go look at all the people
invited like these are all like pretty
hardcore like single issue Gaza genocide
like both sides of the same type voters
like all of them.
Do you see how it just sneaks in? It
just sneaks in out of nowhere. All of
these people think that Gaza is a
genocide.
Why would that matter to you? Why why is
that in being included in this
conversation? Why do you have to keep
smuggling that in? By the way, I pointed
out because I believe that's where the
position comes from, right? I think
that's what they're actually hiding is
they don't want to go against Israel.
They they want to keep taking the same
side they've always taken. But I could
be made to look very stupid if they
wouldn't stop bringing it up every
single time in the exact way I expect.
It'd be so easy to make me look dumb on
that. But they can't. They just can't
leave it alone. I said most of them. We
can look at all the people on the panel.
Most of them are probably like that. We
can go back and and recount up all the
people, but like like 90% of that PV
thing was like about Israel. Like that's
almost the only thing
>> very Israel brain and I agree with you
there. But it's like okay if I'm going
to look at like the majority report and
disagree with like a lot of not a lot
maybe like 30 to 40% of like Emma's
takes and still say hey these people are
still electoral. These people are still
promoting good policy. These people are
still trying to get the general like
promoting Kamla. They're going to
promote Gavin even if it happens. Like I
don't agree with Matt. Matt's like super
tanky but like Matt's the guy in the
back who doesn't even have a camera.
Like do I not do I just write these
people off completely? And if you if you
feel if you feel like
>> I'm not going to tell you what to do.
>> If you feel like you agree with about
like 50% of what Emma says, then you're
probably on that team. That's like the
side that you're on. But then I just
don't know why you either don't
recognize it or you're also on that one
or you want to see most people in media
right now. And if you're like agree with
true, but I want I want I want I want to
hear from I want to hear from Kraut cuz
uh he's a guy invited on
>> No, please. I need to address this cuz
like Okay, Destiny, I I know you've
moved further away. And I think Sam has
moved a lot further left in ways that I
don't like. But like Sam Cedar of
Majority Port, like you respect I I
respect definitely as someone who like I
think is very well read and analyze
these things mostly with a pretty level
head. And if it's like, all right, if
this guy's promoting it, I usually agree
with most of this person's stakes, if
not
the majority report. No, not at all.
Completely on Sam.
>> Yeah, 100%. You can't have that many bad
people around you for that long and then
like have none of the like
Yeah, that's just insane. Yeah,
>> dude.
Wick, why are you pretending you're
concerned about having bad people around
you? It's like radiation.
You are a ghoul. You are literally a
smooth You are literally the opposite of
a smooth skin right now. You are so You
are insanely radiated. Okay, you're
glowing.
>> Yeah, it's a it's radioactive, guys.
>> It's wild to me that you
>> Sorry. I mean, a ghoul from Fallout,
obviously. Okay.
>> Like I I think if anything my view of
this is similar to your p you know your
description of how this has gone which
is Sam has taken a bunch of positions I
don't agree with over the years and has
moved farther away from where I would
agree with him back maybe 2018 time. But
to say like hey I used to really respect
you and now I have 180 I don't agree
with a single thing that you're talking
about or promoting. I just think that's
insane. Like that's not I don't I want
no Soy pill you don't understand.
Ultimately it all comes down to they're
MAGA and they will destroy democracy
immediately. Okay. It's a massive threat
right now and we need to talk about it.
We need to cut these people out because
we definitely have choices to make with
regards to electoralism.
Dude, it's so funny that they do the
abundance thing. Oh, just run the
candidate who works best and they
totally ignore how these candidates
could work best in a bunch of different
places.
>> I'm going to give it to to Kraut and uh
and I got to use Russian real quick. So,
I'll be right back. So, Kraut, go ahead.
>> Kind of lost my train of foot. Sorry. Uh
yeah. No, don't worry. Where was I? I
since you brought up Sam Ceda, he also
did this thing of blaming the Russian
invasion of Ukraine on NATO expansion
and blah blah blah blah.
>> No, dude. I these people actually make
me somebody like this guy. He makes me
He does so much harm to the Ukrainian
cause. He does so much harm to the
Ukrainian cause. Okay, it's it's crazy.
Listen to this guy. So harmful. Shut up
about Ukraine. shut up about Ukraine. I
I like Ukraine. I sit here, I cheer when
they sign the weapons deal, when I get
to watch them blowing up in a cool way.
I love it. And then I have to listen to
this guy and I'm like, "Dude, you you
actually are so embarrassing." Like it
has nothing to do with this
conversation.
Nothing at all. Blah blah blah. He also
did that thing.
>> Um America, all of those people are like
they hate the West America. Everything
that is related to it is like evil and
terrible. I think I I think what I
wanted to tell you is I see no
obligation for people like the way all
of this transpired this takeover of
progressive victory and the first thing
they did right was not like you keep
talking about as if this was a policy
organization but the one of the main
reasons why we're talking here certainly
the reason why I'm why Wick invited me
in here was because the first thing
these people did was turn around and
attack their enemies. The first thing
they did.
>> That's not true. Dude, I'm sorry.
Destiny repeatedly attacked them. Why
are you Why is this all framed around
Desi being a victim? He repeatedly
attacked them. That's how this started
on Twitter was Destiny them.
And not to mention Desi is like the
antithetical thing to what that
organization is trying to do
>> was going after their personal
inventors, etc. It's the only thing they
[__] do all the [__] time. And
when you keep saying this thing where
you say, "Oh, you need to work with
people anyway, even if you have
disagreements." This isn't just about
disagreements. These are people who like
talk about
the way they engage with us is not a
disagreement. It has the goal to have us
annihilated. Their goal is to annihilate
the center left, to annihilate the
center in general, to drive it out of
the political conversation. And as
someone who is in the center, I see no
reason to engage with someone like that.
No reason to work with someone with
that, even if there is some sort of
supposed common goal. And I can't even
think of what the common goal supposedly
is right now. Okay.
>> Every time they've given this guy time
to speak on this panel, it's been a
massive mistake. It's been just a
massive mistake every single time this
guy has spoken. Literally nothing of
value any time he's opened his mouth.
>> Captain, this is a question for you. And
>> can I pose a question? Just cuz I barely
talking.
>> And I know
>> this is the one time I love that going
to be here. And I pray she does the same
thing she does to any small creator. She
totally ignores what they just said and
cuts in with her thing and basically
tells them you you're stupid. Don't
talk. Okay, cuz this is the one time I
will actually appreciate it. Usually
it's like I'm I'm kind of annoyed cuz
the other person's like genuinely trying
to just get like off the ground as a
streamer, but this guy's a and he needs
to be he needs to be casually shugged
shrugged away in the way only Aerodyite
can do. Okay.
>> Oh, I know my mic is off. Um I'm just
genuinely curious your guys' thoughts
cuz I don't think I actually
>> Oh, you're just genuinely curious. I'm
just like legitimately genuinely so
curious. Really,
>> you know the answer and I don't think
it's obvious that they're
>> hands out. Hands on head. I'm just
genuinely so curious. Hands on my head.
Hands on my head. Right now, guys, I'm
just genuinely so curious. Hands on my
head.
>> Is a super clear answer. When you guys
think about like how to party with when
I I look at the right for example, like
MAGA, there's a lot of like unions that
>> just spoke a whole bunch. Okay. I I I
like Aerodite for this one minute even
despite that. Okay. because she just
totally shifted the conversation away
from anything Kraut said. Just basically
was like, "You are worthless as a human.
You have nothing of value to contribute.
Shut the up forever. Here, I'm taking it
in a different direction." The one time,
okay, thank you, Ardite. Thank you,
Ardite. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Even though they're actually very
opposed to one another and they have a
lot of issues, right? And I understand
MAGA's and we all hate them, blah blah,
all the things that you guys need to say
like, "Yes, we hate MAGA." The question
that I would have is essentially is
there some level of like political
unification on the left of like
activating the left that has to happen
where we do have to essentially break
red to some degree with people who are
enemies. My question would be but should
you just keep in mind that there are
enemies? Are there certain people that
we can work with that are in like the
hate look at the Mar coalition look at
the Mara coalition they never emphasize
their disagreements
all themselves. They defend all of
themselves no matter what. They're
always at each other's backs and they
all support the candidate. That's the
difference on the left. These people do
not support the candidate. LIKE
>> WHAT IS THIS INSANE FICTION?
WHAT WHAT DO WE CALL THE MANGA civil
war? What the is Tucker doing? What the
is Candace doing? What the [__] is
Fentes doing? What in the are you
talking about? You are insane. You have
nothing of value to say anymore. Oh,
they never talk about each other. Shut
up. They are literally having a schism
over what issue, by the way? What issue?
the same issue the left should be having
a schism over but you guys refuse to
even entertain the conversation. Okay,
that's the issue. Holy man,
>> you can't have like there's just no
serious political commentator that was
not
>> I didn't even I didn't even get my water
because I had to come back and and talk
about that totally thing that was just
said. They don't talk about each other
at all, guys. They never go after each
other at all. They like to not do that,
but unfortunately when they have major
issues, they do need to resolve them and
there are schisms that form.
Holy [__] Like valiantly advocating to
vote for Kla Harris in in 2024. Like
anybody who was not on that page like
shouldn't have a voice in any left
leaning movement unless they're like 12
or something, right? Right. Unless we're
a literal child. Like there's
>> Wait, I totally forgot. The biggest
streamer on the right wing is actively
saying, "Do not vote for the Republicans
in the midterm. Vote Democrat."
the biggest streamer on that. Maybe
second biggest or third biggest after
Candace and Asmin Gold. Wait, top three
streamer on that side. Vote Democrat in
the next election. These people have you
over Jesus. Okay, now I agree with that.
Now my question is if I'm someone who's
trying to emulate the type of stuff you
did in 2020 and say, "Look, now I have
an audience. Now I have money. Now I
want to do something and actually get
Democrats elected and there's this
organization that I should not work with
because they have people like that in it
or work with people like that. What do I
do with all that time, money, and energy
if I can't form my own organization
without the money?
>> I got a potential answer for you. Go
ahead. A buddy of mine uh says that
there is a alternative to progressive
vic.
>> Guys, have you heard of Z Cohen Sanchez,
infamous liar and incompetent? Well, if
you want something like progressive
victory, look no further. We've got
another incompetent organization for you
that will do political organizing. Let's
go. And he wants to give a quick pitch
for it. Right. So, I'm going to bring
him on and uh he can maybe pitch it to
you.
>> Sure.
>> Blow Trace.
>> Oh, boy.
>> Yeah. What's up, Wick?
>> Yeah. You got a you got something to
pitch to Buddy Soyfield cuz he's asking
like he's asking for alternatives here.
Go ahead.
>> Yeah. No, I I would say go to digital
groundgame.org. It is a organization run
by a lot of us who actually did the PV
program in 2024 and we're looking for,
you know, no shade or flame on TV
necessarily, but looking for more of a
center-left uh way to do similar kinds
of that work. mobilize online community,
streamers, kiddo camping and stuff like
that. It's pretty awesome.
>> Only question needs to be asked. How
involved is SEO this time? That's the
only question. It's the only question
you should want to ask. How involved is
SEO? Is he involved? No. Well, well,
that's 90% of the work gone.
>> If you want to check it out, digital
groundgame.org. We've got a Discord
where everything happens.
>> Is this a Z thing?
>> No, it is not. It is. I know. A very
unfortunate name. It is. Yeah, it's
completely different. It's a very
similar. Z is National Ground Game. Ours
is digital ground game. They're very
similar names and we love Z. We're great
friends, but it is a totally different
thing. We're all about organizing online
communities, whether that's getting them
to go show up to their local things like
we organize lots of people to go out to
no kings or get involved with local
Democratic parties or more big things
like canvasing events, canvasing houses,
things that you've seen from sort of
this online space previously. So, if
anyone wants to get involved, we're
always more than happy to have more
people.
>> Add me on Discord, send me a message
like I Yeah, this is a better
alternative. That's what I'm looking
for. That's what I've been asking for.
But
>> yeah.
>> Yeah. Well, thanks Flow Trace. We're
going to let you go now. appreciate.
Have a good one.
>> Bye.
>> Go ahead.
>> Uh, so should our only relationship with
anyone I guess where's the line of where
we would say at this point this person
is shown to be so costic that we can't
is it not getting behind the dominant
candidate?
>> I'm going to draw this line. I'm going
to draw this line.
>> Does the candidate have to be Gavin
Newsome or are we
>> It literally doesn't matter who the
candidate is. None of that was a
consideration for people on the right.
Every single person there you cannot
name even the centrist people were
supporting Donald Trump. Nobody was
>> Are you talking about people on social
media now? How you talking about
candidates?
>> It could be. No, no. I'm saying I'm
saying
>> No, not you. Not you. Not you. I mean uh
right. Sorry.
>> I'm asking drone association associ.
>> Yeah. I'm asking which social media
creators. Yeah. Specifically.
>> Okay. My goodness. So is DG trying to
get people back in Destiny's orbit.
Yeah. That's explicitly what the
original America tour was about. That's
why they joined up with America. It was
to try to get Destiny uh I I believe it
was trying to get Destiny like some more
profile again. And I believe Aerodite
like explicitly tried to recruit former
orbiters to it. So like it's it is
that's what this would be as well. I I
assume I assume you go with the name
digital ground game because you want the
overlap with DG, right? That seems
pretty obvious. Maybe that's totally
maybe that's totally up of me to suggest
and they don't actually associate with
Destiny. I wouldn't personally
uh if you're trying to build something
that lasts, you should not attach your
opinion to the you should not attach
your reputation to this person. That's
all I'm telling you. Okay? They will
always put their reputation above you no
matter what. Do not attach your
reputation to this person. It will your
organization up. Although if it's called
digital ground game, then maybe it's
just straight up Destiny's thing. So
hard to say.
>> We should be associating that.
>> Okay. The line that I've drawn is that
everyone who in any capacity promoted
bad empanada can burn in hell.
>> Oh, sure. I I think that's good. But the
issue is that's probably not actually as
as far as Destiny is drawing it because
there's probably a lot of people that
don't support bad panata. It includes
a but there's well sure but there's
probably a lot of people that don't like
bad empanada that are somewhat like
still about like being anti-American or
like are very negative towards G.
>> Didn't Destiny retweet bad empanada like
yesterday? Am I crazy?
Didn't he didn't Destiny retweet bad
empanada i.e. promote him like yesterday
or the day before? Okay. Oh. Oh well
cool. What was bad and empanata doing?
harassing somebody.
Oh, okay. Cool. Wow. Multiple times
Destiny retweeted him multiple times,
I'm being told. What? Yep. And Loader
Box's Discord are rooting for bad
empanada against Asan, too. Kind of
openly. Yeah. It's sort of interesting
how it went from this guy tried to kill
us, he's total scum to actually we love
this guy in like two seconds. This guy's
total scum. We hate him. Actually, he
he's awesome. LET'S GO BAT A BANANA. OH,
very cool, man. Super cool.
>> Gavin Newsome or any other strong like
>> I still have to encounter that person.
Another line I would draw is Ukraine.
Everyone who is on that's probably
because it's more closer to me. Everyone
on the wrong side of the Ukraine issue
can go to hell. And um basically how you
treat your opponents.
>> Wait, hold on, hold on,
hold on. What positions did bad empanada
have? What did bad empanada do that they
really disavowed and didn't like? And is
bad empanada turned over a new leaf?
Because the only thing I think that
switched up for B and Panata was who he
was going after. And it's like, oh, we
are totally fine promoting this guy so
long as he's going after who?
Like if you just want any indication of
the obvious spitebased politics, right?
You know what I'm saying?
Oh, we totally support bad empanada now.
Well, wait, why? Well, actually, he just
hates Assan now, so he's awesome. Don't
you understand? What? Don't you
understand? He hates Assan now. He's
awesome. I mean, one of the greatest
elaborate on that bit.
>> Well, one of the greatest things about
being a liberal is that it's it's
universalist. It's seeing the humanity
in your opponent. Seeing the humanity
and those you disagree with,
appreciating disagreement. And when you
look at like the Hassan sphere and the
general sort of vicious toxic leftist
sphere around him, they obsess only with
enemies and how to annihilate their
enemies. That's not like anyone who
thinks in that way. Anyone who engages
politics at these
dude I dude how how do you maintain a
straight face as he says this on this
panel? How do you sit here anybody who
who focus on politics in terms of
annihilating your enemies? Those people
are terrible and I would never support
them. And you just see like Soy Bill,
Wick, Aeronite, they're all just sort of
like their eyes are glazing over. They
have this like performative like haze
they fall into. They're like don't say
it. Don't say it. Don't say it. Don't
say it. Don't say
>> these ways. Who only draws the
distinction between enemy and friend?
>> Nah.
>> So, I agree with that. I agree with
that. I think that that's a really easy
line and I'm completely comfortable. The
issue is that my suspicion
>> are you completely comfortable with
that? Is that is that how it works?
>> Is that there are more people that
probably Destiny is suggesting that you
don't work with, I could be wrong, that
wouldn't fall into that category that
are maybe less costic. But if you like,
for example, typically my one of my
biggest lines is do they want the
eventual erosion of private property?
Then I don't really think I'd throw my
>> Damn it. Soy bill got up right at that
exact time. Listen, I try not to think
of it in terms of like if they're spite
based and just try to destroy people, I
won't hang out with them cuz that would
be financially devastating to me. So
what I try to think is do they want to
abolish private property? Right? Do they
think that like the the moral imperative
sorry the the requirement to work the
requirement to consistently give away
hours and hours of your life every
single week so that you can just live is
that morally wrong in some way. If they
think that then that's the kind of
person I can't work with. But if they
just like attack people and try to
destroy them completely well no I'm
totally down with that. So let's try to
focus in on what matters. Do you hate do
you support the abolishment of private
property at from here to any point
indeterminate in the future? If yes,
then you're a terrible human being.
>> My team, the issue is that
>> why only private property? What? What?
You have this funny thing with that.
What is it with you?
>> Okay, WE LOVE THE BIRD AGAIN. WHAT the
This is like a weird You keep saying
this weird thing. Do you have like a
personal vendetta that you're engaging
with engaging in against like one
specific person? You keep saying this
private property thing. It's almost like
you're just obsessed with private
property. Is that like a standard for
somebody you are obsessed with and hate?
Do you Do you What? Why do you keep
doing that?
>> It's a pretty good rule of thumb. It's
usually a pretty good rule of thumb.
Usually people who are going to be
anti-private property just like are
going to be fundamentally like pretty
open to tanky stuff. I just like find
it's a good rule of thumb. That's all.
>> Okay.
>> Immediately fall back entirely from
saying that it's indicative of
something. It's just a good rule of
thumb, guys. It's just a good rule of
thumb.
>> Policy I'm very opposed to.
>> Oh. Uh Digital Ground Game is the
political group that works on the
pragmatic papers and does online and
offline political activities. It is
basically the political arm of DG. Okay.
Yeah, that's what I figured.
>> Okay.
>> Cool. Hey, we all have these. Um, I I
might have a
>> By the way, I broadly wouldn't even like
I'm probably never going to go to the
digital ground game stuff and like if
they're canvasing for a specific person.
I'm probably never going to like mock
the idea of them canvasing, right? I
would mock the idea that anybody would
get involved with that and tie their
reputation to Destiny, but that would be
it. That'd be all even more kind of
lines. But there's a diff I I just also
want to make a distinction between a
difference between like anyone who wants
to vote for my candidate, I will take
your vote. It does not matter. If you
want to vote for them, cool. Uh but when
it comes to working with you, I have a
much higher bar than
am I willing to collaborate with you?
And I'm not just talking have you on the
same stage as me because I can have
people I disagree with all the time and
I do have people I disagree with all the
time that I would never work with, but I
will engage with. But if you want me to
collaborate with you and to go to your
event to promote your event to um
basically be a figurehead or be part of
whatever thing you got going, you do
have to be liberal in nature, right? At
least for me. And uh yeah, that that's
my line. I don't know what everyone else
What about you, Mr. Mr. uh Soy Pill?
What are your lines? Where would you say
I'm not going to work with this
organization?
>> You have to be liberal. Is that what he
said?
Hold on. Um, I need to basically be a
figurehead or be part of whatever thing
you got going. You do have to be liberal
in nature, right? At least for me. And
uh, yeah, that's my line. I don't know
what everyone else What about you, Mr.
>> Liberal in nature? Okay, that's uh,
>> Mr. uh, Soy Pill, what are your lines?
Where would you say I'm not going to
work with this organization anymore? Um,
I think definitely one of the lines, I
don't know if it's the threshold, but
one of the lines is if you're unwilling
to support the Democratic candidates in
the general because it's not your
preferred, you know, sock democ
candidate, whatever the trying to push
in the primary, then you don't support
us. You're just using us to support your
candidates and then dipping immediately.
I think Assan clearly has indicated that
he would do that clearly like based on
all the rhetoric. So that's someone like
if it was his or then it's like, well, I
know you're not going to help him.
>> Well, I think soy pill says that. I
would I would just put it to Soy Pill
that it's pretty obvious Hassan would
support those candidates. He's just not
willing to say it now. Like I I'm sorry.
It seems pretty obvious to me from the
things Hassan has said. I think Hassan
actually just went back and said like
did he not basically like on the Gavin
comment? I thought he did. I thought he
basically went back and said like
obviously I'd probably vote for this
guy, but like I'm just trying to, you
know, I'm trying to make the point that
I don't want to commit a vote right now.
I don't even want to. No, I'm pretty
sure he did. Ramandas is saying he did.
Or Yonko says no. I thought he went back
and just basically said, "Yeah,
obviously I'm gonna I'm gonna vote for
Gavin." Matt saying he did. Yeah. Yeah.
I knew he did because I remember being
like, I don't think you had to on this,
but okay, I guess.
>> Plus, when it come push comes to shove,
but it seems like Pave is going to do
this or at least has been doing it and
if they stop doing it, that's definitely
a line.
>> What does it mean if Pave is willing to
do it? But if 80% of the people they
work with aren't, doesn't that just mean
when it comes time for PV to rally
support in the general, they're just not
going to get any support for it?
>> If that's what I see,
>> dude, it's what which one of these
people has? By the way, there's the same
line and that's how you By the way,
dude, it's it just becomes so obvious,
right? What was the issue that all of
these people stood on and said, "I can't
vote for this. In good conscience, I
will not vote for somebody who is okay
with this." What was it? It's pretty
obvious, right?
You flip that one thing and all these
people are totally on your side. Read
the yellow dono. What is liberal culture
right now in America? Wearing zipper
hoodies and 2013 techware fighting
obsessively to defend Israel. Tired of
playing catch-up? can't develop
political stars anymore
>> happening then yeah
>> by then it's too late when you keep
saying if that's what is happening by
that point it's too late you have to
evaluate
>> well like if you were
to do something else then yes
>> no I'm saying if we if it was 5 months
working with PV and then by the very end
of like we're coming up to the general
for the primary or for the midterms and
it's like oh sh these guys aren't
backing anybody else I've made a mistake
at that point it's too late
>> what have I lost by contributing energy
and time to them
>> by contributing energy and support to
people who are actually pushing for
Democrats has to win in general,
>> right? But if they didn't win and if
they're not going to help my candidate
and if there was no better alternative
to me, ultimately it was a fruitless
effort, but I haven't like made a choice
that me. It was just, oh, it turns out
you're you're disingenuous. I'll never
work with you again. But if it was I had
to choose them over an or that was
actually going to do what I wanted to
accomplish, that would be the last
opportunity.
>> Okay, so just is the thing is that there
>> he's going to Dude, it's it's going to
be it is really hard to go down this
road of realizing
at the bottom of it all. It sucks. I
hate I hate even agreeing with the
concept. Okay. But at the end of this
road, you're going to realize
that unfortunately they're the ones
making it about Israel and that's really
their line. And that's like what this is
all about. They're trying to talk about
communism. They're trying to talk about
all these different things to get away
from the one thing they want to keep
supporting.
The one thing you could give away and
get the entire left on your side like
immediately. It's It's so funny cuz I I
hate to It is like thought terminating
almost, right? But that is like their
line. And when they make fun of you for
it being your line, don't get fooled.
They're just trying to flip it. They're
just trying to project it's their line.
Look at the polling. Look at the
direction it's going. Okay? Just flip
flip on that one issue and then run
total capitalists. Okay? Run abundance
libs who don't want to support Israel.
Nobody will have a problem voting for
them. So easy. There's no other
conceivable place where you can put your
time right now besides an organization.
>> Until this DG digital ground game thing
was brought to my attention, there
wasn't a clear path forward here. And
now it seems like, okay, yeah, if it's a
zero someum game between dedicating my
time and energy, I'm definitely picking
the one where I'm 100% sure they'll vote
for the Democrat and push for the
Democrats and has an audience that'll,
you know, promote that Democrat in
general, then apparently this one who
you're skeptical of, but I have yet to
see evidence that they won't do that.
Well,
>> there's just evidence of them doing it
across multiple elections. So there's
totally there's evidence of them doing
it across multiple elections. You
actually have way less evidence that it
will happen with this other group other
than the fact that Destiny says so,
right? Or Eerite says so or whoever's
involved says so. You have actual
historical evidence that PB will support
those candidates. So I don't I don't
know.
>> What was the example that guy gave
earlier about what was it? Let me look
at this race that Jonah gave.
>> I don't I don't remember the the which
state it was the governor's race in. No,
but he talked about phone banking and
and to me phone banking just isn't
enough.
>> I don't know. That's me, but whatever.
>> What are you eating?
>> I'm curious. Is there anything? Can we
find Is there anything on like PV's like
Twitter or anything about them promoting
this at all? Like is this anywhere? Did
this actually happen in a meaningful way
or
>> the
>> Yeah.
>> New Jersey Governor, right? Are they
talking about Mikey Cheryl? Did Pave go
out and canvas for Mikey Cheryl? Is that
what they're talking about? Maybe this
is an example that was brought up over
and over again like this. S H E R I L.
>> Okay. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Easy,
>> easy. Yeah, surely on their Twitter
account they would have some
support of her. Correct.
>> I don't know. That's what I was asking,
but I mean I can check. It's okay.
>> Apparently, you can't search on Twitter
if you're from a bench. So, sorry.
>> New uh NJ uh New Jersey governor. Their
preferred person lost.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Shut up. Hold on. Shut
up.
>> Decision desk HQ projects Mikey Cheryl
to win the New Jersey governor election.
OUR FIRST VICTORY OF THE NIGHT.
PROGRESSIVE VICTORY. # ELECTION2025.
WOW. SO, they're celebrating it at the
very least, right? Be cheers all around.
Okay. Well, they're doing their best.
Oh, and five months ago, Progressive
Victory endorses Rep. Cheryl for New
Jersey governatorial election next
month. Join our phone banking efforts
here. Oh, so they did both. Oh, cool.
Oh, cool. Wow. They like Mikey Cheryl.
They love Mikey Cheryl.
Isn't that awesome? initial one was
>> I don't
>> just one tweet really just one tweet
guys just one tweet really
>> yeah but uh
>> like
okay so they had a progress my I think
I'm understanding this they had a
progressive candidate they preferred
that person lost and then they made
calls for the Cheryl Still
>> Mickey Cheryl is the New Jersey governor
Mickey Cheryl by the way just it's like
a weird thing to notice just how like
this space is so warped it's like a
weird lens why did the content totally
stop because Destiny was googling a link
like Destiny didn't believe what the guy
said who was from Progressive Victory.
So the content totally stopped. It's
just like the lens of this is so odd to
me now. Now that you're looking from the
outside looking in, it's like wait, why
did you all stop talking?
>> Yeah. Do we see any promotion on their
site? Do we see any promotion on their
socials? Do we see any promotion on
this?
>> Well, if they legitimately did phone
banking, they might not have a ton of
promotion. Um, unless we just think that
they're
>> I can point to you promotional material
that they put out for um the primary
candidates, right? Like so.
>> Keep talking, Wick. Keep talking.
>> By the way, it took me 5 seconds to find
that. Five seconds. Although I knew who
Mikey Sher was.
>> Primary candidates that were running uh
recently in the election, I think in
Chicago, I believe it was.
>> Um, can we point to promotional material
of a similar nature to Mickey Cheryl?
>> I promise you Destiny's found it at this
point. I promise you it took me two
seconds. Desi's 100% found it at this
point and doesn't know which direction
what argument he's going to make. Now
he's trying to figure out what argument
he's going to make right now that he's
been proven wrong categorically. He's
like, "Wait, which one do I say like
isn't enough? Do I try to show like
other progressive candidates and how
hard they push them and say, look, it's
like not even that much. How do I change
the conversation to to like basically
pivot from the point I was making to one
where I don't look? That's what this
pause is. Okay. He's trying to he Dude,
I'm telling you, he's trying to
formulate a different argument. He found
he found these the phone banking
immediately and he's actually just
trying to formulate a totally different
argument or trying to figure out how to
not look totally moronic now that
obviously they did phone bank.
Obviously, this is the case. He's just
trying to discredit and discredit it in
any way he can. The question was, did
they actually promote or do anything for
Mikey Cheryl?
They did and he found it and now he has
to go to a different argument. He's
trying to figure out, okay, where do I
go in the conversation?
>> What uh what do you mean about like
leftist about tankies?
>> Just a totally bad faith actor. It's
actually embarrassing
>> about working at what point would you at
what point all these things?
>> My my reference point here entirely is
history. Like I think I told you before
that my dad used to work with
anti-communist dissident in
Czechoslovakia in the 1980s. So a lot of
my views of who these people are and how
they operate is shaped by like
how like the way the communists came to
power in Czechoslovakia was in 1948
through a coup in which they overthrew
the government and the way they gained
the power to get into government was by
consistently lying to the social
democratic and the liberal parties in
Czechoslovakia. They told them we're
democratic. We're trying to achieve
liberal Marxism. We're trying to do this
and that. We're moderating ourselves.
They deliberately moderated themselves
to get elected into power to come into
government and then they
>> I every single every single contribution
built up police for everyone was called
of communistic.
>> So I am
>> power in Czechoslovakia the first people
they rounded up and had murdered were
all the liberals and so I am seeing just
FYI I am seeing them promote Mickey
Cheryl in
>> I will say it's a little it's a little
sarcastic. They literally say it's good
enough after the preferred person person
lost. So, it's definitely not a rousing.
>> Wait, what? They literally say it's good
enough. Wait, where do they say? Like
her, it's good enough. Oh, the
promotional.
Like her, it's good enough.
Yeah, I think they're leaning into the
idea that like, hey, even though we
didn't support her, right? Isn't Wait,
isn't that leaning into well, we didn't
support her in the primary, but like
her, it's good enough.
Isn't that exactly what you want to
agree that like, hey, we should go and
actually vote for her.
It's not lying. It's not disingenuous.
It's not saying she's your preferred
candidate. Saying, "Hey, go vote for
her. She is good enough."
>> Support. Um,
>> it's good enough.
>> I don't know. Definitely would not have
been how I promoted an event, but uh
that's just me. I mean, so it's there.
We got to give them their flowers for
that.
>> It is there.
>> He's just been thinking about how you
spin this now. I don't think there's any
way Soy Pill could like understand this
at all cuz it's like I one I am used to
watching this person flounder. But two,
I
and when he goes back and watches this,
I just want Soy Pill to review and see
that like he was correct again. He's
totally correct again and they are doing
anything they can to try to spin it as
him being the wrong person or having
done something wrong. He's answered the
questions, every single question
perfectly. Okay, I'm sorry. When has
Hassan or his community ever done this
to like a coworker in the same way where
they are literally in a like 5v1
conversation trying to convince you that
everything you're doing is wrong. When
has that ever happened? This is a cult.
This is a cult. Okay. None of these
people are operating in good faith even
remotely.
>> Good. Go ahead.
>> Did um did the PB people did they ever I
understand that I'm persona not did they
reach out to like Josiah or
>> dude totally different argument. Hey,
could you concede that you were totally
wrong? You were completely wrong. They
went out and they phonebang for this
candidate. They endorsed them and they
celebrated when she won. Are you
serious? Well, no. Correct me if I'm
wrong. Did Pavey reach out to like
Josiah? I'm sure he was messaging Josiah
saying, "Hey, did PV reach out to to be
a part of this?" Right.
>> BTC or I don't I don't know anything
about their workings. I have no idea.
>> I could. Do you want me to ask? The
person I'm asking didn't even work with
PB on any of these things. They just
used to.
>> Well, sure. I'm just curious if they did
because I because almost everybody at
that I think was like a recognizable
like Democratic party hater left like
super lefty person
>> except for Mr. Beat and
>> and Dylan and Soy Pill and I'm sure some
of the Democratic Party candidates are
not Democratic Party haters, right? I'm
sure.
>> Neils, I think basically.
>> Sure. Yeah.
>> What are your plans going forward?
You're you're like all Americans except
for for for I can't pronounce your name.
Sorry. Um
>> Devodite.
>> Aerodite.
>> Dev and Aerodite are both not American.
>> Dev was Canadian too actually. Okay,
that was
>> I'm the least American immigrant. Okay,
I get sunflowers.
>> What are I can't tell you what to do
with organization when it comes to uh
the midterms
>> engaging like I I'm not American. I can
I can [__] on these people all I want
and I'm going to um in particular as
long as they keep talking
>> Americans can do that too. Actually, it
turns out that's the great thing about
America. They can do that all they keep
talking about Ukraine. That's my plan
for the future. Oh, so what
>> I mean this is a good question which is
like the tactical versus the principal,
right? And this is the this is the
actual tension I'm trying to sort out.
What's tactically effective versus like
principally effective? I think
>> there's no tactical effectiveness here
because the people that are claiming to
be tactically effective don't actually
think the other side is that bad. Like
the SW seems like he's like 85% in
agreement in terms of what they're
saying or he doesn't seem that huge of a
deal
which I not Hassan. All right. Like
these are very different people. The
fact that you I I can't believe if you
go watch like the majority report now I
feel like you'd agree with like 78% of
what Sam Cedar is saying. If you
disagree with that, like I like I think
we should go test it. Like maybe I'm
wrong, but I I can't believe that you
wouldn't.
>> Well, one of the issues with this
argument is that if even even if we said
that we agree with 70%, if the 30% that
we disagree with is fundamental to like
liberalism and like the things that we
value as like the
>> it's not though. It's literally not. And
you explicitly get told that, hey, it's
not fundamental. We're not trying to
erode rights. We're never going to do
something that's anti-electoral. We're
not trying to take over. Right? You get
told this over and over and over again
and you refuse to accept it every single
time.
>> It's not even fundamental to liberalism.
We we can't move away from ideology.
It's just it's a one-way street. That's
the issue. All of these things are one
way streets. They will never ever ever
ever ever come out and ardly support
like a moderate Dem in the general. Like
a lot of these people
>> um Sam might maybe, but whatever.
>> Just nothing you're saying is correct.
You literally haven't said a correct
thing on this entire panel. How are you
a guy people respect on the internet?
How what has happened? You've said
nothing correct. Everything you've said
has been wrong. Literally every point
you've made on this panel has been
horrendous dog.
>> Is completely and totally destroyed by
all the people around. Dude, when there
was that election, the series of like
special elections, it was like six
months ago. I thought that Emma was
legit on stream when all the moderate
dems were winning because you could tell
how hyped they were to see all these
Dems lose because they weren't as wacky
far left as they wanted them to be. Like
this.
>> You mean the Mumani victory that they
all were out celebrating together? You
mean the Maldani victory where they were
literally at a party in New York City
that Meldani threw celebrating that
massive win for their coalition? They
were literally WE WATCHED IN FACT, I'M
SURE THIS GUY REACTED TO THE PARTY. NO,
DIDN'T THIS GUY REACT TO THE PARTY.
Literally Hassan [__] Medi Hassan,
Emma Vigant, like Sam Cedar. I watched
them all. They were all at this party,
weren't they? I thought they were all at
that party. Was Em was on stream and I
didn't see the clip, but I like that was
the night Montani won. So many people
were psyched. That was the biggest
victory the coalition has had since AOC
was elected. Girl, it seemed like she
had to like triple up on her pros act to
survive that night. I'm not even joking.
She was so upset. Like these people are
not
>> Okay, if that's true my 7030, but to be
clear, I know they don't like moderate
dems, but I'm pretty sure they'd support
them.
>> You can't It doesn't It like
>> It doesn't work that way.
>> This is It's Dems, but I'm pretty sure
they'd support them. You can't. It
doesn't. It like
you can't. It's just It just
You can't. It just It This is It's This
is Don't work to have because everybody
knows I'm
>> Dude, hold on.
>> You can't It doesn't It like
This is It's This is Don't work to have
because everybody knows that I'm
intuitively correct. So, I don't know
why I'm expressing this. I don't
>> Everybody knows that I'm intuitively
correct.
Guys, don't you all know that I'm just
intuitively correct all the time? Don't
you? Everybody just knows that I'm
intuitively correct. Why do you argue
against me? Everybody knows that I'm
like correct automatically
ontologically. Like why? Why argue? Why
are you arguing with me, guys? What?
What?
Kylo sitting there just like, "Yes, I do
know that. Yes. Yeah, you are right all
the time about everything." Yeah.
>> Because I'm bad. I genuinely don't get
it.
>> You do because I know you apply this
lens of thought to anybody else. I know
you wouldn't. If somebody says, um, I
want singlepayer healthcare. This person
is only pushing for a public option.
Okay, we're going to fight it out in the
primaries, but if I, you know, if we
just can't come to an agreement, you
know, I'll support him in the general.
That's a position that is believable
that a person can take and can advocate
for their audience. If your position is
this person is pro genocide, they're a
pro genocidal Zionist, ethnorreligious
supremacist supporter, pro genocidal,
proaparide state piece of, there's no,
it doesn't matter what your words are,
like you guys would have used all these
arguments against the neo-Nazis in the
past. Oh, we're not racist. Dude, do you
see how the first argument that comes
out once again every single time? Every
single time. Right. I I want to talk
about anything else. I want to talk
about literally any other topic, but
just take the morally correct position
first. Right? take the position that's
not on the side of the country that
dragged you into this war, that's
destroying the global economy, that
continues to exacerbate every possible
turn, and that is not on the side of the
country that is destroying the way of
life of everybody around them. So
simple, man. So simple. It's so easy.
But actually, guys, they all say it's
like really bad to support this country.
Yeah. I wonder why. Oh, we're not
anti-semitic. Lol. Because we said it.
We can selfid not being this thing. If
you spend the entire time attacking the
left from the frame of like their
genocidal apartheid supporters there, it
doesn't matter if you you pay lip
service to supporting them in the
general, it doesn't matter.
>> Wait, if I say if I say that I think
that promoting genocide in Gaza, but I
think it's absolutely imperative that we
vote for over Trump, is that in
congruent position?
>> If what
>> if Kla Harris is pro like you know
destroying Gaza and genocide based on
the policies that she's promoting and
that said, I think it's imperative that
we vote for over Trump and do everything
in our power to stop Trump because it's
100% going to be these functionally
congrent. What
is what?
He's literally making it immoral to to
be against Israel. He's literally making
it immoral to not want Palestinian kids
starve to death. You're actually the
total piece of cuz you're pointing out
these these Palestinian kids are
starving to death. You're actually the
bad person. It's you.
This is beyond shameless, man. It's it's
so shameless. And I don't think he's
getting paid. I do think this is
entirely derivative of Hassan is bad of
he hates Hassan. He knows he would have
to agree with Hassan. He'd have to say
Hassan was right if he switches
positions. So he can't and he won't.
That is all it is
>> because you know what you're because how
the [__] you going to vote for somebody
that's pro genocide? That's an insane
position at that point
>> because it's impossible to look at the
like totality of an America and its
policies around the world and say I'm
going to purity test based on one thing
and recognize that there are better
options no matter how bad you
>> literally but all of these people Ryan
Grim and Emma and all these other people
is literally what they do.
>> Isn't this like a solvable question
though? We just need
>> So that's already been answered right
that's already been answered. The answer
was hey
if I felt the organization was doing
that I wouldn't be a part of the
organization. They support the Dem
candidate. They have done so. I've
proven it already. By the way, remember
Destiny brought up, did they really do
that? He looked it up. He was
categorically proven wrong and then he
pivoted away from it and never Soy pill
never extracted concession because it's
a 4v1 or 5v1 conversation. Okay. But he
was categorically wrong. So now they've
gone back to saying, "Well, uh, Ryan
Grim's like that." I don't even know if
that's true. By the way, I don't know if
I'm guessing Ryan Grim would have liked
Kala Harris. I'm sorry, not liked, but
would have stomached voting for Kla
Harris despite her Gaza position, right?
But maybe not. Maybe he is against it. I
think that's dumb, by the way. I think
that's dumb because Trump is obviously
going to give BB whatever he wants. And
I I hope I pray that Kamla wouldn't have
gone to war with Iran, but I don't know.
I'm pretty sure I'm like 95% sure on
that still. Okay. Anyway, so it's
obviously a coherent position. I
>> need to know like to what extent is the
audience of Sam Cedar and Emma Vigaland
will they basically fundamentally always
refuse to vote for like the broader
party or are they going to gripe? And
I'm not
>> We already did the Hold on. We already
did this. We already have seen this poll
for Hassan's audience. Overwhelming
majority for Kla Harris in the 2024
election. Overwhelming majority of votes
for Kla Harris. We've already we've
already done it. And that's your worst
example as apparently. Not saying that
the griping and complaining again
because all that matters to me is t is
tactics, right? Which is making sure
that the left wins all of the upcoming
elections and all these sort of things.
And I agree with like kicking a lot of
these people out of group. I've been a
pretty staunch like kick the far leftist
out. The question is tactically, for
example, if you're a canvasing group,
okay, so you're a DGA and you're in
Illinois canvasing for some moderate
dems. What if there is a socialist
chapter locally that is willing to
support you and canvas for your
candidate? Will you work with them or do
you cut them out?
>> This doesn't happen. I don't know why.
Like I don't even know if these people
were
>> ask hypothetical.
Why would you ask that stupid question?
Destiny is becoming that which he hated.
Destiny is becoming
Kelly Jean. Oh no, he can't he can't
answer a hypothetical. He can't answer a
hypothetical. What the
>> willing to Didn't the DSA pull their
support from Amdani?
>> Let's
go support general people. It's like
it's like like it's it's fighted.
Oh, did the DSA support the retract
their support M for Mani? Didn't all of
the creators you're currently about not
retract their support and were totally
psyched about Mum Donnie winning? Why
would why would you now pivot to the
DSA? Why are you pivoting to a totally
different organization out of nowhere?
>> Probably does happen some of the time,
right? That
>> Oh, it did not. So, that didn't even
happen. So, he answered the hypothetical
with something that was a lie.
>> I don't think so.
>> They will show. Yeah. I I I think in
even in the federal election, we had a
number of people that came out that were
like socialists who were still willing
to get in behind.
>> No, we're talking about like the bigger
figures. We're talking about the leaders
like I'm sure the liberals can get these
people in.
>> No, no, no. Not like that is always the
answer, right? Oh, well, if you show me
a bunch of like some of these leaders
like Bosch, by the way, who you guys
have been on, Bosch has been vehemently
blue no matter who in the general
Republicans are onlogically evil. You
could never accuse Bosch in a million
years of being light on Republicans or
equating the two parties. Okay? You
can't do it. You literally can't do it.
But they're still arguing against Vosch.
Oh, Vosch is a total tanky. Vos is a
total piece of Vos was blue no matter
who the whole time. It's just it's
crazy. And no, not Bosch though, but
like the other leaders like Emma Vigler,
like like Hassan, right? It's just
always going to be no no quite like
that. Apply my just so story. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no. Don't give me
counter examples. look at the exact
thing I'm saying and say I'm wrong.
Well, no, you're giving like one example
that isn't representative of the entire
hole. Oh, okay. Not like that. Not like
that. Well, I don't even know if what if
soy bill just calls this out. I think
you guys are giving examples that are
not representative of the hole because
you don't actually have an argument like
progressive I already showed that
progressive victory really did phone
bank for for the moderate liberal
candidate in the general sorry in the I
guess it was a special election, right?
the candidate they didn't want. They
they went out for her. They they sold
well they didn't sell the farm for her,
but they they went out and they canvas
for her. They sorry, they phonebanked,
right? And then they celebrated when she
won. So, it's already been proven that
it's not representative of the whole and
that Soy Pill is a part of an
organization that is f focused on
electoral outcomes. The people who are
litigating their petty, spiteful,
personal grievance are here. They're in
the call with you, Soy Pill. It's not
Hassan. It's not Bosch. It's not any of
these people, okay? And I hope I just
pray he sees it
>> involved. Sure. Because some some of
them will because the actual people the
the audience themselves are not as
radical sometimes as some of the content
creators or are willing to support
another candidate.
>> So then is there benefit of are there
some content creators that from being
anti-America that essentially could be
utilized in such a way to pull them
towards liberal causes that would be
tactically beneficial for liberals? It
does that exist?
>> No.
>> Whatever trade-off you're paying there,
you're you're losing it to the whole
like having all of your conversations
held hostage by the same tired
uh anti- anti-billionaire corporate
Dems. Both sides are the same anti-
genocide Gaza talking points over and
over and over and over again.
>> Andals actually get their [__] together
and start making major movements and
start making major waves and having
bigger political media figures that we
can actually get behind and work
together. I'm all for that. The question
is tactically as we're building that
thing. Is there going to be a point in
time where you do get soy pill on
>> Oh, we will we will be doing this
substance. Absolutely we will. This is
very fun. I enjoy this a lot. I I always
like think about like, okay, how is this
how is this movement going to do?
Because like
they seem to have moved past the
reputational hit from Destiny to some
extent, right? And I'm always thinking
like, how are they going to do? And then
I I I'm cuz I'm concerned that they're
going to get really big and then
continue to harass me or my channel,
right? And then I actually tune in and
watch and I'm like, oh, this is
embarrassing. Like, this is just sad to
watch. Like there's no way this survives
contact with the outside world. Right
there. It's not built on anything. It is
just built on spite for Hassan. It can't
survive contact with like a broader
political movement at all. It is just in
this one narrow space where Destiny has
built a cult over a decade that it could
possibly work. And it's barely working
here. when when he made the argument
earlier, the compelling the incredibly
compelling awesome argument of um I
don't even know how to argue this
because I'm just intuitively correct.
That's incredible, man. Amazing.
>> More leftist spaces
built because all of them are owned by
tankies that everybody's willing to work
with. So can't even get off the ground.
>> The problem is is we have a limited
amount of time, energy, and resources to
spend. And if we appeal to the Emma
VMON's audience or to Ryan Grim's
audience, for every person we might get,
right, from appealing to them, we're
gonna lose 10 who see us appealing to
them and are disgusted by it. These
people are a cancer. They will
>> It depends on what you mean by appeal,
right? Cuz that's implying that I'm I'm
saying we have to like yes man their
crazy policy.
>> Well, they won't work with you
otherwise. Well, I don't know if that's
necessarily true for every single like
what at should we start trying to should
we start a pool and just try to figure
out at what level of disapproval for
Israel will these people flip? Is it is
there a number if it if it truly becomes
a 9010 issue for the entire Democratic
party? Will they flip? What do you guys
think? They have to eventually. If it
becomes bad enough, they have to
eventually. But like they've sort of
they've gone out on their their life
raft and they have no other no other
island. Okay.
Is Israel is the only land in sight.
They got nothing else.
>> Leftist essentially contact. I just
don't know if that's actually true
>> with that new law today. Israel is sunk.
Are you talking about the one where
Bengavir is trying to pop the champagne
that they're allowed to kill all of
their prisoners and Bangavir's in the
Knesset popping champagne open?
DUDE, HOW DO YOU GUYS PULL OFF LOOKING
SO insanely evil? It's so crazy. This
guy brought champagne to them
determining that they could kill
Palestinian prisoners. Yes, 100%. That
happened. That is a real thing with news
pins. That is Wow. I didn't notice the
newsp thing. We will cover that story in
a little bit. Maybe. Okay. Oh, the
champagne video might have been old.
Maybe. I I don't know, man. I don't
know. Hey, maybe I'm propagandized. I
didn't think so, but we'll check it out.
It's so funny because currently this is
a rhetorical pivot from Dems. AOC is
considered to have a good record on
Israel and she'll shoot down amendment
uh any amendment that would strip Israel
defensive weaponry from the from the US.
Yeah, exactly. Oh, the defensive weapons
thing is very very goofy to me. We need
weapons to defend ourselves. Why are you
striking Iran? Don't we have the right
to defend ourselves? I I see I see
what's happening here. I see I see how
that is. I I see it. I would assume that
that's true for the large ones. I would
just grant you that, right? But I'm
asking for like the minutia. What if
you've got a 120k leftist account that
is willing to get behind the Democrats
in the general election and is willing
to talk with you and you don't have to
couch out everything? Are are we able to
>> I have to see that first. I I'd have to
see that first because that is not
something that is out there right now.
>> I do not see anyone out there who's
willing to like in that space conceited
even a millimeter.
>> Can you think of one?
I'm just praying that some liberal
candidate somewhere in the world goes,
"Hey, I could be like I could be like
pro expansionary housing policy. I could
be pro
I could be pro business, pro like
business grants, pro subsidies to big
business and I can also be against
funding Israel." Oh my god, that's a
that combination works. It's not like
inherently a communist belief that that
Israel should be sorry that Israel needs
to not be funded anymore. It does
doesn't mean you're a communist
automatically. Roana, that might be
Roana. I'm hoping more liberals will
figure that out. Roana is more
left-leaning than just a liberal though.
Roana does believe in like increasing
taxation cuz he's in the district with
all the billionaires and they literally
apparently tell him we should be taxed
more.
>> Off the top of my head.
>> No, but I don't consume leftist content
so I don't That's a problem. Well, hold
on. But that my lack of finding an
example isn't evidence that this cannot
exist, right? And
>> well, hold on. But you could probably
name like 10 leftist content creators
off the top of your head. It's
problematic. You can't think of a single
one. Even if we don't consume leftist
content,
>> there are lots of things that I already
No, no, no. This this has already been
granted by me.
>> Guys, I can't think of a single leftist
candidate who doesn't want to destroy
democracy. By this definition, Econo Boy
wants to destroy democracy, by the way.
Okay. By this definition, a connoy, the
guy they hung out with forever that they
basically I think harassed out of this
space entirely. Okay, maybe not. Maybe
not. But that's how it looks to me. That
to them that's a guy who wants to
destroy democracy. Okay. Yeah. When you
keep figuring out new and exciting ways
to explain why these people are all
tanksy tankies, Marxist Leninists,
people who are anti-democratic, when you
keep figuring out new ways to paint them
all as the same thing, they're going to
all appear that way. Is that shocking to
anybody? Is that Yeah, obviously you're
you're undertaking massive effort to
make it look this way. Yes, it's not
shocking to me that to your audience you
can make that argument.
>> Already granted that I think the biggest
ones are kind of write-offs. I think
that this is a legitimate problem. This
is why I would never work on an event
that includes this. Not that he would
ever work on one with me either, right?
Like this I've already granted. What an
>> he he might have some like pre-existing,
you know, dislike for working with
people who support women being
victimized the way Erdite does. And
realistically, I can't I can't discredit
Hassan for that. That is a noble
position to take.
>> Asking is like when you're getting to
the minutia of like what this actually
looks like, there is a tactical question
where you go if you're doing event that
is supporting a moderate Democrat and
Sam Cedar is willing to come out and
support that moderate Democrat in the
event, do you allow him to come through
or do you block him principally? This is
like a question that is beyond some
doors that have yet to be open, which is
why I don't think it's worth
considering. Like if we that this is a
good problem to have if we have
socialist groups that are willing to
campaign in the general that are pushing
for more extreme stuff in the primary,
but that's not where we're at. We're at
in a primary. It's over and over again
all of these like socialist types saying
you're going to lose every single time
until you fully endorse our platform
because all you are approach that's why
not just test it. Why not take the
morally correct position on Israel and
see what happens? Because I know that a
bunch of people, by the way, Hassan
sold the farm for Biden in 2020, right?
Obviously, he did. Why did that happen
if he will never support the damn
candidate? Can anybody explain that to
me?
It's almost like there was something
going on in 2024 that all of these
people took a moral stand against that
they felt they couldn't support a
candidate who was doing this. Right.
Right. Kolinsky has literally said he
would vote for the worst Democrat any
day over the best Republican. I'm sure
he would. Dude, it's it's just crazy.
>> Proartid and you know that's why the
Democrats are keep losing [__] Avenue
over and over again. That's all these
people. They really don't like Israel.
Yeah, that is just Bro, these people are
these these people are in a total echo
chamber. They just don't see it. I don't
know. I don't know how they can't see
it. It's everybody. And it's not
anti-semitism. It is stop blowing up the
houses of all of the poor people around
you. Stop blowing up the houses of all
the poor people around you such that
they can't even build a life. such that
they can't live, that they can never be
happy again. Stop trying to destroy
happiness and beauty. Stop it. I
>> was saying look at the look at the
response to the hypothetical that Hassan
got over um No, no, it wasn't Hassan. It
was between Hutch and uh Piso or
whatever over like would you vote for
what was it? Like Gavin Newsome or who
and the general
>> it was it was it was like it was like
what was the origination of this? It was
JD Vance versus Gavin Newsome. I don't
remember who got asked this initially if
this was
>> because we're talking about Hassan's
thing and this like okay Hutch are you
going to have the same position if it
was Assan versus JD Vance who would you
>> like these are GED level political
commentator questions you obviously
would support Newsome regardless of how
progressive or socialist you are if you
have trouble answering that question
then your opinion and your participation
in any Democratic movie should be wholly
discarded just totally thought
terminating because you said this word
because you said these words right
regardless of anything else you
clarified regardless of what the clear
tactics are regardless of what anything
else is because you said these words you
cannot participate in democracy with us,
okay?
>> Democratic party movement, you're just
not part of the same team. Like I like
the sooner we realize this, we would
just be so much better off for it. It's
such an easy question. Like if
>> the sooner you all listen to me in my
thought termination exercise, okay, the
second you take my word for it and do
exactly what I say, we would all be
happier. You Soy pill, if you just
listen to me and what I say and not
question it at all, maybe you'd stop
getting DMs telling you to keep yourself
from DJs. Have you thought about that?
You'd just be so much happier if you
weren't being told to kill yourself
constantly, right? Don't you think if
you're having there will never be
elections or questions as easy as as it
is right now. And if you're genuinely
stumbling on them, you're just like
you're fundamentally a different thing
political, which is fine, but just don't
confuse it for being a part of the
Democratic party. How much So my
confusion is that you constantly
correctly point out that these people
don't really have true power. They never
get political movements off the ground.
Their candidates mostly fail unless
they're in super safe districts. So if
all that's true, but they are able to
have massive audiences and are able to
throw support behind moderate dems. They
do. That's the if big if. Then why is it
worse to include them? How much more are
they harming than they're helping if
they're not powerful enough that could
be politically effective?
>> The boss is going to throw behind Roana.
Is that good or bad? And do we work on a
Roana?
>> I don't care about Roana. Roana is his
own on his own little island. Okay.
That's like a
>> I don't care about Stop bringing up
examples. Stop bringing up examples of
where I'm wrong. I don't care about
Roana. Hey Destiny, didn't you do an
event with Roana?
I don't care about Roana. He's by
himself. No. Roana has actual analysts
looking at looking at polling, looking
at issues and saying, "Here's what it
would be smart to support." You don't
think the guy with the biggest
contributors in the entirety of America
in his district has a lot of money to
put towards analytics and figuring out
what the right positions are to take.
>> He's like a snowflake. I'm just saying
that in general in general will throw in
behind you Buddha judge.
>> 100%. That'd be cool. That'd be great.
That'd be great. But what I'm saying is
that these the way that these people
work is they just overwhelmingly
they they
it's all I I hate to say it, okay? This
conversation with Soy Pill just straight
up shows the anti-Zionists aren't
anti-genocide. They're very progenocide.
They just want it to happen to James
because they feel like that's to justify
genocide. That's really what it all is
what all of it boils down to. Even
though it's the arc that got me into
Destiny, I'm glad he's done with it.
Dude, soy bill where he's Soy bill is
sitting here like, "Guys, I'm begging
you for any organization." Oh, you have
an I'll I'll look at it, guys. I I don't
support Hassan at all, guys. I
dude Soy has shown me that these people
just want all the killed. It's like,
okay. Yeah.
Insane levels. JN levels off the charts.
Okay. Never before seen. This is JN
Chernobyl out here. Okay.
>> They hijack the Democratic party's
messaging so that we have to talk about
that they care about that the broader
electorate doesn't care about that
overwhelmingly slants like younger,
whiter, more affluent.
>> Yeah. Yeah, definitely. I'm I'm pretty
sure that people's position on Israel if
they're white, that's far more they're
far more likely to be anti-Israel than
if they're brown. Yep. Yep. Yep. And
then even if they're not, like it's not
like they're so powerful that they can
win elections because if they
>> I can't think of a single brown
community that might be anti-Israel. I
just I can't do it, guys. I can't think
of it. Would there could there possibly
be?
>> No.
>> Have their own candidates in places that
are just trying to lead off the
Democrats. But just because you're not
powerful enough to win your own races
doesn't mean you can't negatively impact
dramatically negatively impact
a socialisty type of person that will
throw in behind Dems and consistently
does. So I think Contra Points is a good
example of a type of person who's
probably more socialist coded.
>> Hold on. This is the worst. Watching
Kyla just try to throw out lines to
bigger creators all the time. I'm going
to show charity to this really big
creator. Just constantly networking,
constantly looking to get away from
Destiny. Will any bigger creator give me
a platform? Can I am Punky Branch away,
dude. My Gaines was right. Sorry. I That
was probably too far. That was too far.
That was too far. Okay, but she just
said that and like that's totally
cutting against what Desty's trying to
say. It's very funny to me. Okay, cuz
she's just always thinking about
networking with bigger creators. It's
very funny.
>> Example you could ever give contra point
because contra points would agree with
every single thing I'm saying a billion
times over. Contra points entire online
existence has been holy leftists are
terrible ex excise them from your
movements.
>> Is your line just agreeing that leftists
are evil because that that's fine. I
agree with that. Okay, I have no problem
with that line.
>> Necess people that are going to ardently
support your candidate in general should
never be included.
>> Okay, but contra
>> hold on.
I would love to see, by the way, and I I
hope Contra Points isn't the person
who's like this. I don't think she is,
but I would hope that now with Lebanon,
Contra Points would basically go, "Yeah,
now I'm like totally I'm sorry. I like
cuz there was some subtlety the issue
for a long time, at least based on what
information you had and could confirm.
But now that Gaza has been flattened,
now that um now that Lebanon's been
invaded, I I feel like now that Iran's
been attacked, okay, now that Iran is
the the victim of this war victim, I I
maybe that's the wrong word to use. Now
that Iran has been like devastated
economically, militarily, um
humanitarian in a humanitarian sense in
every sense. Okay. Right. I do wonder
where counterpoints. Sorry, Connor.
I just read the word Connor. Contra
points
would be on this. I do think she'd
actually go back and rethink and and
reassess at this point. Okay. I do think
she would. No, I'm not going to start
over. I'm not going to start over. I
just I'm saying I think Contra Points
would probably be like pretty
anti-inist. I think she was antiist in
the first place, right? I think there's
a lot more impetus for it to be
anti-ionist like for you to be
anti-inist at this point now. There's
way more. She's dug in her heels so
much. She's not remotely anti-inist. Now
she's kind of I I don't I remember
thinking that like I understood where
she was coming from. I understood how
she got to the position she was in. I
just disagreed with it. So, we'll see.
We'll see. We'll see. We'll see. I think
I think she'd shown some like empathy
for the Palestinian people that is not
really there for liberal Zionists in the
way you guys describe it. So,
>> points is an example of somebody who is
a type you ask for a type of socialist
content creator who would throw in
behind the general. I'm saying Contra
Points is that type of person. So, will
we work with Contra Points? My answer is
yes.
>> Of course, because she passes my simple
test of will they support their
candidate in general?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. FD signifier. He threw in hard
behind Kamla. Do we work with FD
signifiers to fight the fact that he's
actually I think an ML if not further. I
think he might be further than an ML.
I'm not
>> I would have to see if he actually threw
in hardcore behind.
>> Surely we're gonna say I just I'm It's
unfortunate for Aaron because she just
ends up being like the the testing
point.
Did Aaron go? Did she, you know, try to
work towards Biden getting elected? Did
she try to work towards damn candidates
being elected in 2024 when she literally
worked at with you guys at progressive
victory?
Would you cuz you guys talk a lot of it
turns out your test she's like firmly on
the good side of it and you guys talk
all of this about her and how she's like
a threat to democracy. So, it's just
weird how we double we play both sides
of that line every single time.
>> Uh, sure.
>> I don't even know what that is.
uh a large content creator on the left,
Brett Tuber.
>> Okay.
>> And I agree that there are very few
contra points, right? FD signifier might
not count, but what I am saying is that
it's really important that our tent
>> Yes, Kilo. Yes, I've I've brought this
up before multiple times, that they all
worked with Aaron on Progressive
Victory. They all worked with her the
whole time. That's why they've created
this new cutout that makes all of their
previous content look deranged about
Aaron, right? Oh, well, if they support
Dems, then that that's fine. That's the
line. Uh, that's a newly made line and
not the one you were arguing with.
You're trying to shoot on Pisco or
trying to on Aaron in general for both
of these people. That's a new line that
you just made up because you understood
that you had a total contradiction that
you had to resolve. So, this is your way
of resolving it. Just makes your
previous content on this topic look
insane.
>> Captures the contra points and doesn't
chase them out. It's really
>> super easy to do. Yeah, that's the
contra point is an incredibly rare
cupcake snowflake. If you watch her
Twitter on Twitter, it seems like most
of the time she's just getting on or
hated by others.
>> Sure, but when you ask me for an example
of this type of creator, it took me a
bit, but that would be one example of
this type of person that left
you brought up earlier like, okay,
someone who thinks that Kamla's position
on Israel is abhorrent is in congruent
with someone who says we need to vote
for Kamla over everything and throw all
of our support. Is
>> that what I said?
>> Don't say it. Don't say it. Don't say
it. When you fail, I understand what I'm
saying over and over again.
>> Okay. Well, I failed. Please tell me.
I'm sorry.
I do hope Zoe Bill goes back. I've been
told that Zoe does some analysis right
after this. I That's not what I said at
all. That's not what I said at all.
Wait, I need to hear the precise quote
again cuz we'll see if this is for an
example of this type of creator.
>> Let me listen again. Example of this
type of person that left
you brought up earlier like okay,
someone who thinks that Kamla's position
on Israel is abhorentt is in congruent
with someone who says we need to vote
for Kamla over everything and throw all
of our support.
>> Is that what I said? That's precisely
what he said. Okay. So, someone who
thinks that Camala's position on Israel
is ahor
ahor and genocide and she
supports genocide/apar
tid. So, that's going to be the part
where Jesse says that's not what I said.
It's that they constantly harp on it
being a genocide and apartheid. Right.
But that is what her position is on
Israel is she supports a genocide and
apartheid. That is an accurate
description. So, that that's what
Desty's going to fight on. I'm almost
positive, right? Um, the is incoherent
coherence with supporting Kamla or
something. I list the rest.
>> When when you fail to understand what
I'm saying over and over and over again
>> to vote for Kamla over everything and
throw all of our support
>> I know it's the SSRI side. I know it. I
know when when you fail to understand
what I'm saying over and over and over
again.
>> Okay. Well, I failed. Please tell me.
I'm sorry. If you're constantly like if
you're screaming that a person is pro
genocide, pro a partite over and over
and over again, you you've removed that
person from the convers undefeated
undefeated undefeated undefeated. No,
it's about the scale. It's about how
often they do it.
Like I I'm sorry. The download is
complete. I don't even need to I don't
even need to try. It's so easy to say
exactly what these people are going to
do every single time. It's actually
boring conversation of being able to
actually support this person in a
general election. There's just most
people just won't be on board with that.
It's just not possible. That's you have
to recognize that there's some your
audience is never going to be able to uh
unfortunately what Destiny fails to
realize here is that's just been the
status quo in America for a long time.
So regardless of whether or not that
like regardless of whether or not you
see it accurately, that's been the
status quo. Most people are fine with it
inherently. That that's true.
>> Turn their nose and be like, "Oh, fine.
I guess I'll for the progeni." Yes.
No, I'm I'm aware that that kind of
rhetoric can absolutely turn a good
chunk of your audience away. My question
is how you think this is completely in
congruent from that person saying, "Hey,
like if you think your entire audience
is willing to accept everything you're
saying about them, as nasty as you're
being, but then completely ignoring you
and you say, "Look, I think this is
important. However, obviously this is
the materially right, correct, moral
thing to do, and you all need to go do
it and they're sucking comla during the
general." Like, how are these things
opposed? Like, these are things that I
know the majority report did. I don't I
And by the way, Soy Pill asked like,
"Why are you act these things are not in
congruent?" And Destiny categorically
responded, "They are absolutely
inongruent." So if he tries to get out
of this argument, I don't know how he
would do it because Soy Pill is now
basically trying to resolve this thing
Destiny said before, okay? I have no
idea how he's going to get out of it
because he said something stupid again.
>> Obviously Assan and I don't know, Vage,
like those people won't. Absolutely not.
They've already signal that they won't.
They definitely didn't last time. But
like there's people like me who can say,
"Yeah, I think this is abhorentt. I
didn't sh on Kamla nearly so much as
some of these other people did. I didn't
even have a platform at the time." But
the idea that this is like, "Oh, and and
therefore like going out and throwing a
material weight and telling your whole
audience and mobilizing them to go door
knock and canvas, like that's not
enough. Like I I don't want those people
to be exised from the movement. They're
clearly going to fullthroat support the
people that I need to get elected when
it comes to shove."
>> Yeah. The line definitely can't be
fullthroatedly anti-leftist because I
think a lot of like performative
>> dude how did these are these people like
update they're updating their message
right is what they're doing. They've
realized they look totally insane with
all of the rhetoric they've been doing
and so they are just updating in real
time. Well, it can't just be like [__]
every leftist. Dude,
a week ago, sorry, two, three weeks ago,
you were all defending Hutch saying he
needs we need to cut every lefty out of
this coalition. these these socialist
types. Get them all out. Get them all
the out of here, right?
You're all defending it. And now now
you've realized you're you've watched
everybody laugh at you and you're going,
"Oh, well, maybe it can't be every
leftist. Maybe okay, it's it's the
private property thing." No, it isn't.
>> Leftists that are soft leftists would be
turned away from something like that
that we could otherwise like absolutely
work with. Tilly is another I know that
is not American. Yeah. Yeah. So, like
that's why I'm saying like what are the
rules of thumb? This is why I typically
say like I don't know the policy that I
feel like you can kind of somewhat test
people on is do you want to get rid of
private property? If you have another
one that you would like to use instead
as a rule of thumb, that's fine. But I
don't think it can be you. Who the is
Tilly? Um, somebody is trying to set
Destiny up to Actually, that's really
that's actually really rude to Tilly.
Tilly is a content creator in her own
right. Totally disconnected from this.
That's actually that's who she is to
Arrodite. Okay. Sorry. That's who she is
to Ardite. That's not who she is. That's
very rude of me to say that about her.
She is a content creator who does
debates. She's done some Oxford style
debates. She debated Charlie Kirk.
People thought she did quite well. She's
the person who said Andrew Wilson is a
and then she made the video about it a
couple days ago. Okay. So, I I
apologize. That was that was crass of
me. So, she is a content creator of her
own right. But to aerodite, she's the
person she's trying to get into the
destiny sphere of politics. Okay.
>> Are vocally aggressively anti-leftist. I
don't think that that's the line
necessarily, right? Because then we're
excluding Tilly's. We're excluding
potentially slay the GOPs. Instagram has
a lot more of these types of content
creators that are going to be leftist
coded because they're not that deep in
their political philosophy and they're
born in LA, but they're actually
liberals that just don't really know it
yet, essentially. And if you say, "I'm
anti-left," you're going to lose them
because they're going to be afraid of
losing their audience.
>> Just Just real quick, just real quick.
Um Dev, you sent me this. Uh
>> yep.
Am I Am I reading this wrong? Uh here,
I'll show it on screen.
>> Actually, hold on. I feel like I feel
like we're going to pull this up. And
this this is my Israel derangement.
Okay. I feel like they're going to pull
this up. They're going to go, "Actually,
young people everywhere really love
Israel and they think Palestinians are
basically not worthy of human
consideration." Dev, are you sending me
this correct? Is this a study that says
like young people everywhere love Israel
and they think Palestinians are like
subhuman, so it's not really a genocide
anyway? Is that is that true? Young
people 15 to 22, they all think this. Oh
my god. Wow. It's It's been all a lie.
>> Give me a second. And you sent me to
something too, soy bill. If you want me
to still show that, we can. But here's
FD signifier
>> and he's basically saying he didn't
campaign for Kamala.
>> Huh?
>> Yeah. This this is an exchange from a
month ago where he he's getting blasted
by a far.
>> It's from a year ago. It's not from a
month ago. It's from a
>> lefty for supporting the Dems. And he's
like, "No, I didn't do that." Actually,
>> you point me to the video where I
campaigned for Kla Harris and
>> that guy low key throw slides.
>> Yeah, he uh he's one of he's also one of
the
>> Hold on.
I mean, we understand. I don't know what
FD signifier did. Okay. But are you
asking them to go out and campaign for
these people or are you asking them to
say obviously this is the harm reduction
candidate, right? Obviously this is the
harm reduction candidate. You should
vote for Kamala Harris. It will be way
better than Republicans. That is way
different than going out and and like
campaigning for somebody, right?
>> People who promoted bad and banana bad.
>> I can't wait to see this. The weird
Drake obsession sounds like a you thing
and being mad about switching thumbnails
is so petty. It makes me mad that I
responded to this uh crying face and not
FD signifier. That's fine, right? But
then we've got tillies, we've got contra
points, right? I especially suspect on
Instagram you're going to find a lot
more of these kind of like even like
people like Nimas, for example, do if we
say we're anti-left, Nima would never
join. But when you talk to Nima, she's
pretty much a lib. Like she's definitely
not a communist.
>> I think this is these types of these
types of obsessive conversations I think
are the reason why even as Republicans
plummet, Democrats are like always just
like when it comes to popularity or
>> who started this conversation, who's
been running with this since the
election happened, who's been entirely
on this page the entire time. Dude, what
>> approval? Because on the Democratic
side, we're just constantly asking these
questions of like, can we please bend
and cow out as much as possible to these
people who hate us and trash us
constantly and [__] on all of our
candidates and call us pro genocide,
like all these horrible things over and
over again. What can we do to appeal to
these people? That's like what the
Democratic Party is just always betting
itself backwards over to do. And I think
there's a reason why
>> they constantly eat our own. Yes. It's
because we constantly no.
No, they do. The people on the far left
do and you WANT TO KEEP INCLUDING THEM.
THEY'RE THE ONES eating our own
constantly. Yes.
>> You're inviting him.
>> Oh god. We've reached We've reached the
absolute worst case scenario.
Arerodite just infinitely more
intelligent and informed than Destiny.
It's actually over. Arrodite is like,
"Oh, I try to go on these other
platforms and I look for where like the
new people are." It turns out every new
person is like some form of left and we
do need to actually communicate to these
people. We can't just cut them all off
or we'll never have audiences again.
Don't you want to make money, Destiny? I
need to make money. Right? That's what
Erid is saying. I can't cut these people
off. I want to make money. If I say that
I want to cut out all leftists, which
she said constantly, by the way, these
people, we need to cut them out. She's
the one who came out with that, okay?
Right. After the election, these people
need to be cut out. They need to be
exised.
But now she's realizing, oh, all the new
viewers, all the young viewers, oh, they
won't watch me if I'm not left. Oh,
well, um, guys, we can't say that
anymore. We got to we got to switch it
up. We got to change a little bit.
Hannibal Lecter to the dinner table and
wondering why everyone's in need.
>> I agree. I agree. I have been swatted
and docked and attacked by these far
leftists just as much more than almost
anyone. But
>> so now that I She blamed me for it, by
the way. I She blamed me for it first.
She blamed me and Queen for it. Her
getting swatted and doxed. She openly
did so on Twitter, right? And now it's
all the far-lefts who have been doxing
and swatting her. She's just lying
again. and doxed and attacked by these
far leftist as probably more than almost
anyone but Destiny probably more than
literally everyone but Destiny on this
panel. So you're preaching to the choir
when you're talking about like the
problem with these type of people. The
thing that I am pointing out is what is
tactically effective here. That's all
I'm talking about. And I don't think
just spit driven lines is EFFECTIVE FOR
OH NO. OH NO. IS THIS better or worse
than Stardust employer coming on and
basically saying she was lying about
everything? I can't tell. I can't tell.
It feels like it's pretty good. I don't
know if it's quite that good. It's
pretty good, though. Hey, we shouldn't
just be spite based, guys. Bosch was
right about you, D.
>> It's It's good stuff. It's not
I'm I'm saying it's not spite driven.
It's that you need to have strong like
liberal things that like liberal people
that people are advocating for that once
you create you don't you DON'T AGREE.
YOU DON'T AGREE.
>> YES, OF COURSE I AGREE. WHAT? all of my
career supporting you and supporting
liberal content.
>> That's not what we're talking about.
It's not just about you. I don't know
that has nothing to do with anything.
>> Here's the thing. Well, the most
relevant thing of this conversation
right now. What I'm saying is that if I
dude, Kyle has done more for this guy
than like anybody. Okay? More than
anybody. She's literally violated every
moral principle she's ever held for this
guy. And the second she disagrees with
him, she is trash to him. And it's so
it's so fun to watch. It's just very fun
to watch every time.
>> If I want a leftist candidate, I can
find and I can find leftist influencers
that are big bad awesome leftists.
They're all the Democrats are all the
Republicans and it feels good. You say
all these people are on Instagram and
Tik Tok. Of course they are cuz they're
allowed to be there and they're allowed
to talk about how horrible the genocide
is and everything else. But as liberals,
you can't create those people to those
spaces. You constantly have to run to
those people and become a
selfperpetuating problem. We're having
just real quick. I am trying out Hold
on. No, no, no. I'm making sure my
position is clear so that it doesn't get
like turned into something else. I am
trying to parse out what will work most
effectively. That is all I am trying to
figure out here. I'm not actually
strictly advocating for any direction
right now. I'm actually poking holes and
questions into positions that are
stronger so that I can decide for myself
because I think for example, one of the
big issues that you're pointing to with
the leftist is that they're eating our
own. They're eating the liberals. They
are constantly attacking it. And I think
one of the big issues that liberals have
is we don't support each other very
much. I suspect right now that your
audience right now is all over Neil's
and all over me super nasty despite the
fact that we are literally aligned right
and so
>> who Neil's
is that oh is that this guy or is that
soy pill's name I don't even know
>> this type of behavior I think is a
leftist problem and is a liberal problem
and is always going to create issues
over liberal things it's over supporting
the cannibalistic leftist
>> build things up I don't like you asking
you're asking the right question and I
don't disagree with your question
Arerodite is what is most tactically
efficient what should we be doing in
order to win the argument that I am
making and and I think Destiny is making
is that by inviting these leftists in
even you may gain a few of their
followers even some of the like some of
them might work with you and you might
be able to have some of them vote for
you things will happen because you do
that that are going to hurt more than
Let me finish. Let me finish. Let me
finish. Okay. They are going to drive
away other voters. That's uh more
moderate voters, more centerleaning
voters. Uh I will say I did get sent
these logs which are a little bit funny.
Okay. A little bit funny. Little bit
funny here. Do you remember this person?
This person was very very very pro
Destiny with all the stuff. Uh all of
the stuff after January, right? Uh
Destiny nails nails nails. Destiny,
you're completely wrong. Omega lol soy
pill W destiny you were wrong Destiny
he's correct IP van IP van get out get
out are going to see you appealing to
these or working these people and
they're going to they're not going to
want to work with you anymore because
they know how they operate there's going
to be a lot of these people in their
audiences that are going to come in that
don't have the same um morals as their
uh streamer uh person that they're
following that are absolutely going
behave
like the evil Hannibal Lectar leftists
that we're talking about and just
destroy
um destroy any kind of sense of of of
unity within whatever organization
you're trying to make. I do.
>> The harsh is just real quick just real
quick and then we'll let we'll let
>> It's very funny that Crowd's whole thing
is these people are only fueled by petty
spite spitefueled grievance and he
doesn't realize how well it applies to
the people making the arguments here.
Okay, it's just very funny that that's
also like progressive victories broad
problem with Destiny is they want all
these people to work together. That's
what they're trying to do and Destiny's
like the antithesis of that. He's been
arguing against that for months now,
right? There's really nothing there's
nothing about Hassan here that was like
co-opted. It was, "Hey, we want to work
with all of these people. We want all of
these people to work together.
>> We work with Tilly's. Do we work with
Tilly's?"
>> No. Uh,
>> go ahead.
>> Not this, but she's British. That's a
British person.
>> Dude, I Dude, I Is Soy Pill brave enough
to just call it out? Uh, of course we
work with attractive women. Of course we
work. Why wouldn't we work with
attractive women no matter their
politics? Guys, could you That's what we
do. Obviously, we will work with any
attractive woman who is willing to not
say that who who is unaware of the
things I've done. Any of them. Any of
them ever.
>> I know. Use the example because I've
given Contra points. I've given Tilly's.
>> You're talking to a Canadian. Just the
little bits of shade. The little shade.
Yeah, you're literally talking to a
Canadian right now about this. I don't
know where slay the GOP is exactly on
Newsome, so I'd have to vet that one
out. Na might be an example. Do we work
with these people who will identify as
leftists and won't want to work with us
if our position is doggedly
anti-leftist?
>> I actually I I I actually talk with a
lot of leftists. Um I associate with
some of them.
>> It's actually so funny how cooked these
people are and they can't see it. Like I
sometimes your faith is shaken just a
little bit. Okay, but they're actually
just totally cooked. Not Soy Pill. Soy
Pill is waking up. Soy Pill's waking up.
He's coming online. But the rest of
these people, it's just like
transparently about views and clicks and
siphoning off as much of Destiny's
audience as you can before he eventually
crashes out and somebody or Yeah,
basically like I think that's basically
all it is. It's very interesting. One
thing that they all have in common,
those at least that I associate with is
they all got chewed out and purity
tested by Hassan P and co. So I think a
great place to tactically start if
you're going to build bridges into the
far
>> great place to start. Assan is mad.
Assan is bad
>> left or into leftist corners or whatever
the you want to call him. Good place to
start is to go for those to engage with
those who got purity tested and chewed
out by that monstrous
>> Oh, by the way, on the on the
counterpoints thing, why is Israel so
bad at propaganda? Are they stupid? Or
is being universally despised part of
some larger plan?
I think I don't know if this is her
being like pro Israel and not wanting to
be look like a fool or if it's literally
her saying like, "Yeah, they are they
look monstrous right now." It's hard to
say. It's hard to say.
Well, I think Contra Points hates
Hassan, but I don't think Contra Points
would try to do some like moral
framework thing. Oh, it's like morally
good to hate Hassan. I don't I maybe she
would. Maybe I I feel like from watching
the videos, it seems like solid
foundation that she operates from most
of the time. Most of the time. Okay. I
don't think she go I'm morally correct
for hating Hassan. I think she would
say, "I just hate Assad. This guy's a
piece of [__] to me." And I I think she
doesn't think they're effective, but
building up over there.
>> The way to tell a lot of them was right.
Unfortunately,
>> the way to tell is do they support the
camp?
>> That's the MAGA tactic. That is the MAGA
tactic that has worked so perfect
perfectly since 2015. It's you like
that's what people like um like
what they did they always go after
people who were chewed out by their own.
So yeah, we go after the people who we
built the bridges to the people who got
chewed out by people like Assad.
>> I agree. But the issue is a lot of those
people a lot of those people now have
unfortunately like landed on the right
in such a way that I think a lot of
>> Yeah. Because we didn't catch them.
>> I agree with you. I totally agree with
you. Right. I totally
>> doesn't mean that. Yeah. It like saying,
"Oh, yes, but this example and this
example therefore let's not do this
anymore." That's not exactly something
that works.
>> Yeah. So what I would point out here and
all I would say here is that if the line
of thumb of who you do and don't work
for is the voc vocality of being
anti-leftist, I think it's not
sophisticated. I'm just trying to parse
out what's tactically effective because
I think you lose people like Nimas, like
enemy Charlie, who is a leftist.
>> How do we do Do you want to know why you
lose them? It's because if you're
clearly anti-leftist, there is a thing
you're doing that is
again again it all comes down to one
thing and that's the thing you're
explicitly like controlling for. If
people are anti-left, it's over what
issue? Oh, Israel is that is I watched
Sneo suck Assan's the other day. Okay.
Over the Israel stuff. Some people in
the right wing are very fine with Assan.
The people in the rightwing who are
attacking left are often doing so based
on one issue. Okay. Well, sorry, a lot
of issues, but it's it's one big thing,
right? It's so it dude, it's so funny.
It all comes down to the same thing over
>> Why do we keep repeating this point? I'm
saying that you just don't support
people that don't like valiantly support
the candidates in the general. That's
it.
>> Oh, ENEMY CHARLIE'S ON THIS SIDE. WELL,
Wick's about to flip teams. WAIT, AN
ATTRACTIVE WOMAN IS on that side. Oh my
god. As for Daniel, comrades, don't we
love the USSR? Hello everybody.
>> Most people might not. I suspect then
you don't have them on your team. Then
they're cancer. They don't work with
them as cancer. I don't critical of
Gavin. Well, the issue is which
candidate do they have to support right
now? Ardent ardently. What if they say
of course what if they say something
like I of course will support Gavin
Newsome? Say we he wins. Okay, it's
Gavin Newsome for president. All right,
that would be my dream. Okay. If they
say I'll of course get vote for Gavin
Newsome over JD Vance, but they go but I
would have had different preferences in
the primaries. Is that okay or are they
out too?
>> What do you think?
>> I would include them.
>> No. What do you think my answer said?
>> Of course you would include them.
>> Wait, that's such a ridiculous question.
If their position was
>> Wait, that is Hassan's updated position.
By the way, just he just included
Hassan. That is Hassan's updated
position. Hassan did actually go after
the fact and say, "By the way, what do
you think that implies about his
audience that Hassan felt it was
necessary to go back and update his
position? Do you think he was maybe
getting pushed by his audience to not
stand on business there?" Like I it's
like such a blind spot for all of these
people. I would have supported somebody
different, but I'll support them in the
general. Obviously, this is a person to
be included. This is not 99% of the
people that we're talking about, though.
Okay, but what if you have people right
now that are that are further like this
that do become like this? Like what if
instead of uh Gavin Newsome winning,
Pete Buddha Judge wins and so suddenly
Sam Cedar is willing to throw in behind
uh Pete Buddha Judge. I'm not
>> sure Sam would also throw behind Gavin.
I'm pretty sure.
>> Sure. Regardless, do we work with them?
>> Uh the only question there would be
whether or not Sam would throw behind
Pete Buddha Judge. I dude I I'm sorry.
Leftists have a unique derangement for
Pete Jud Buddha Judge. You shouldn't
judge anything else on that. Okay. Pete
Pete Buddha Judge is like the primary.
Maybe Slotkin's a little worse now that
she's a literal CIA agent, but I'm
pretty sure every leftist is like Pete
Buddha Judge is a CIA agent. He is like
evil. He is evil incarnate. Okay. Maybe
Slackin's worse now for them. I'm not
totally sure, but a lot of leftists
really hate Pete Buddha Judge
>> now or do we not? Because they've been
so costic because they have
>> No, we can wait with them in the
general. If they want to support us in
the general, we work with them in the
general, but are we're fundamentally
misaligned in the in the primary, so
support other content creators. Support
>> well, Hold on, let me ask you.
>> What if they're willing to vote for
Gavin Newsome, but also vehemently
critical of his connections to Apac? So
they say, "I would vote for him cuz he's
better than [__] JD Vance,
>> but he's still a genocidal maniac.
>> More tongue and cheek, but he's still a
genociding A-packer. But of course, I'm
going to win vote for him over a
fascist."
>> A genociding a packer. Whoa.
>> What if that's their position? Do we
work with those? We can find I think we
can do better. I think we can do better
than that.
>> Yeah. There there are other lines like
even if they're willing to give lip
service to our I do I do I pull a tweet
just to drive home a point? Do I pull
home a tweet or sorry do I pull up a
tweet because it really drives home a
point just that none of them wanted to
cut that enemy Charlie person out of the
conversation because they like her
because it's all petty spiteful
personal grievance. Okay. Now, I have to
pull it. I have to pull it. I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to this Charlie person if you
get dragged into something. Okay, but
this is everything they've said is wrong
with Hassan right here. She's
retweeting. I want the US to lose this
war. For the sake of liberation and
deolonization, it must for the sake of
humanity. We must lose. The best outcome
for the US results in ecoside and
multiple genocides. This is every single
thing. Dude, Hassan might Hassan would
probably blush before tweeting that. And
they would all support this enemy
Charlie person 100%.
Right. They would be totally behind her.
Why? I mean, one, it's it's spiteful
grievance. Two, I I will go no further.
Okay, I will go no further. I know she's
like a lesbian, so I don't want to be
too weird about it. Or maybe she's But,
you know, all these candidates are
corporate shills who do not have your
best interest at heart that will just
sell you out. Uh, that they're the
Epstein class. They're the um, you know,
So, you're done with Roana, who coined
the term. Dude, how many of these people
are paid by third way? I Why would you
pick this third way group as the group
you're going to like shill for? I like
you're literally just doing their work.
Why? Why? What is it based? What What is
happening?
I I don't get it. I really don't get it.
They're their Apac shills, all these
things. No. No. We don't want you. We
don't want to work with you. We We want
people who support us, not you. So
that's where we probably disagree. It
seems to me less tactically sound
because if they're willing to like work
together but still be super critical of
Gavin Newsome, I'm broadly still going
to just be willing to work with them.
Right. The people that I'm not going to
be
>> it's not just being critical, it's how
they're critical.
>> Yeah.
>> I don't know why we're playing. The word
games here are really funny tonight. I
don't know if this is intentional or
not. Like I don't understand you and
>> the word games here, bro. Aeronite's
like 95% on their side. Do you want to?
Dude, it's like a perfect microcosm.
They say it's cultlike behavior to
require somebody to be 100% on your
side. Arodite is objectively 95 to 99%
on their side. And they are trying to
break her.
How do you not blush doing this? How do
you not feel self-conscious doing this?
That you like have to take this person
down now. I bet she's going to
apologize. Well, well, well. Sorry. if
they're if they're going to be critical.
Who the is talking about being critical?
We're talking about calling somebody a
genocidal supporting Zionist freak.
That's not being critical. It's being
unhinged.
>> Wait, are there a lot of
Is this directly personal now? He just
hates that people call him this,
dude. That Destiny is starting to come
he's coming to the he's sobering up.
Okay. He's coming to the realization
that that cookie debate is going to
haunt him forever unless he can like fix
this and put all of his political might
behind making sure that it's not a
problem, right? That the debate where he
goes out and sells out to talk about the
Cookie Rockets, that's going to haunt
him for the rest of his career unless he
can change something up. Okay? He's got
to he's got to make it right. There's
like this is like a but not in act not
in the sense of actually making it
morally right. He's got to make it right
by making it seem like he was right.
different kind of like there's not a
single person in here and if there is
then then whoever is saying this I don't
I don't think anybody here saying this
who's saying we can't accept people who
are critical in the primaries of our
candidates I don't think a single person
in here is saying that or has ever said
that or will ever have that position
unhinged
>> so did he say that we we keep the enemy
Charlie's did he say we keep the tillies
and enemy Charlie's by the way he
doesn't have a problem with the rhetoric
right he doesn't he doesn't know he he
would have to go after this person just
as hard right just as hard he'd have to
go after this person maybe harder than
Hassan. I don't know if Hassan's come
out and said, "I need the US to lose
this war for the sake of
decolonization." That's like some
extremely far-left like hardcore
leftist. No, I need the US to lose this
war because otherwise horrible things
will happen. That cookie argument
solidified his orientation in the axis
of Epstein.
>> Sure. When I say critical, I mean the
level of nuance and sophistication that
I expect from the majority of these like
I'm a leftist because I don't know much
more and I live in LA type creators.
That's about what I expect. And I do
expect them to call him
>> Sam Cedar from Emma Vlin from anymore.
I'm talking about people like
these creators that they're gonna be
less
>> all of these people have said negative
things about Destiny. That is all this
is that's all this is in relation to.
They've all said negative things about
Destiny. As soon as it's somebody who
hasn't explicitly spoken out negatively
about him, they're fine. No, they can be
in the coalition is unaware of their
talking points. He doesn't care to know
their talking points, they're fine
because they haven't talked about me for
they are leftist, but they're leftist
because they're in LA to some degree.
And they
>> The problem with your hypothetical
though is that it doesn't really
correlate with reality. That's not what
happened in the last election. It's not
what happened. Well, we didn't have
these far left people come around and
like, oh yes, Camala is the like in the
thing that you describe where they're
begrudgingly supportive of that's not
what they did.
>> I agree. I agree because
>> do not vote third party blah blah blah.
>> I agree. I agree. I agree with you
entirely because I think that there was
literally almost no media uh community
social structure for
>> Do you think it would have changed had
liberals been like, "But we really
really want you, please."
>> That's not what I'm advocating for.
>> Yeah. No one's advocating for
capitulating.
>> I'm not I'm not saying lick the boots of
people who want to destroy America and
hate Democrats and want to destroy it.
I'm not saying that obviously.
>> No, I'm I'm not saying you're saying
that.
>> Well, that would be the conclusion of
that, right? If I'm
>> I don't think so.
>> Please, Hassan, will you let us on? It's
like that's that's pathetic behavior.
What I want mostly for liberals to do is
support other liberals and rally around
each other. The main thing that I want
to make it clear is that we are a soft
landing place for people who like call
themselves leftists, who do use things
like genocide support other liberals.
>> What?
>> What do you mean? What do you mean with
like this is like the third or fourth
time I'm so curious is to ask what do
you mean with liberals then support
liberals? What do you mean with that?
>> Um for example uh engaging with one
another positively in content trying our
best not to endlessly critique one
another as we are doing right now. Um
try to build a
random meme things but
>> these aren't me things at all. I don't
know.
Dude,
you're such a stupid Jeridite. Why do
you even talk? Aridite, you're such a
stupid Why do you even talk? They say
they want to destroy the movement. This
is not a critique of a liberal. But I
guess I'm saying what the [__] does that
mean when they want to destroy
>> people who don't support the candidate
in general because they didn't get their
way in the primary.
>> Sure. Okay. So, what about people who
are not very sophisticated but do do
some level of political content like
enemy Charlie's and Nimas? What do we do
with these leftists who probably do call
Gavin Newsome a genocider because they
live in LA and all their friends are
doing that but probably
>> what why is Arerdite like infantilizing
all of these women? Why does Ardite
realize that enemy Charlie I'm guessing
would be super offended by this? She's
just like a really stupid who can't look
outside of her own bubble and like if
she just talked to a smart person like
Destiny then maybe she'd realize that
Israel is just doing the moral thing to
the most moral army on earth, right?
Like, why are you doing that? Isn't that
super offensive to all these women? Now,
far be it for me to criticize misogyny.
Okay, I listen, I respect Ardite's game
there, but that makes me blush. All
right, when when Aronite said this
stupid
enemy, Charlie can't even think for
herself, can barely look beyond her own
bubble. But if she just had a smart man
like Destiny to guide her, she'd be
she'd be right up here with the rest of
us, okay? She'd be a really smart
political commentator. And I was like,
dude, I I'm a misogynist, but that's a
bit much. No. Isn't that a bit much?
That's a lot. Jesus.
>> He could be pulled and probably would be
willing to rally around and behind
certain modern Democrats. Do we work
with them? That's what I'm trying to
ask.
>> What does that have to do with liberals
supporting liberals?
>> Why? Because you don't have to. I never
do this. I never ever ever have to think
about questions like this. Like, do I
bring somebody on who says they're not
going to support Trump? Do I didn't do
this? They just don't work with those
people and they pick people who support
the
>> I think she literally just said I think
she literally just said, but they do
support for them. Okay. All right. Yeah.
Get on get on the team. Right. If you
want to be on the team, you can be on
the team. We'll accept you. But you got
to get you got to come to us, right? Is
that what we're
>> Yeah. These people don't even have real
political power in terms of they can't
get any of their candidates elected.
They don't go to win primaries anywhere
outside of like the deepest, bluest,
most Democrat prepared places. I don't
understand why the conversation is
capitulating to them. It should be
>> Now we're about to loop. Guys, are you
ready for the loop? Now Soyill is going
to feel compelled to point out that
every time you make this point that they
have no power, they have nothing. you
then why do you need me to not interact
with them if I'm getting everything I
want and they'll never be elected if
there's no concern about how they'll
like destroy democracy or something why
is it bad for me to take free money from
them what is your what is the why are
you saying this how much
our politicians want to work with them
right that that's reality
>> because that's acceptting these people
into our movements because nobody's
doing anything to audit these people and
because there's this weird acceptance on
the left of having to work with tankies
and [__] does never happen on the right
they don't do this on the right
>> how do you pull
Does Destiny really is Destiny really
arguing for auditing the influencers and
their past and how moral a person they
are? Is that is that what we're doing
here? Well, I guess maybe he's arguing
for auditing He was making that argument
earlier. Very bizarre. Maybe he just
means now audit them to see if they will
support Gavin Newsome. I don't know.
>> Is towards the liberal side effectively.
>> I don't know. I don't care. I'd rather
create more mocklers and more loopies
and more of these types of people than
try to figure out how to appease or
appeal to people that don't seem
>> Adam Mockler who directly talked to
Hassan who likes Assan who gets along
with be of the party.
>> It's wasted energy. Like look, I would
love aid. I'll put it like this. Okay.
Um the neocons invited mega in and then
they got destroyed. The liberals
shouldn't do the same with the far left.
>> I none of this. No, I'm no longer
talking about the far left. I think me I
don't know where I'm not going to put
words. My position
>> talking about liberals again. What
>> I am talking about this space between
somebody who is actually a tanky who
knows what they're talking about and
means their positions right like a
Hassan or a Vosch versus people who
their politics aren't overly
sophisticated. It's mostly result of
their culture. They happen to be
probably an LA socialite and so they're
in this socialist progressive camp and
they probably identify as a leftist. I'm
asking what do we do with these people
cuz I actually think that they have a
lot of value.
>> If it's not even strongly committed to
anything then fine. You do events with
them I guess. Sure.
>> Okay. That's what I'm asking. I
>> dude, I'm sorry. It's so funny. Uh I
just love people like Tilly and Enemy
Charlie who are like ditsy bimbos who
think they're socialists, who think
they're leftleaning, but they just
haven't really like learned anything
about the world. And thank God they've
got people like Not So Arerodite and
Destiny to teach them to guide them to
towards being like an enlightened
person. I just I I I'm so they're so
precious these attractive young women
who are just totally ditzy bimbos with
no real political uh understanding and
we can guide them. We can shape them.
Okay.
Thank you Ardite. Thank you.
>> I will disagree. Right. I think that
like well if they want to work with
>> True Sim Yes. Absolutely true. You need
to groom them into the liberals of the
future. Destiny and I are looking to
groom these young attractive women into
the liberals of the future. Yes,
>> view. That's fair. I don't think we
should try to appeal to them. I don't
think we should try to kind of reach out
to them because I think that the people
who are going to give us more value and
what I mean by that is votes to to be
clear vote.
>> Oh, also we will check out the soy pills
like post retrospective or whatever
after this right after.
>> I don't care about clicks on social
media. I care about what only in in so
much as it translates to actual votes on
election day whether that be primary
election day for my preferred primary
candidate or in the general election. Um
we talk we reach out to the people who
have a history of voting right who have
a history of participation who are
getable and we do that by sticking to
our liberal values. One of the problems
that we have and one of the reasons we
look weak is because we're constantly
trying to appeal to the to these people
who aren't going to give us anything.
>> Where where's this constant appeal I'm
seeing? If anything, it seems like the
opposite is happening, which I'm not
saying is a bad thing, by the way, but
like I
>> When have you guys appealed? When has
anybody around you appealed?
What What is that happening? What where
is that? I'm
>> not suggesting we appeal these people.
It doesn't seem like a lot of people
are. The only thing I'm seeing is that
people want to go on platforms that are
big that have to be run by leftists, but
they're not appealing to those leftist
like policies that aren't
>> wait. They are appealing to them because
those leftists are controlling the
conversations. That's why we just had a
PD thing where 90% of the conversation
was about Israel Palestine.
>> Okay, fair enough. And that's the thing
that when people are watching it, that's
a both sides issue. Like both sides are
equally bad on Israel Palestine and the
way forward is.
>> Yeah. And so when Wick says, and this is
something
>> both sides are basically dude, what
where's the shift? Where's the shift on
Israel Palestine? Oh, Donald Trump is
worse. But it's like
I think this is one of those issues
where absolutely you can stand and say
I'm not voting for somebody who's not
willing to change this. I'm it's it's
destroying the global economy because
nobody has taken that stand. and
everybody refuses to for some reason.
I'm not going to speculate on why they
won't take a stand, but they should take
a stand. Okay, I think this is one of
those few issues where I do I do not
mind people saying, "Yeah, I'm just not
going to support someone who's going to
send my tax dollars to Israel." Not
going to do it. Sorry. I got to agree
with when Wick says, "If you partner
with these people, if you're a
politician, you're on that panel where I
was on and they're saying some unhinched
and they're like posting this with like
all the clips of the song saying more
unhinched, that probably will lose you
more support with voters than it would
gain from you working with a person like
that." And that's why I'm like, "Yeah,
that's probably bad." versus, hey, this
person said, I'm going to canvas for the
general person. I'm not saying this has
happened yet. Let's just say this is the
case. I I don't see any reason to reject
that help.
>> Yeah, I guess I just the examples we're
giving are things have just never ever
ever happened. So, I'm not even sure how
to like evaluate these examples.
>> We just saw the PV is thrown out
>> literally and has done so the entire
time they've existed. The entire time
>> help for the person in the general that
they don't support
thro tweet for the other person that we
did see that tweet that was a event that
helps get them elected.
Okay.
Okay. By the way, Destiny, when that was
brought up, just to refresh you, when
that was brought, he brought it up and
said, "Did they even tweet anything? Did
they even do anything for this
candidate?" And now he is just
categorically wrong. And he is basically
trying to mock Soy Pill for bringing up
the fact that he was categorically
wrong.
Again, cult cult. It's insane. It's It's
crazy to watch.
Soy pill is just correct. And now Soy
Pill bringing up the fact that he is
correct. This he goes, "Okay, they did
one tweet." Okay. Okay.
They generally care.
>> PV thro tweet for the other person that
we did see that
>> a tweet that was making event that helps
get them elected.
>> Okay,
>> that's good, right?
>> Okay.
>> It's it's not it's it's a it's a
magnitude question. You would understand
this in any other circumstance, but for
here we're pretending we don't. I guess
I don't know why you always accuse me
like that. Like it's like at worst I
>> You're such a soy pill. You're such a
stupid tanky.
You can't you see I'm I'm just obviously
intrinsically correct. I'm obviously
just intuitively correct. Why won't you
just agree with me? Why do you make
arguments?
>> The reason why watch no is one of the
big reasons why like Assan doxed every
single person he could in PV because of
their association with me. That was the
only reason. every single person in PV.
A just reminder for this guy who is very
very concerned about people in
Progressive Victory being doxed. I just
want to remind you this is not the first
he's hearing of it. In fact, when when
people were reposting this stuff, not
even when it was found the first time,
but when people were reposting this
stuff, one of his chatters came along
and said, "Hey, maybe Destiny, could you
let like Hutch and Josiah know that
their information got posted?" And what
was Destiny's response? I wonder what
was Destiny's response. It was, "Hey,
oh man." Oh, wait, wait, wait. Up at the
top, Destiny. Send it to them so they
can see what they are doing. So, send it
to these people. Send it to who?
Destiny. Josiah and Hutch and stuff. Oh,
me. They can figure it out themselves.
Oh, me. Oh, yeah. This guy got banned
tonight for disagreeing with Destiny.
Oh, me. They can figure it out
themselves.
The only time Destiny decided to go tell
them about this was when he thought he
could bend Hutch like to his way of
thinking. He made zero effort to go and
tell him in the first place and
explicitly said so.
Yeah, the very violent guy got banned.
Well, I assume he won't be banned very
long. He's a total cultist, so it is
what it is. But he's now he's virtue
signaling about the Hassan thing. When
this originally happened, Destiny did
not give a about these people and
explicitly said so.
He does not care about you. When he
makes these points, it is because he
hates Hassan, not because he cares about
you. And he did that. Hassan calls Dylan
Burns a war taourist or jumps on it and
shits on [__] loner box who's
literally been on an island for like 12
months of content. Like Assan has almost
single-handedly tried to destroy this
guy's career because of any resemblance
to being pro-Israel or being like that's
what these people do. And then the
conversation,
>> you don't have to explain leftist doxing
to me. my personally experienced it and
working to it. What I'm talking about
with like
>> again the person who is who is helping
Dan dox people, okay, is the person who
originally grabbed all the PV papers and
published their docses, publish all
these people's docses and the whole
anti-han campaign. That's the guy who
was who was finding people's I'm sorry I
it is the way it is. Okay, we're
it's still bad. What Hassan did is still
bad. It's really bad. It's It was at
best at best insanely reckless to watch
a bad empanada video without knowing
what was there. Okay. At the very best.
Leftist is just President Sunday. Do you
think that's what she's talking about? I
don't think that's what she's talking
about cuz she's talking about swatting
too. Anyway, I agree. The leftist trying
to destroy us is one of the biggest
issues. Liberals always have it coming
from both sides at all time. Right. At
all times. And so I agree with that. But
I think one thing that liberals could do
better to be proactive rather than just
being like ah the leftists are
destroying us is being more proactive at
supporting each other. This is actually
think something that destiny you're
uniquely good at right you allow anyone
to come on your platform you typically
try to support smaller content creators
right but like I think it's really
important for example that like in
liberal space
>> why has he been doing that is it is it
like basically all of the people he is
ever invited on his platform he's uses a
pool of like partners you think it has
anything to do with maybe there's you
know I I can think of a reason I
wouldn't want like Tilly or basically
like any woman to go on that platform is
because he's openly for for years used
that as a way to build towards
relationship with people,
right? So, he brings people on, but what
is the motivation in bringing people on?
Be honest. What is the motivation when
somebody calls him out for sharing their
non-conensually? Something you totally
supported this person, Pixie on. Okay.
What does he say about her now? She was
a clout. She's a gold digging clout.
And yet, you still appear with him. Wick
still appears with him. You guys are
totally fine with this, right? It's
totally okay. It's all good. Destiny
supports small creators until they speak
out against them. And then it is, oh, I
have to destroy these people. I will dox
them. I will with their lives in any way
possible.
And you sit here and pretend Hassan is
the problem. I fought with Hassan. I was
like the number one guy a logging
Hassan. Never got doxed, never got with
in any way that was like inappropriate
for the internet. People talked, but it
wasn't a problem. And I was the guy. He
was naming me and trying to like read
out my lore on his stream. If somebody
was gonna with me, I would think getting
brought up on Hassan's stream multiple
times so he could talk. You'd think that
would have happened. I've seen what it's
like being against like Hassan and then
I've seen what it's like being on the
bad side of DG and I can tell you one of
them is significantly worse than the
other
>> places to have slightly soft landing
places. Like me and Soyel disagree on
certain stuff about like how to interact
with things. I disagree with just I
disagree with you, but we should like
broadly try to do our best to like have
criticisms for each other but also have
a decently soft landing place for one
another and give a lot of grace to one
another in a way that I see progressives
will do with one another. You mean that
we have a corner where we check each
other off? I I
>> This is not what you're talking about
has nothing to do with soft landing
places. You're talking about inviting
people like soft landing spaces are
where you have areas to derdicalize
people who have more or less disavowed
like the political ideology that they're
coming from or like are on the verge of
doing it. You're talking about accepting
people who see themselves as utilizing
you to energize and supercharge their
political ideologies.
>> Well, you're talking about right now.
>> Again, again, dude, I I can guarantee
you right now Soy Pill is seeing Hold
on. What is Soy Pill seeing? So, Bill's
got like a a video going on in his head
right now. Okay. That is like He's like,
"Dude, what? What? Wait, what?
>> You like chicken and waffles?"
>> I do.
>> You have a lot of this in Chicago.
>> What?
>> Uh, no. We don't. I don't.
>> Oh, you need to pray first.
>> I did.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> I'm sorry. Like, when did this Oh,
you're you're only bringing people on
not You can only bring people on when
they've disavowed their ideology
completely. Okay. You can only bring
them on when they've disavowed their
ideology completely and they're willing
to like that's where the soft landing
space is. Wow. Okay. All right. I guess
this has changed. I
>> I understand why you're saying that. I'm
not talking about right right now just
I'm not talking about like the
socialists at all. I'm excluding them.
I'm only talking about people actually
who identify in the liberal camp are in
a liberal camp. And when I say a soft
landing place for liberals, I don't I'm
not talking about converts. But I
understand why you're confused. I'm
actually talking about other liberals.
Like for example, I typically try to go
out of my way all the time to give other
liberal content creators as many
opportunities as I possibly can. And
when I say a soft landing place for
liberals, I don't I'm not talking about
converts, but I understand why you're
confused. I'm actually talking about
other liberals. Like, for example, I
typically try to go out of my way all
the time to give other liberal content
creators as many opportunities as I
possibly can to like get into other
spaces. And when progressives on
Instagram started thinking I was a
progressive, I started getting a whole
bunch of offers and I very quickly to be
like, oh, like, you know, like I'm not
really I got a lot of Gaza offers and
stuff and I would be like, oh,
respectfully, I'm probably not the
person that you're looking for
necessarily here, but
>> hey, would you like to fund raise for
Gaza? Um, listen, I'm I'm not the person
you're looking for. You support
Palestinian. I'm not the person you're
looking for. That's a crazy position,
right? Isn't that insane?
>> I see us doing very little of this,
right? We very little like course is
probably the best example that levels of
part is very nepotistic. What grow?
>> That's part of who we are. That's part
of our principles. We like pure
pluralism. We embrace pluralism. We're
also disconnected. We There is no such
thing as a liberal community online.
There's a liberal space.
>> Uh-oh. A classical liberal has entered
the fray. Not good for everybody else
here. Uh-oh. You're you're you've
wandered into a destiny liberalism
conversation as a classical liberal.
You're about to get educated, my friend.
>> Because we embrace difference. We
embrace doing things
>> we embrace. This is why we should be
able to unify better. Like you should be
going and engaging with short fatter
talk and just like promoting and
retweeting and promoting some coming on
a panel together to talk about our
issues with leftists in the space and
others. Maybe someone
>> but also like if you
>> to all agree and vehemently attack Soy
pill on everything he says even though
he's been correct in every assertion
he's made the entire panel but never
admit as much well if that's what
promoting each other means then I
suppose get hit with an opportunity from
um uh a candidate that you actually
think another liberal content creator
would be a better fit for or should be
pulled along see if the candidate will
work with this other liberal content
creator too right when you see for
example when I see any liberal content
creators content I try to like like and
retweet and like create a little bit
more engagement for their content so
that we can like win this the culture
war, right? So like maybe this is an
inherent nature to like what liberals
tend to be like, but at the same time we
should try to counterman it so that
people want to stay in the space and
we're supporting one another and we like
build something because we're getting it
from side only in this place. I think
people do want to stay in this space but
the thing is also how do I put it?
>> It's not other liberals that are driving
them out.
>> I'll say that.
>> Do you mean and people staying in this
space? Do you mean the audience or do
you mean other creators?
>> Other creators I think if I'm creators I
think so
>> if I'm understanding your question.
>> Yeah. Like I said, I don't think to
piggy back off crowd, maybe crowd has a
different answer. It's not liberals who
are primarily driving others out of
these space. Again, the reasons why it's
sometimes hard to get people if I have a
show with Destiny, I have to make sure
everyone knows that Destiny's going to
be there because there are certain
people who won't go on because they know
that if they go on with Destiny that
it's it's going to it's they're going to
catch hell.
>> That's that's the thing that I've had
experience for like the last eight years
of my life. Basically, every creator I
publicly associated with instantly gets
barged with this guy used to be an
anti-Sw. You should not. Yeah, you
should not. Like it's like that's true.
None of the opportunity
we're not even purity testing ourselves.
It's outsiders who come in who do not
hold themselves to our principles and
then try to blackmail us on the basis of
our principles.
>> I agree and I think it's why in some
ways we need to be a little bit more
gentle with each other because we should
recognize that we're like getting it so
much from like one another. Like I just
dominantly shut
>> you're never going to convin somebody
who thinks that this is one of the guys
who thinks that sunlight is the best
disinfectant that like tolerate that
always having the conversation is good.
You're not going to win this guy over.
That's the classical liberal like credo.
You're you're never winning him over on
this. I don't know why she keeps trying.
>> Yes. Like for example,
what I
>> The problem is that we barely engage
with each other. And I think that is a
good thing that
doesn't mean community. Yeah. This is
the problem. This is maybe the problem,
right? Pluralism should not imply anti-
community, but what we kind of have for
liberals right now is a bit of an anti-
community. There isn't like this.
>> Do you think that has like anything to
do with the fact that basically Soy pill
I know he's going to get a ton of
harassment for this. I'm already seeing
it happening. Right. Do you think that
has anything to do with the fact that if
you hold a position different to
Destiny's in his community, his
community will attack you like
vehemently and he will at best say, "Oh,
no, don't do that." But most of the
time, he'll go, "Yeah, this person." He
did with Pisco and all of you sat back
and watched. All of you were totally
down for it. All of you helped. I
>> I don't disagree with her long term.
Again, if this is what I trying to get
into as wick and it's like there are
certain cases where you can show me,
it's like associating with these people
is absolutely more harmful than not. And
I would 100% agree. I just don't know if
that's always the case and I don't know
to what extent I should use their help
if they are materially helping. It's
something that I agree with.
>> So just to respond to that real quick
like I don't have a like I can I'll just
grant you that in certain cases it might
turn out well. It might turn out
positively. I don't have a crystal ball.
I can't perfectly predict the future.
They like took on our labels right like
the label progressive right? If you'd
asked me five maybe 10 years ago like
hey wick are you a progressive? I would
have been more likely to say yes. But
since people like Hassan have uh
absconded that label and have worn that
label even though they are not
progressive they are something else
entirely but they are seen as
progressive. They say they're
progressive. They act like like they
they act like they are the progressive
movement. I think that word has become
like a cancer, right? Does that make
sense?
>> Yeah. But in many ways, we also adopted
a lot of their language. Like I think a
lot of Democrats for example got
extremely woke in their language and got
extremely concerned much more like
intersectional stuff that wasn't really
part of the liberal brand cuz it like
felt good and they could like wear capes
and be like I'm actually, you know, for
the people too guys. Look at me. I'm I'm
I'm a revolutionary. And I think that
that was really damaging. Like for
example, there's this question of
essentially like if we if you view this
as like armies, is there an army that we
can work alongside while fully
recognizing the entire time that we will
be diametrically opposed on a certain
number of areas despite the fact that we
might be unified by a common enemy? Like
right now bring it up because it's brand
dead, not analogous, but that's
literally what we did in World War II.
It's like, yeah, as soon as this war's
over, we're going to fight to the death
of these people. But if we don't, then
we're going to lose. But this is not
analogous to today because
>> why why would you use this sort of why
would you view politics of war? The
purpose of politics is not to be war,
>> right? Um, I think it's analogous to a
line like incentive structures. Like how
do you mobilize people with aligned
incentive structures while
acknowledging? I think the issue that we
had with like the left from 2016 to 2022
is that Standard Lives and Democrats
pretended that they were much more like
the MLS. They took on a lot of the
language and had some others robbed,
right? But they in many ways didn't
excise and go actually we're not quite
like these people. Like you you guys can
with us if you're for like helping us
like further antitrust policies, but
we're not going to with you if you're
like trying to just like fixate on like
um let's say extreme like um non-binary
gender absolutionism or any of this
stuff. Like we're not really vibing with
that. And I think that we sold out in
that way. The question is, can you at
some times work with socialists who you
understand with and not lose all of your
values and principles in the first?
>> Yeah. But but the the the problem with
that, as I was saying, like you're
exactly correct. Um, one of the problems
that liberals and just the left in
general has had is we feel in response
to defend crazy people takes because
they're on our side, right? We will see
someone uh getting called out by libs of
Tik Tok or something. And
>> that has nothing to do with any of the
stuff you're talking about. You could
easily just say, "No, that's really
stupid, but they agree with me on this,
so I'm going to work with them on this
thing."
>> You can do that. They'll say, "Look at
this liberal doing X, Y, and Z. Aren't
they crazy?" And because people see,
"Well, hey, that guy's on my team. I
have to defend him."
>> Should define MLS. MLS typ aren't
typically woke at all.
>> Yeah. I think that's it's by far like a
more conservative ideology, right,
socially. And it's just very funny that
they they lump all these things
together. They take advantage of the
lack of clarity, the lack of rigor,
right? They just lump everybody into
this like amorphous blob so that they
can do Han's bad or anyone else is bad
that they could get into that blob.
Okay, that's that's the whole goal. So,
the lack of rigor, the lack of clarity
is the goal is is sorry, maybe not the
goal. It is a part of what they're
pursuing. A lack of rigor.
>> They'll do this weird thing where they
defend things that they should just not.
And it's a in that way it gets mixed
into kind of like what a liberal is in a
way that hurts us. Does that make sense?
In the way that moderates are like, I
don't [__] with that giant. Most
liberals aren't like this, right? Like,
yeah. I So, again, so this is to the
point of is there a way that liberals
can stand on their own? And as we're
like building this up, there are certain
people that were socialist coded that we
might need to work with that
fundamentally will actually align with
us. That that's that's like the tactical
question exclusively.
>> Okay.
>> Right. Are they sabotagers? Some of them
will inevitably be, but some of them
might just be like
>> I said I I do stand by my nine out of 10
rule, right? Like I think that yes,
you're right in certain cases, but nine
out of 10 times it's it's just going to
be worse for us and it's going to hurt
us. So we shouldn't $5 from
>> I don't know if that's true though,
right? Like um Lauren somebody in your
speaking of super chats to give the
super chats some money. Now somebody
brought up Lauren P. So Lauren P has
worked a little bit with which is not
part of she's leftist coded, right? And
she says that she's a leftist, but she's
a definitely a type of person that I
wouldn't be surprised if liberals were
just a little bit more socially cool and
a little bit like bigger in like the
rhetoric game that she would just
basically be a liberal, right? I think
that she broadly going to is going to
appeal to what she views as what the
left dominantly holds. Um these are the
type of
>> just another really stupid woman who
doesn't understand. She just doesn't get
it, man. She's like kind of just, you
know, it's a trend. Politics is like a
like a social trend for her. She doesn't
get it, but she's awesome and I should
totally appeal to her and try to get her
in my coalition.
What are you saying? What is What is
positive if she has such a shallow
engagement that you don't think any of
her beliefs are sincere?
What is cool about her?
I would I would love to see what what
Erid thinks is cool about her
>> that we chase away.
>> I don't I don't know how to like what
liberally socially cool means. Are we
just not cool enough? I guess I don't
know.
>> Liberals. No, no, I wouldn't say it was
very cool. No,
>> liberals.
>> Look, I'm not the expert on what cool is
or not, right? But I'm just talking like
I I guess I just fundamentally don't
understand that mindset of someone who
just wants to be cool and will go along
with that crowd. I understand it exists.
It's just something I don't I'm not
>> I understand it. It's on the internet
all the time.
>> Yeah.
>> $5 from Dosadia to say the Republicans
made that deal with MAGA. That's what
saying when he says he'd work with Assan
on to further his own names. It's
>> true. No, but they didn't. They actively
opposed them and then MAGA won in the
primary and then took over the party. It
wasn't like, "Oh, we'll work with you."
>> They they literally tried to coordinate
against Trump and they got
>> Does nobody remember all of them
attacking Trump and Trump just being
like, "Your wife is ugly. You're 5 foot
nothing. Does nobody You're low energy."
Does nobody remember this? They were
literally all against Trump. They all
came together to try to attack Trump
every single debate. And it looked awful
for them. They looked
>> Rand Paul. I've had you up to here. He
taps his chest. Okay. immediately
started working with him.
>> They won. Yeah, they won the primary.
And it's like, well, okay, we're not
going to like tank our whole election
because Donald Trump is our candidate
now. Like, that that's a different
story. If Assan is like promoting
tankies in the primary like, yeah, we
need to fight back. And at that point,
if he wins the Democratic primary,
people like that win, I think we're just
like magn
What the he says, is the anti-semitism
prevalent among the lefty tanky folks,
not disqualifying on its own? How could
reasonable Democrats ever work with
them?
>> You are neurotic. You are histrionic.
You this this anti-semitism you claim
does not exist.
At least to the degree you're saying.
Okay. It does exist in some places.
Sometimes it can happen, but
unfortunately it is it's driven from a
place of like nothing. Unfortunately,
you can only complain about this stuff
happening for so long before you start
to become like jaded and bitter and not
morally clear on it. Okay, that's that
does end up happening. The anti-semitism
is there. That does end up happening.
But I'm telling you, all these people
principally are against that kind of
thing. all these people. The second you
start speaking up about this, the second
you start working against it, it will
swap back in. It is not a level of
racial hatred like it is for
right-wingers, like it is for like the
Fuentes of the world. It's not the same.
>> Sorry. So, you guys lost your lost
cause. You should have got a better
handle on Israel. Now, we throw you to
the fires. We try to save our country.
Good luck.
>> It is something where
>> we survived the fires in the 40s. We'll
do it again.
>> There was there was an article written
uh recently that I responded to because
it it was just horrific. It was
horrifically anti-Semitic. uh it was
talking about how uh the title of the
the article was yes all okay so just to
give you an idea okay
>> was it in German
>> no but basically basically it's it was
purportedly author anti-inist uh who
just basically said that the are
entirely responsible um that her people
as a whole were responsible not just the
ones in Israel but all institutions
everywhere I mean I would say I don't
agree with that but if I were if I were
a a whether or not I supported Israel I
would be aware I do not want to appear
to support Israel right now.
>> You know what I'm saying?
>> Reban Ruben donated through
>> Hello Reuben Rubin from Philadelphia.
>> Oh, I see. Yes. Yes. Thank you very
much. In order to be anti-inist,
you have to cheer on Hamas for the
miracle of October 7th. Just the most
essentially this is essentially
position, but there's nobody that will
call it out. So, it's do you think Wait,
I'm curious. You think it's fair to say
that Hassan is better himself.
>> Oh,
>> wait till he undefends and then he can
you can ask your question again.
>> You should ask him.
spoiler. He's going to say, "No, I think
maybe Hassan is a little bit yikesy, but
in general, I wouldn't necessarily say
he's anti mainly focuses on anti-Israel
stuff." He's going to say something
like,
>> "Yes, get guys, get ready to mob this
guy." He's going to say Hassan's not
that anti-Semitic. Actually, I mean, if
you were watching before, I do think Soy
Pill gave a couple like token uh he
calls dimbreads, he calls them all kinds
of things like this. I think he was
talking about that. So, I wouldn't say
that Soy is going to say Hassan's not
anti-Semitic at all. I don't think so.
Didn't seem to be his opinion before. No
one no one no one cheat and type in his
chat uh the answer there. I want to see
Oh, he's
>> I am curious.
>> Go ahead. Go ahead. Would you say that?
Do you think it's not? Is it fair to say
that his rhetoric is across the
threshold of like pretty big
anti-semitism? Of course. Oh, there we
go.
>> Oh,
>> yeah. Cuz I don't just make assumptions
about people. I listen to what they say
and I I I try to be accurate about
people, you know. Wow. Wow.
By the way, I think I think you can let
some of the like inbredad comments, they
don't really affect me that much. I
don't necessarily I have like thoughts
on this on where it's like anti-semitism
versus like outrage over an injustice
that sort of can be conflated pretty
easily, but is not inherently from a
place of anti-semitism. This is the
argument I was making at the time around
October 7th. Anyway, we'll let them
talk.
>> Okay. Wait, Hassan [__] or Mitt Romney?
Who are you voting for?
>> No, me.
>> Mhm.
>> Mitt Romney. Good answer. Okay. $5 from
>> Hey, look. Hey, he invented Obamacare to
an extent, you know.
>> Another black creator trying to steal
from a white
>> is in the getting L's in chat right now.
>> True.
>> I mean, he's
No, no, they're calling him a tanky
sweeper because he says he'll associate
with them depending on certain factors.
That's why they're calling him a tanky
sweeper. That doesn't fix it. But
by the way, I I don't even know if
that's sincere. I wonder if Soel had
like a full conversation on that if he'd
really stick to that position to be
honest with you. I think I think he just
did that cuz he sees no point in
fighting these people who are totally
disingenuous in the first place, right?
Like they aren't holding anything to a
reasonable standard. Oh, it is sincere.
Well, I assume you've had a conversation
with his son's rhetoric is expressing
anti-semitic then even further. How do
you justify working with him? because
the degree to which he perpetuates it is
massed enough that I don't think it's
the same type of [__] that Nick Wendas
is doing. Even it's no it's horrible.
It's like, all right, you can like every
time you call him out for this
anti-semitism, there's a reason why his
audience and anyone who is a useful
idiot will come and be like, well,
actually, I think he's just being a
little, you know, anti-Israel here. And
don't get me wrong, this still spreads
like actual real anti-semitism, I'm
sure, to like the same kind of you see
that uh Wiction
I barely heard. Hold on.
>> Because the degree to which he
perpetuent
is doing, even it's not it's horrible.
It's like, all right, you can
>> How do you justify working with him?
Hold on. Hold on. How do you justify
working with him? How do you justify
working with him, man? How do you
justify working with this guy? Every
time you call him out for this
anti-semitism, there's a reason why his
audience and anyone who is a useful
idiot will come in and be like, "Well,
actually, I think he's just being a
little, you know, anti-Israel here." And
don't get me wrong, this still spreads
like actual real anti-semitism, I'm
sure, to like the same kind of you see
that uh Wick was just talking about
prediction. I I'm talking
>> he dude Soy pill is being way too
consiliatory here. Soy pill is literally
doing all of the little like the like
like throat clearing things to not get
attacked and he still gets attacked. He
is literally cocking in every possible
way. He's like I I think he is like a
he's like still anti-semitic and it's
like not quite as obvious but there's a
reason people like still hear it and
it's anti-ionism to them and not
anti-semitism. Oh, so you you think like
you think it's not that bad? Okay. Well,
you think he's not like Fentes? Well,
you're I'm going to I'm going to take
the win here. You said Hassan's not like
like Nick Fentes. I'm going to take the
win here, guys.
>> On that one, Kyla. I literally
explicit anti-semitism. It's more
masked. Like, yeah. Like, I'm sorry.
It's
>> so hide. I don't I don't even know what
Van is masking. I'm not going to lie.
Every time I
>> these people are not masking in their
like
in in the thing they're pushing okay
which is support for Israel no matter
what Israel first they are not masked
even remotely okay
the anti-semitism that Hassan does which
he absolutely does and acknowledging
that is just as bad as Nick Wendis is
>> it's worse it's worse
>> it's worse I'll tell you why
>> I said be right back and then I heard
this my
god It's worse. It's worse. It's worse.
What is wrong with these people? WHAT IS
ACTUALLY WRONG WITH these people? What
the
>> That [__] I'll be right back.
>> The anti-mitism that Hassan does, which
he absolutely does. I'm acknowledging
that is just as bad as Nick's.
>> It's worse. It's worse.
>> No, it's worse. Can I tell you why we
need to tell you why it's worse about
it?
>> I have never heard if you can find that.
I've never heard say that we should them
all.
>> Go to the [__] you know, go to the
speech where he's got the big screen
behind him. when he's talking about we
need to like go to war with the people
like what are you talking about
>> you no you understand why it's worse
even if even if Fuentes did say that
what Hassan is doing is worse because
it's normalizing it and masking it and
it's much more insidious
>> if you think that
it gives people an excuse it gives
people an excuse
>> no please wait no this is insane if you
think that the people how many
minorities you know that you say that
you would hear say I just wish they
would just come out with it'd be much
better if they just called me the
>> No agree that's so that's ridiculous
it's
>> No it's much more Hassan's audience
audience and like per capita is going to
be more pro the Nick Fentes's audience
different
>> dude these PEOPLE ARE SO DERANGED IT'S
ACTUAL derangement
it's actual insanity it's it's
absolutely crazy to watch
>> it would be more holocausting it because
for the neo-Nazi position is and has
been control all of our country we want
all the out they are in charge of things
like replacement etc but neo-Nazis
follow to Israel. Hassan advocates for a
project of the destruction.
>> Dude, neo-Nazis would never follow Jews
to Israel.
I think you're confusing neo-Nazis with
America first.
Does he think? Why do you think they
love the Hitler clips, Destiny? Why do
you think Nick thinks Hitler's so cool?
What do we What are we doing here, man?
[__] are we doing here? And by the way,
Fentes explicitly says some people will
occasionally go and do this thing with
Fentes. They'll go, "It's not like
racial hatred." Like, you don't think
there's like a blood guilt there, right?
And Fuentes will go, "No, it's not
Zionism. It's not Israel. It's Jew. It's
not Zionism. It's not Israel. Let me be
very clear for the people in the back.
It's Jew."
That is what he says. Now, do they stop
being when they get to Israel? Do they
stop being evil when they get to Israel?
I feel like they don't. And for a long
time, Destiny would argue that you're
actually just sweeping for them. If you
say that they are going to stop when
they go to Isra, like if you if you say
they just want them out of the country
and they never hurt them, you're
sweeping for these guys. Now, we've
started arguing the opposite. No, no,
no. They're really sincere about just
letting these people all go to Israel
and it's it's fine. Totally fine, man.
The same people arguing that Hassan is
more anti-semitic and dangerous than
Fentes are the same ones that rightfully
recognize that people who have more for
AOC than MTG or Tucker Carlson have lost
the plot. Yeah. Yeah. No, it's totally
accurate of the state of Israel would
support military action to do it. Much
the same
Israel is based. This is terrible. I'm
not saying I do so much.
>> Go ahead. I don't I don't
>> I do genuinely believe that
>> I do genuinely believe that a
substantial amount of Hassan's audience
are just they would believe anything.
>> Dude,
why are they thinking that Hassan would
nuke Israel? I'm sorry. Why would Why
are they thinking Hassan would nuke
Israel? What part of Hassan's character
leads you to believe that he would nuke
Israel? Are you out of your minds?
>> Like it's debatable to what extent.
Look, okay, Nick Fuentes is a neo-Nazi
who says you have no place in
civilization and you're comparing this
to Hassan who is anti-Semitic who is
conflating Israel and Judaism and is
saying a bunch of horrible and saying
these things are worse than what Nick is
saying. I don't know what reality we
live in. This is anti-semitism because
they're both
the neo-Nazi anti-semitism doesn't
extend past the borders of your country.
It's because are interested in
destroying whatever the fabric of your
country through mass migration or
whatever else. But Hassan
>> Yeah. inherently at a genetic level.
What do you think? What do you do? Do
you think Nick thinks that they're going
to go back to Israel and go, "Oh, well,
we lost America. That's fine. We'll let
America thrive." Do you think Nick
thinks that? What part of Nick talking
ever makes you think that once once
everybody's old are expelled from from
America? What part of Nick's
anti-semitism makes you think that, oh,
the will just be nice now that we kick
them all out? They'll be nice and
they'll go to Israel and they'll just
let America thrive.
Are we Are we serious right now? Are we
actually Are we for real right now? I I
I don't know. I don't know what we're
doing.
>> Anti-mitism comes from an anti-western
anti-imperialist would follow them to
the Middle East where he would want them
to be removed from Israel. That's why he
like you're never going to hear from a
neo-Nazi like go back to Brooklyn or
whatever else, right? If anything,
neoazi would be happy if every off to
Israel. Whereasan wants the country of
Israel to be destroyed. They think that
they literally say no. Neoaz are also
anti-Israel.
>> No, they're anti-America working. Dude,
WHAT PART? THIS GUY'S DEBATED Fentes on
this topic. How did he not understand
any of this? How did he not pick up
anything? Not all neo-Nazis are
anti-Israel. They're only ever
performatively pro-Israel in that they
will support an ethnostate because they
like ethnostates. They still think that
ethnostate is filled with people who
they just want their ethnostate. And
once they get their ethnostate, they're
going to go deal with the other
ethnostates. 100% down the line, they're
they're going to go deal with that
ethnostate. The only other view that
exists amongst people who could be
called neo-Nazis are the BAP people who
are just a Zionist plot, okay,
themselves. Okay, that's they literally
are. It's they're literally people who
support Israel who are trying to get
right-wingers to be racist and
proethnostate but also support Israel.
I'm sorry. That is that is the state of
play. Buy me somebody else who falls
outside of this. I would love to see it
with Israel. No, there's so no, you're
thinking of like Christian nationalists
that are specifically looking at this,
but they're so neaz
when you say anti-Israel in Israel in so
far as they exert influence over the
United States or force the US to get
involved with wars. That's why they say
like America first, it's not Israel
because Israel is going to go to war
with Iran.
>> But they also want to kill all the
because of that. Like that's what I'm
saying. But why does that matter if
they're like well oh they want if they
if they left them alone? Yeah. But they
think that they control everything and
are evil. Like what what is this
distinction?
>> If we're not drawing a distinction there
then then there's even less of a
distinction between Hassan's perspective
which is that Zionism is inherently like
a what did he say on CNN? ethno
religious supremacist nationalist
project like and and 90% of they're
Zionist. So he would call for basically
the elimination of 90% of people. Like
what did he say before? What was it two
days ago? He said they should all go
back to the Russian oblast for like way
off in the east. Like
>> I I I don't know. Show me. I'll grade it
next to the
>> he thinks if you support this genocide,
you are a terrible human being who
shouldn't be accepted back into society.
>> That's that's true. That's a comment on
the genocide though. That's a comment on
like what is being allowed to occur.
civilization.
This is why you can't make these
gambles, right? So the statement that I
just said, right? So like like um chat
literally agrees with this, right? How
is that wrong? That's true, right? So
your child even agrees with these what
are they agreeing with is an
ethnosremist religious supremacist
project and that the state
>> isn't Zionism ethnremist.
>> No, it's not. Only if your understanding
of that is is a child's notion of a lot
more than I can't say.
>> No, how is it saying it's not saying
it's a supremacist by ethnically
protecting a country is it has to be an
ethnically supremacist position that you
can't
Destiny's defending the ethnost state.
DESTINY'S DEFENDING THE ETHNOST STATE.
LET'S GO. LET'S GO.
This is Hey, Kraut. Kraut, you want to
speak up on how this is um these are
liberals, right? Aren't these classical
liberals that are defending the
ethnostate concept right now? Hey,
Kraut. Kraut, aren't you ready to step
in and say, well, that's not about
that's not liberal values at all right
now. If you're an ethnostate that that
purges all non-Jews out of your area and
then treats them differently within your
society, I would say that's kind of
ethnosopremist. Yeah.
>> No. Ethnos supremacist is different than
protecting the ethnicity of a country,
right?
>> In in protecting it, you're expelling
another peoples and your explicit
mission is to like get all the Gazins
out of the West Bank and the Gaza Strip.
This is ethnosmreist and religion
supremacist.
>> If I can't I can't if that's your
perspective, then that's fine. This you
have the perspective of a child. Can't
you see I am obviously intuitively
correct? Dude, does this guy make
arguments anymore? When when did this
guy stop making arguments? This is the
guy who used to say he was the best
debater on the internet. He doesn't even
attempt an argument anymore. He just
does an exasperated sigh and shuts his
Yeah.
What in the world is happening? Time
stamp. Uh minus 1 hour 36. I can't get
you a direct time stamp. I don't have
the the script. Tell me why it's not. I
mean, that's how it sounds to me.
>> It's not about It's not about one
religion dominating another. It's about
people having feeling like they want to
protect the ethnic group in their
country. This is like, oh yeah, they
don't want to expel black people. They
just want to protect the white
population, right? Like you can phrase
it that way. But like it seems to me
that this is why we're
>> No. Don't you understand that they've
been programmed? They've been
programmed. So So because they've been
programmed, they get to do whatever they
want. They you once the Holocaust
happens, they get a free ethnostate
automatic. Automatic, man.
Zionists want to expel the Gaz and the
Palestinians, right? Like
>> that's how you don't have to expel black
people in the United States. There's no
reason for that. They're not a threat to
the white people. So it wouldn't make
sense in that sense. Whereas for
>> inherently inherently they're not
>> what are we saying about the
Palestinians now inherent oh uhoh are a
huge minority so there's a different
I'm saying that the the
>> dude so every single white supremacist
is just like reaching over for their FBI
crime statistics right now and frothing
at the mouth at this. They're not
inherently like a pro. They're not
they're not like a threat to anybody. OH
MY GOD. HAVEN'T YOU SEEN THE FBI? OH MY
GOD. WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
>> THE DESIRE to protect the ethnicity
comes from a different place in ethnos
supremacy. It comes from a place of
there's an ethnicity that the country
wants to protect.
>> This is a distinction without a
difference in me
>> position and expelling a bunch of people
that are of not of your ethnicity
because well the because I'm better than
them. It's cuz they're dangerous to me.
>> We can commit to a crime. That's the
only reason.
>> Oh, so Bill found it. Soyel threaded the
needle. Listen, why do why do black
people commit so much crime? They seem
kind of dangerous to me. I think that
might be a problem. We would have to
actually get them out, wouldn't she say?
>> Ethnic in Israel, but those ethnics all
flipped against Israel and were also
like working with terrorist groups to
attack Israeli civilians. Do you think
Israel would want them out in the same
way that they want like
>> I don't think that disproves what we're
saying.
>> Well, it well potentially in this case,
right? They might be willing to like try
to
work with the minorities
>> literally. Yeah. Do you think Do you
think the fascists aren't ready to put
you in the firing squad right now for
liking blacks?
I you could flip every one of these
hypotheticals.
Like it's
>> then you've betrayed your country.
>> It's just
>> Sorry, I don't want to do the thing. You
can flip every one of these
hypotheticals. You obviously could make
the argument that if you were working
against the aims of white supremacists
and they ended up winning that if you
had worked significantly against them in
a way that they thought was dilatorious
to the future of their country,
dilitterious to the existence of their
people, they could justify killing you
and they would probably do so. I'm sure
that some German soldiers who were
sympathetic to people and tried to hide
them got killed in the Holocaust. No,
I'm guessing that's almost certainly a
thing. Or did they go, "Well, you're one
of the uber mench, so actually we won't
kill you, and that's the only way you're
ethnostremacist."
So if Germany refused to execute German
guards who like tried to sneak somebody
out of the out of a concentration camp,
if they refused to kill them, that means
that they're truly ethnosists because
they weren't willing to,
I guess. But if they killed those
people, they wouldn't be ethnosremacist.
So if they killed those people, if they
killed somebody who was a German who was
trying to help, you know, people out of
Germany or something, that would prove
that Nazis were not ethnosremacist in
Aerodit's world. Very cool. Very
awesome. You love to you love to see
arguments like this.
>> In the same way
that's willing to work with the
minorities and you've betrayed your
country and your peoples, like yeah, but
I don't think that means they're not
ethos supremacist. This is a
>> Okay, we could have this is real debate
another day. Uh $5. Well, you have to
establish a Jew saying that they're
better, not that they're like worried
about like safety.
>> For the two Canadian, which they do,
>> this is by definition, Judaism is not
like a it's not a proitizing religion.
They don't try to convert people into
their OR WHATEVER.
>> YOU JUST ARGUED SOMETHING. I'M SORRY,
BILL. You
What THE IS YOUR PROBLEM? YOU LITERALLY
JUST ARGUED HIS POINT,
DUDE. DUDE, you literally Why don't they
try to proitize? Why don't they add
people to the religion? Because they're
the chosen people.
That's like that that has been a part of
the religion for a very long time.
They're the chos people
>> ever. Dude, dude, what do you think
birthright is? That's what they're
constantly trying to do this.
>> They're not trying to convert people
right is literally exactly not that.
Birthright is bringing
>> Yeah. They want them to come in and they
try and they try to make them more
culturally more religious.
>> What do you think? What does the birth
part in birthright stand for? It's
boring. I know that they're already they
want them to become more religious. It's
like, dude, come on. Like,
>> no. They want them to join the country.
They don't care about the not just join
the country
of the culture and the [__] religion.
They do this all the time. This is a
leftist talking.
Judaism has nothing.
>> He want Judaism has nothing to do with
the religion. Did he just say that?
>> This is a leftist. Judaism has nothing.
Judaism has nothing to do with the
religion.
Wait, do they have like religious
symbology on all of their money and like
all over their their country and their
their society?
Do they give exemptions to join the
military specifically for who are too
religious who have a religious like
opposition to it? That one could be just
because they're buying political votes.
But still still
>> I think he means well I think what he
means there is he probably means Zionism
or being Israeli Israel is nothing to do
with the um the religion. That's
probably what he means. I saying Judaism
has nothing to do with the religion is
yeah it's it's like a [__]
people to go to synagogue in Isra.
But I will say that is a thing Destiny
does is he tries to talk over people and
he says utter nonsense. Like just total
and complete nonsense, right? Like he
just doesn't want Soy Pill to make his
point. So he's going to say nonsense
over him for as long as he can to stop
Soy Pill from making his point. I think
he realized that he said something
stupid now. So he had to stop
>> because they want them to become part of
this cultural movement. This is just a
thing. I'm not even saying
they're not promoting a religion.
Ridiculous.
>> The point of birth is to bring back to
Israel so they can show up the
demographic majority so they can absorb
more Arabs that they have to.
nationalist. Just to be clear, it is a
national going to temple birth.
>> They do that. They promote this as well
as part of birthight. They literally
promote religious teachings.
>> Okay. Okay. Okay. Hold on. You guys can
debate this another day. $5 from Grman.
For the two Canadians, so this is to Dev
and Erdite. Who do you think is more
extreme? Hassan or Avi Lewis, the new
head of the federal NDP in terms of
policy and how they act.
>> Yeah. Theodore Herzel was was um it was
a Zionist, sorry. Zionism was about a
nation state for for Israelis based on
the ethnicity that these people were not
inherently religious. But I will say
upon the founding of Israel upon so
Herzel dies way before they actually
found Israel upon the founding of Israel
they do make several decisions that have
explicitly to do with the religion as
well and that progresses that that gets
absolutely put in over time becomes like
increasingly increasingly important
right I don't think anybody denies that
Herzel himself was about land was about
a nation but once they obtained that
nation they absolutely became very
religious at that time like they they
started incorporating turning these
elements into the the because it it had
to be like all hands on deck, right?
>> I don't know anything about Avi Lewis. I
I know that he's fighting with the
Alberta people, but I don't know
anything about Avi Lewis.
>> Anything about
>> uh talking about like monies, first of
all,
>> to Pave. Hell, invest it. Anything but
PV.
>> I'm not talking about like monies. First
of all, I do not have the money to like
change elections. I'll donate like 20
bucks to a candidate that I like. What
I'm talking about is like, hey, a bunch
of my audience is like, "What do we do?
What do we do? We're looking to you."
And so when I see Destiny Vos do this
[__] where it's like let's get all of
you guys out here and try to flip this
that matters is going to help us get the
Senate majority. I want to do that. And
stop killing people. Stop blowing stuff
up. Stop killing people. Stop blowing
stuff up. Stop exping. Stop ethnic
cleansing. Stop killing people. Stop
ethnic cleansing. Stop blowing stuff up.
Stop killing people. Stop ethnic
cleansing. That's the only conversation
that needs to happen. So easy. Oh, stop
the aparthides. Sure. Sure. Stop the
oppression. It's over and over and over
again. All right.
>> Apparently, there are other organs that
are not PB that are doing that. So I'll
I'll hop on there if they're the ones
who are working with us on. So
>> $20 from Odashara to say, "Soyill, which
group of creators in these political
projects would do more advocacy for the
Democrats in general? Progressive
victory or digital ground game?" There
is your answer.
>> Sounds like digital ground game. Yeah.
>> $5 from Audacity say just just tie your
career to these people. Just tie your
career to these people. Soy pill, you'll
be fine. That person's a literal
schizophrenic who sent that super chat,
by the way.
>> Literal schizophrenic.
>> Good points. But how does this ensure we
give Israel another 578 bazillion
dollars, dudes? Bro,
>> $10 from Odashara who they want him. End
quote. You should care. The type of
rhetoric will create either
unenthusiastic voters or [__] third
party voters. There needs to be
>> This guy has a 60 IQ, by the way. He is
one of the dumbest human beings that
I've ever had the displeasure of sharing
a VC with.
>> I live in Los Angeles and none of us
normies think Newsome is a genocide.
Most of the normies I've know like him
because he's standing up to Trump. That
seems like a bigger factor to me.
>> Yeah.
>> I guess this is reference to the enemy
Charlie thing that you were saying
earlier, right?
>> Sure. Sure. It's just like there just is
a lot of like socialisty I don't I don't
even want to speak for her name any char
exact specific positions. I don't know
if they've ever talked about gavismism.
They're just like I don't know just in
LA there are just a lot of these types
of socialist people that are like
socialist champion socialist types that
>> Why does she keep doing it? She just
keeps doing it over and over again. Hy
Charlie and this Nimma person are like
turbo who have no idea what they really
think cuz they've never looked into
anything. They're just stupid bimbos who
have never bothered to do any deeper
research i.e. watch a Destiny stream,
right, to get the real opinions.
How are you a woman? You do this to
other women. How am I How have I become
the guy who notices this and points it
out? I'm It's so
I just want to go back to being able to
be misogynist. These people made being
misogynist so uncool. It sucks.
>> Can easily be moved in one direction or
the other based on what I think Newsome
is based and
>> she's on board.
>> I'm going to call trap on that tweet
because every single person I knew in
California hated Newsome. So, I'm
calling super mega cap on that tweet.
>> Fair enough. I don't know anyone in
California because
>> all the LA people I know hate Gavin
Newsome, but maybe I just know a select
crew of LA people.
>> Gavin gets a lot of for his like
homeless policies and his inefficiency,
but like he said,
if there's anything you don't like, I'm
going to middle ground. One, I'm getting
wings for dinner. Two, my don't want in
the coalition
forever. It's power. They just want to
endlessly critique power, which is
usually true. It was a good
amount of agree with that that we
definitely don't want the coalition also
like this. They say far more than don't.
>> Yeah, that was that was the the kill
shot tweet their entireity. Okay, $5 by
sending an email about a mission. Please
respond. You guys can do that.
>> $10 from kid H regarding unsophisticated
LA. If you're convinced it could be over
the motor only then consider them.
Regardless, your time would likely be
spent better spent elsewhere.
>> I could get Charlie on board in 10
seconds. So
>> it's just it's just not a
>> You hear that Charlie? You hear that
Charlie?
>> I'm I'm sorry. What dude? I don't want
to be the guy who hears this. I don't
want to be that guy man.
What? I need I need a soy person. I need
a soy co-host who can freak out about
this stuff so I don't have to. Okay, I'm
I'm done. I'm done. I'm done. I'm done.
>> Zero some game. It's like you can
>> tech 10 seconds with soy pill will set
her straight. Now, is that talking about
an Israel or herbs?
>> Obviously, just do both things. You can
try to bolster liberal voices and invite
like LA socialites to liberal events and
and collab with them. Like, it's just
obviously you could do do both of these
things. It's just obviously if I'm
interfacing with somebody further and
further left my collab
>> and just like that we're back and just
like that we're so back in costic
because we disagree about everything.
>> Okay. $10 from dirty deeds to say the
answer is always
>> corrective debate incoming.
>> Simply ask yourself if X creator
explains worldview and you're willing to
fight and die what they want. They are
not your friend.
>> So I'm so sorry. I'm
>> When is [__] unameric?
>> I don't want I don't want to say these
things. These are these are crazy. is
unfuck America going to make college
chapters to challenge the Kirk Jun and
YDSA losers.
>> There we are. I'm pretty sure, right?
>> Don't know.
>> They're trying to make college chapters.
>> These people are far more effective in
organizing the groups than anything that
left or liberal people do to be honest.
Like Dave and I probably remember some
of this [__] like
>> also progressivism developed as a
critique of liberalism in 18. It was
okay. What was it? Do you remember it
>> with an illegal immigrant who doesn't
California in like Tennessee? So like uh
it depends on what level assimilation
we're looking for. Okay. Uh, $5 from O.
Can we get a collab and get Lauren Petta
Pettra and Mont Madre? I have faith that
Kyla can bring them on our side.
>> I don't know those people.
>> Lauren P is the girl that kind of like
LA kind of. Yeah,
>> I don't know who Mont Madre is.
>> Not Not sure.
>> $5 from Granite Hard. Airite keeps
conflating any interaction with working
with a creator on a political project.
We interact with leftists by disagreeing
with them.
>> That I don't believe I've ever
>> I'm just guessing that this Lauren
person is very attractive. Uh, yeah.
Yeah, this is this is the person. Guys,
can anyone can anyone figure out why
Erdite thinks that this I think this is
the person. I'm not totally sure. Can
anybody figure out why this person would
be somebody that wants to collaborate?
>> What's your favorite promise that you've
broken so far?
>> There's so many. It's hard to choose.
>> I got time. What a beautiful piece of
art this is.
>> Wow.
>> Really beautiful. What's your favorite
promise that Trump
>> Wow. Wow. Wow. Wow. I wonder what's
going on there. Good luck to you in
watching content.
>> Travacia for $5. Question to the entire
panel. Do we all agree that the critique
the far left makes against Gavin is and
should be ignored regarding trans stuff?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> I just wish I was wrong. I actually wish
I was wrong. Sometimes I wish I was
wrong. Okay. I really do.
>> He's like explicitly protrans in like
several different ways and pass a bunch
of protransis. It was literally like
ahead of the curve on LGBT issues than
any other person in California. Not any
other person than most politicians. And
the idea that it's like oh yeah, but
he'll throw trans people because he went
on a podcast with with The transition
should be in sports, I'm pretty sure,
which is like true obviously.
>> There are questions.
>> This is this is a good example of why
appealing to leftists is is just a
fool's errand because as soon as you say
something that's off script, it doesn't
matter in the past.
>> Can you point to the person in this call
that wants to appeal to leftists?
>> I'm saying it to the audience who in my
chat there are plenty of people who are
disagreeing with me. Okay.
>> Sure.
>> Yeah. No, I had a recent dust up with a
very big leftwing YouTuber named Nara
who basically said the same thing
because I'm not protrans women sports. I
was the same as like weird like
privilege. I just like it's either
privilege or you're lying. Like you
don't act. Dev would never be
anti-trans. That's the only thing he's
attracted to. He would never be
anti-trans. Okay. Ever. Ever. Ever. Dev
is the biggest chaser. And you're
accusing him of being anti-trans. Come
on, man.
>> Obviously mean that them if you think
about it for like 3 seconds.
>> Mhm.
>> Uh $5 from fancy teeth. Why is it so
hard? These people are sabotur. Why are
we helping them? True. $5 from real
terminatics.
>> Wait on that one. Wait. So like if
anyone's asking me like, "Hey, should we
like capitulate to like a Hassan point
or like should we prop up Hassan's
movement?" The answer is obviously no
cuz I think it's insane and terrible and
harmful and there are saboturs. The
question is should we let them help us
if we think that would benefit us more
not are we propping them up.
>> Yes.
>> And what this is the question this is
the practical question we let them help
us like like I said if they are willing
to come and work with us I think that's
a different question than if they get
together a political movement and say we
want liberal creators come out and help
us with this. I think those are two
separate questions. Does that make
sense?
>> Okay probably in part depends on what
they want help with. If what they want
help with condition it's always going to
be policy. It's always going to be a
question of like well what what are we
doing
for leftist candidate? No.
>> So he's disappointing me. I mean, to be
honest, it's just a struggle session.
It's been a struggle session the whole
time. I think he's probably being
sincere, but he is maybe maybe all of
his sincere positions just perfectly opt
out of the struggle session. I feel like
there's got to be something else going
on there a little bit, but I don't know.
>> No, if you want me to support Democrat,
Republican every single time, yes, of
course. But the rule of thumb here still
stands for me is that nine times out of
10, it's going badly for you.
>> I'm going to need I'm going to source
something.
>> He's a weak man. Uh, that's the only
criticism I wouldn't make right now that
he's weak. He's pointed out where he's
correct. He's not argued it when people
like refuse to actually make their own
arguments when they get like just very
like little baby throwing a tantrum
moments. He's not going to keep going,
but he just makes sure it's like clear
that he's correct. So, if he ever has to
go back to this and point it out, he
just do so, right? I don't think he's
weak at all here. That's like maybe I I
disagree with a lot of his positions,
but I wouldn't say he's weak. How? What
do you mean?
>> You being seen working with these people
is going to be so cancerous. It you're
going to it's like they have a stench
and that's going to rub off on you and
you have to take
>> I feel like moderates are so much more
like just like they're just like less
animallike as an audience. Like I feel
like if I spend a lot of time
>> are moderates people around you? They're
less animallike as an audience. Have you
ever I I want Erin to go and the next
time Pixie tweets something I want her
to go read the replies. Actually, maybe
not even now, like three months ago. Go
read the replies on some pixie tweets.
>> I'm just saying less animallike, guys.
>> And with progressives, but as long and
like leftists, but I'm like sufficiently
pushing back more or less on the all the
things that we disagree on or whatever.
I don't think anyone would be like, "Oh,
I mean, I like that Kyla girl, but like
she talks to FD signifier." I think as
long as it's like, "Yeah, I mean, I
disagree with FD signifier on
significant enough things, right?" The
real question is, do we help them in
like political campaigning in areas
where they're like robbing and stealing
of our culture and do we let them take
our language and more importantly, do we
take on their language? And the answer
obviously has to be no. Liberals should
have a backbone and a culture and a
community and stand by it and defend one
another and protect each other and
support each other.
>> Liberalism is like by its definition
like the it is not a culture by
definition. Unfortunately, liberalism is
like a negatively defined concept.
I it is tough for it to be a thing and
stand on something because it is by
definition not that thing. Right? That
is the that is the point of liberalism.
No,
it is like literally neg it's defined by
what you shouldn't be doing. It's like
everything else. It is the negative.
It's a negatively defined thing. What is
the culture?
>> I I don't I don't think so. I think a
lot of moderates are turned off when we
work with leftists and and things like
that. I think a lot of them will just
abandon us if they do that. Um and that
really I feel like they'll abandon us.
>> This is the culture they they purport to
to follow. Yes. I don't think that's the
but I also don't think that's good. I
think that's quite actually say gender
doesn't exist and we should abolish
gender. But I don't think they abandon
us if we
>> and that's capitulating to a leftist
narrative. That's not working with a
leftist. And to be fair, if you're
leaving my movement because I'm working
with someone who I don't agree with who
says I'm supporting you, then you don't
support my movement. And
>> I'm not even sure about that. Like I've
I've I've embraced like the the pronoun
thing entirely.
>> Okay. We are definitely circling the
drain hardcodely.
I've completely adopted that to
>> Trump because you got
>> Does anybody have a time stamp for
Zoyill's stream so I could go watch his
retrospective or did Substance get the
entire clip? cuz I know Substance
clipped it. But is that all we need is
just the clip? I would assume there's
like a little bit like this is also
someone where it's like okay you clearly
don't give a [__] about these like
movements. You don't think I don't think
I like I would if Taly invited like I
wouldn't work with her on like a
political project to collaborate
but I would have her on my show. Wait
wait wait wait. I just want to say I
just want to pay I just say real quick
wait cuz you're very good at like you
speak very honestly without realizing
how honest you're being. Every single
time you were challenging my position
earlier you kept saying like somebody
that was like slightly critical or
somebody like oh I get so bad like your
words are very like couch but for here
you actually just restated my position
perfectly when which I could have
answered you perfectly. said, "Would you
work with Tally or whatever?" This is
that one. Is she that Jew girl who hates
Korean people? Yes.
>> You said you said, "Would you work with
her if she wasn't willing to support
your candidate?" No. That was so easy,
but you perfectly absolutely with
absolute clarity stated my position
there. It's interesting that you state
it so clearly there with regards to her,
but seem to obiscate or soft the
language when it ever had to do
anything. That was very willing to raise
money for my candidate. If he's willing
to promote a candidate that I support,
then I would work with her. That's the
point.
>> The instant clear
if we mean on the show with Yes. If we
mean work with as in put together like a
coalition, right, to kind of like
>> Yeah. That's what everyone means. Soy
bill also to your ear the pron joke. Uh
it's
>> not actually
>> destiny just tried this like oh actually
you share my position completely. No soy
bill just restated the exact position
you guys have been making him struggle
over for the past three hours.
>> No like you know who victor weapon is
right the premise of Hungary.
>> You you guys adopted his position by the
way not the position you were arguing
before right and not a position you're
applying consistently. you are. The way
they're doing it is they're going,
"Well, anybody would support the
candidate." But then they're going,
"Well, if you frequent if you're willing
to call this like a genocide repeatedly,
then you're not supporting the
candidate." And so the entire contention
was, "Well, no, I think you can call it
a genocide, you can be super against it
and still admit that in reality, like
Camala Harris is better than Donald
Trump, even on Israel. And while I
called it a genocide, you should go vote
for her." And Desi said, "No, that's
inherently contradictory." That was the
disagreement, right? But it's all it's
all like weasling around the edges so
that they could cut Hassan out and get
somebody like Charlie in. And that's
probably just not possible,
unfortunately. You if you just operate
off of spite alone, you're never going
to get the exact coalition you want,
which is probably why you shouldn't.
>> Goes to to CPAC in the US. I think
speeches in English where he tells you
Americans that he saved Hungary from
gender pronouns. Um, there are Hungarian
is a gender neutral language. There are
no gender pronouns in Hungary. That's a
joke. There's only the pronouns uh
that's it. Like it's it's saving Hungary
from something that doesn't exist. So
that's why when you find Hungarian lives
and leftwingers on social media, they
often put the pronouns in the bio to
make fun of that fact because he would
never give that speech in Hungarian
because it wouldn't make sense. That's
basically that.
>> Here's the one that you wanted to
answer. I found it. Um Mr. uh Mr. Dev,
this is from
Kylie.
>> Bad is Trump and equally corrupt.
>> No, I didn't.
>> As Canadians, do you wanted to answer? I
found it. Um Mr. uh Mr. Dev,
>> hold on. What is this? This is from
Kyla once implied was as bad as Trump.
Equally corrupt.
>> No, I didn't.
>> Uh oh, that's the Jesse Lee Peterson
thing, right? And she's going to say,
"Well, I was meing on Jesse Lee Peterson
the whole time."
>> Do both believe that.
>> She said, "Oh, gun to my head." It was
It was Heming and Hawing. No, it was
Heming and Hawing. But she's going to
say she was voted Trudeau over P.
>> Would I have voted for Trump over P?
>> Of course not. I mean, leader.
>> No, obviously not. the [__]
>> Well, see see was
>> I I might have voted polyv over Trudeau
at some point. Uh before before Trump
got in a second term, as soon as Trump
got in a second term, I was never voting
for anybody who wasn't like vehemently
opposed. That that flipped my vote in
the election. Trump how Trump acted
towards Canada flipped my vote in my
Canadian election. It's up.
>> It's actually crazy.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Every American
that gets so twisted about one joke that
I made to an alien old man, uh which is
um
>> Yeah. See, she's just saying, "Oh, I'm
actually lying." people. What's his
name? Uh Peterson. Peterson.
>> I just wouldn't compare him to kind of
crazy is so obnoxious because every
Canadian will tell you super super
corrupt. A lot of Canadians don't like
>> Paul. I don't know who you're talking
about. Paul, but Paulv,
Mr. Paulv, Pierre Paulv, he was against
Trump, but he wasn't. He he had been
cozing up to Trump for a long time. He
was winking at populism stuff, and I was
just super dumb with it. Super super
dumb with it.
>> No, typically I go to NDP, actually. So,
you're welcome.
>> Yeah, there was a lot of
>> There were several high-profile scandals
in Canada. There was the cherry scandal.
Yes. And seeing scandal huge.
>> Yes. Oh my god.
>> Mind-blowing. Huge. When Americans are
like
>> nothing on the order of anything to do
with with um America at all. It's like
minor. It's like minor corruption. And
it is stuff I wouldn't vote for him
over. But it's it's nothing like what
Trump's done. Not even a little bit. Not
even a little close.
>> I made one joke where I was like, "Oh
man, it's tough between Trump and
Trudeau." It's not actually Trump tough.
Obviously, it's still Trudeau. But
Trudeau sucks. That's the joke. But
welcome to the joke. Trump sucks and
like him.
>> What Trudeau did in the SNC scandal is
Trumpike. And
>> it is. It was horrifying.
>> And also,
>> please ask, please ask Ardite to say
what happened in the S SNC Lavlin
scandal.
>> Please, please, please.
>> It was a few months ago, I think the
Canadian Supreme Court ruled that the
emergency powers Trudeau used during the
trucker protest uh was unconstitutional.
Like Trudeau was a terrible prime
minister. Doesn't mean that that
liberals in
>> h that trucker protest should have been
handled way sooner. The only criticism I
have for Trudeau in the trucker protest
is that he didn't send cops in with
nightsticks to beat the [__] out of
those people sooner. Okay. only
criticism.
>> Terrible, but he was just uniquely bad
for the Liberal party.
>> Fair enough.
>> He just had his reputation saved.
>> Trump $2 for one hero HQ to say Wick is
right. We should just prefer you to say
it. Okay. Well, thank you for that. I
appreciate you. Uh $5 from real Trump
not to say soy bill will unironically
support the second worst on a topic by
virtue of them not being the number one
worst person on a topic.
>> Support them. I think that's doing a lot
of heavy liar to say soy bill. Yes or
no? Uh channeling his inner peace. If
the minority because all of Israel was
taken over, do you think they would be a
second holocaust?
>> No. Yeah, probably. I mean, they're
surrounded by people who want to kill
them.
>> Okay. tectonic or being antinist. How
does that make sense?
>> Because Zionism is like, well, we need a
homeland. It has to be in this specific
place that's going to cause constant war
and turmoil. And I don't know if I
support that. I think that yeah, there
should be a place that Jews call their
home in the fact that they're kicked out
everywhere and there's anti-mitism
everywhere. But the idea the only
solution to this is to establish this
historical homeland that is never ever
going to be solved is constantly going
to be having war fought back and forth
and killing millions and millions of
people. I think it's ridiculous. I think
I think this is where they should spread
out other countries. I don't think you
can just give them a
constantly genocide against which is why
they constantly which is why they want
this, right? Because
>> give them
do American thing. Give him a
reservation in America somewhere. I
don't know. Like the idea that has to be
in Israel is ridiculous. Case in point.
Okay.
>> You're advocating for the full ethnic
cleansing language from Israel, right?
>> No.
>> Just say yes. Yes.
Anyway, it's already we're already
by the way.
>> Sorry. I've got this way too fast for
the actual argument. There's a
substantial argument happening at the
end here and I didn't expect it. So, I
got to keep listening.
>> Genocided against which is why they
constantly which is why they want this,
right? Because Jews
>> give them give them Manhattan Island.
from Brooklyn.
>> Do do a do a Native American do a Native
American thing. Give him a reservation
in America somewhere. I don't know. Like
the idea that
>> I will say Bill's super confusing to me
now. Why is he he's somehow arguing that
like actually they shouldn't have
Israel. Like actually they shouldn't
have Israel at all. Move them all out.
It seems to be I'm like what? Wait,
what? I'm conf Now now I'm confused. Now
I'm like giga confused. What the are you
talking about?
>> Has to be in Israel. It's just
ridiculous.
>> Case in point. Okay.
>> Wasn't make him answer. You just say
you're advocating for the full ethnic
cleansing of Jews from Israel, right?
>> The No,
>> just say yes. Yes.
>> Obviously, this can't work anyway. It's
already We're already into
Just say it. Just say by the way the
position ethically doesn't matter. This
is what I mean when I say leftists have
a more anti-semitic position than that
that would cash out into a more antic.
Don't you get it soy pill?
>> You are always a tanky [__]
>> You just didn't realize it. All it took
was talking to Destiny for long enough
and now he can see that you are an
insane tanky who wants all killed. Okay.
So I hope you are happy that now that's
you. That's you now buddy. talk to
Destiny long enough he can figure out
how to call you anti-semitic. Let's go.
Soy pill is an anti-semitic like
borderline holocaust denying I would
think. Piece of I'm guessing a lot of
people are going to carry that forward
now than neo-Nazis do. What do you mean
you don't? You just said you want them
to flee Israel and go to all other
places on the planet. That's an ethnic
cleansing from Israel.
>> Clarify obviously this is not available
now. We they've been established there
for 80 years. Okay. Now I don't know
what the you do. It is. No, if you snap
my fingers and teleport Israel, like
lift it up like a big island and drop it
next to Manhattan, I would. And that
would be ethnic cleansing, but they
don't really need to travel into Libya
and Egypt and all this. But like, no, I
don't want to like expel them. I don't
think we should kick them off their
land. Obviously, there's too
established. This is like saying like,
yeah, I don't support the
>> Okay, clearly fixed it. Hopefully none
of that happens.
>> Genocide and the expelling of Native
Americans, but guess what? It's been
like 400 years. I don't know how you
rectify this at that point. you need to
find a way to like I don't know how to
solve Israel Palestine but no obviously
what I mean is the project of Zionism to
establish it in Israel and the way that
they did this I think was destructive as
I think it's led to all these problems I
I think they should have chosen
something different at the time and so
the idea
>> when you're saying anti-ionist as in you
don't want them to be the majority in
their country anymore so then what
>> stop killing people stop blowing up
buildings stop destroying everybody's
capacity to be happy at any point in
their lives stop killing civilians stop
killing children stop starving civilians
Stop starving. Stop starving children.
Okay,
that's it. Don't try to get Don't try to
do a gotcha on some definition. This is
why it's Dude, it's I'll do it in a way
a three-year-old could understand. Stop
hitting that other guy. Stop. Stop. No,
I don't care what he did. I don't care
what he did. You stop. We're better than
that. You stop. Stop now. Actually, no
more money. No more treats until you
stop and you've been stopped and you
start actually using your allowance to
give treats back to those guys. That's
it. That's how it is. What is that?
>> Is that is that what anti-ionism is? I'm
not saying that they can't be the
majority unless
>> literally the majority in their country.
>> Zionism is where you have a majority in
Israel because it's an ethnoprotected
majority. Yes. So if you're
>> if the way that if the way that you are
establishing this ethnic majority is
that you expel minorities and like steal
their land and kill people. Yeah. that
I'm I'm anti that.
>> So So they've already done that
realistic
wait because nobody ever has to answer
this question. They said they're anti-Z.
I know what
>> they've already done that. I can't tell
if that's Destiny saying they've done
that historically or if he's just
talking about Lebanon. Stop trying to
get Lebanon back. You're not getting
Lebanon back. You're not getting
southern Lebanon back. Stop trying to
get Lebanon back. BRO, THEY DID THAT
YESTERDAY, BRO. They're doing that now.
What do you mean they already did that?
No, they're still doing it. They're
literally doing it right now. What the
are you talking about? I'm just cur like
so what is the solution then? It's the
ma the cleansing of Israel.
>> It's the Okay, so the are you giving a
dichotomy between first of all the idea
that I can solicit
but second no if you're asking me the
dichotomy if you're asking me the
dichotomy between what they're doing in
the West Bank and Gaza and not doing
that I think there's probably a better
thing to do. And just because I don't
know exactly what they should do doesn't
mean I'm anti-Jew or like proing. This
is why I hate that the whole leftist
people have decided to purity us on this
one issue because the position is
totally untenable.
>> No, no, I'm not saying you are, but all
the other people that you if there is no
solution for them, but starting wars,
ethnically cleansing, taking land, you
know what the decision is? It's super
simple. Stop giving them money and
weapons to do it.
How hard is it? How hard is it? If you
are going to do that, I will try to
oppose you and I will not accommodate
it. How hard is that to do? How hard is
that to say? Holy [__] That are on the
far left. They pretty on this position.
Like when somebody says they're
anti-Zionist, I just don't know what
that means. What is it actually?
>> What is anti-Israel's project of
ethnically cleansing Gazins right now?
>> Okay. Just your first stopped in Gaza.
Just real quick, just real quick. Hold
on. If they stopped in Gaza,
>> no money for Israel until they've
rebuilt Gaza and they've rebuilt
everything they destroyed in Lebanon.
No, not a dollar, not a dime. No more
qualitative military ad edge. No more of
that. Nothing. Nothing until they've
stopped. And they've reversed. They need
to reverse. They can't just stop. They
need to reverse. Okay. Rebuild Gaza.
Rebuild Lebanon. Once that started,
maybe maybe stopped in the West Bank,
but still kept their uh their uh ratios
for how many uh ethnic are in the
country versus how many um other
ethnicities are in the country. You'd be
okay with that?
>> Uh if how do they enforce their ethnic
>> amnesty for Israel? Amnesty. Guys, what
if they just stopped now? They just did
a couple genocide. They just did a
little bit of like genocidal war crime
attack. [__] I'm trying to do
explicitly like talking points. They're
um I'm trying to say all the things at
once. They just did a couple war crimes.
They just did a little genocide. They
just did a little ethnic cleansing.
That's all. Let bygones be bygones.
>> No.
No.
uh by only letting in uh ethnic Jews and
expelling uh if it goes above a certain
amount the uh
>> other and if I say I'm not okay with
this does that mean I'm pro Israel being
ethnically cleansed because there's a
the thing you have toity
on a real level that's what would happen
ethnic cleansing is necessarily bad I
think we should ethnically cleanse
people from West Hollywood personally I
don't think all ethnic cleansing is
necessarily bad but just like own the
position
>> okay wait To be fair, like I know that
was a meme, but do you actually like
when when is ethnic cleansing justified?
Like Chinese exclusion hack type stuff
or like like uh oh, we can only have
this ratio of like this type of people
from this country. Is it ever justified?
>> It Yeah, it probably is. But the thing
is, it's never the reason why the reason
why it's hard to have this conversation
as an American is because we get to take
our ethnicity, our national identity for
granted because we're never threatened
by anybody because we have way too many
people. So, it's not a question for us.
But if we had countries to the north, if
Canada had 10 billion people and Mexico
had 30 billion people, we would be
having questions about what the American
ethnicity is and how we need to protect
it all the time. But we don't have them
in immigrants.
>> But I would
>> Has Destiny ever heard? There's this
invention that happened a little while
back.
>> It's kind of crazy. It's called the
airplane.
Does this guy understand that there are
airplanes and that immigration can
happen to America from anywhere in the
world? Do we do we not understand that
that in terms of protecting your
ethnicity quote unquote the entire world
can immigrate to your country in a
technical sense? It's very
>> support that. I would say look if it
turns out that we just get a bunch more
Canadians and Mexicans and this
transformed their country
every single person in Canada every
single person in Canada every single
person in Mexico was a Nazi and we lived
in the United States of America and we
had 300 million people. Let's say that
500 million Nazis from Canada wanted to
immigrate into the United States. You
would accept that unquestionably. You
wouldn't have I wouldn't promote an
ethnic cleansing. No, I wouldn't. And
yeah, I think we have a far different
problem if you have an ideology so
pervasive that it's going to destroy
your entire democracy and coming in like
people you're sounding like people
talking about No, no, no. You're talking
about Muslims. Muslims are coming into
this country. Muslims want to destroy
the democracy. So, we should ethnically
cleanse Muslims from Europe.
>> What did he even argue with Constantine
Kissen on? I actually don't know what
was his problem with what Constantine
Kissen was saying. I didn't watch the
debate. I'm never going to go watch the
debate. But what is the core
disagreement? Well, we're not God's
chosen people. Okay? We are. And so have
to deal with this. And God's chosen
don't. That's it. That's all it is. I'm
sorry. That's all that many Muslims
coming here. It's not a problem.
>> There's millions. But there's millions
of them. There's tensions. Millions.
Millions is nothing to us. We're 300
million Germany. Should Germany
ethnically cleans Muslims only
population of 80 million. Well, you said
it's justified people.
is such a worthless position. You can't
even engage critically with the
position. We are not there.
>> Dude, I guarantee you if you wanted to
just get Destiny to argue with Destiny,
you could just go find whatever you're
saying to Constantine Kissen, right?
Easily just find whatever his arguments
were against Constantine Kissen and
replay them back to him and he would
just be arguing with himself, right? If
there were 10 billion Muslims to the
north that wanted to destroy democracy
in America and 500 million wanted to
immigrate, I think I WOULD HAVE SOME
questions about that. that I think most
reasonable people would. We don't have
to worry about that. There are 7 million
in in Israel in a in a region surrounded
by a billion Arab Muslims. They do have
another question about that. A lot of
these Arab majority states literally
have their ethnic identity protected in
their constitution, but they just don't
deal with it much because there's not a
billion Chinese people trying to
immigrate to Pakistan.
>> You can be against that. Wait, no, no,
no. Okay, you can be against it, but it
doesn't matter that you're against
cash out
the epic majority of [__]
Afghanistan.
or Iraq.
>> Soy pill. Soy pill. The law prevents
rich people and poor people alike from
stealing a loaf of bread. Right? That
law is obviously going to only affect
the poor people in a realistic sense.
What you have to engage with and what
anti-ionists have to engage with and
they're you know I I'm not asking you to
solve Israel Palestine but if I haven't
heard this argument before let's see
where this is going. ethnostate and it
is an ethnostate of
Israel went away, they would be under
massive threat. It would happen,
>> right? And if you're if you're giving me
the trolley problem of either support
ethnic cleansing or your country is
taken over by neo-Nazis, like yeah, I
guess, but like I don't know how you map
this onto reality when there are
potentially infinite solutions in
between those of making a project that
there literally there are. And by the
way, all anybody's asking for is to just
stop spending your tax dollars to put
your thumb on the scale for one side of
the argument. That's literally it.
That's literally all people are asking.
Just don't spend our money to do it. I
don't want that. Please stop spending my
money to do it. Right. Not literally
because I'm not American, but that's
that's what people are arguing. It's
crazy, man.
>> It doesn't involve ethnic cleansing that
solves this. And going to extreme
hypotheticals of, yeah, if there were 10
billion Nazis in Canada and they're all
coming in, well, yeah, obviously I don't
want Nazis in my country. You suck. But
but but the idea that like, okay,
therefore you support ethnic cleansing.
It's like this isn't what we're talking
about necessarily. We're talking about
specific situations that Okay, go ahead.
You're saying support extreme
hypotheticals like Hamas is not an
organization that was supported by
Hezbollah that lived to the north of
Israel that was supported by Iran that
was the basically the
>> dude why is he being you're saying
support
>> what we're talking about necessarily
situations that okay go ahead
>> you're saying support extreme
hypotheticals like Hamas is not an
organization that was supported by
Hezbollah that lived to the north
>> it was supported by that was supported
by Iran that was that was supported by
Iran, the basically the largest player
in the region that was tangentially
peripherilally supported by um the
Houthis. Uh like like you're like
hypothetically hypothetically like I can
>> he's doing his list thing where he's not
making a compelling point at all. It's
not even a little bit compelling the
thing he's saying, right? It's not
compelling at all. He's just doing a
list thing. Can't wait for Loner Box to
come back and defend Destiny and not all
this.
What Soy Pill doesn't understand. What
Soy Pill doesn't understand. You can
never even imagine this to be the case,
but this is like the reality.
>> You're saying the hypothetical is either
you ethnically cleanse or you die.
>> No, the the is what Destiny is saying.
Yes.
>> That is what Israel's argument is. Yes.
>> That's the hypothetical you gave me,
right? Either you either ethically why
you why you just filibustering. The
hypothetical was do you protect the
ethnic majority of your country or do
you become an ethnic minority and then
die? That's the hypothetical. So, ethnic
cleansing or you die. That's literally
what you just said. That's literally
what you just said. How do you protect
the ethnic majority? Through ethnic
cleansing.
THAT'S THE EXACT SAME THING. IT'S THE
EXACT same thing.
What is wrong with this guy?
>> Okay, that's the reality.
>> Using this logic, should Germany expel
all the Syrians?
>> How many Syrians?
>> Like 10 to 14 million and then 8
million.
>> That's a million 14 million. Wasn't it
10 to 14?
Wasn't Wasn't it like 14 million?
>> I think they took like a million in
>> people that all left Syria. Like the
entire Syrian diaspora was 14 million.
>> Maybe I'm mixing up the numbers. Let's
say it's
a population of 80 million.
>> Typical leftist tactic.
>> Okay.
>> No, I I was just wrong. I'm admitting
that.
>> Dude, it's Soy pill is the only person.
Why? Literally, you can't have an
argument. You can't have a conversation
with these people. It's actually so
disingenuous. Like fundamentally, how
many times have they been wrong in a
row? Soy pill misspeaks once, they all
pile on him instantly.
What is the point of even having this
conversation or being a part of these
things and he just goes, I'm wrong.
High school bullying. It's so
embarrassing, man. It's so People are
beneath contempt. Like they're just they
suck so badly.
They don't have Dude, they don't have an
argument. They're just going to bully
this guy until he like stops speaking
up.
>> I got the number messed up. a million
and 80 million. Should they start
ethically cleansing them if more and
more people are coming and they're
subverting the culture?
>> No, it won't get to that point because
those countries protect their
immigration. They don't accept that many
people. So, they don't get to that
point.
>> And typically, people assimilate over
time.
>> Okay. 30 years into the future, that
Syrian population, because they're a low
cost of living, you know, population,
they're having like big families,
they're actually starting to reach near
an ethnic majority.
What do they do now? The white German
population, the German ethnic population
is no longer having kids. They are very
close to being almost almost below
majority. What do they do now? That's
quite literally the problem Israel has,
right? That is the problem Israel has.
So what? Just run forward the
hypothetical a little bit.
>> Like the reason why like in part we're
not super concerned about Muslims coming
to our immigration.
>> It's so funny because I I'll be real
with you. Okay, I'll be real with you
straight, right? I don't I don't
necessarily disagree with their
arguments, but I've always held that
position. I don't think it's wrong to
think like, okay, well, we've got this
core majority of people and and I think
that that could have something to do
with your country. I don't think that is
a wrong thing. I'm of the belief that
while I don't think that's wrong, I'm
willing to try like the multicultural,
multi-thnic fabric and see if that works
for a country. And I'm I'm like willing
to try it because ultimately I'm going
to be dead before the negative
consequences hit anyway. But I'm like,
"Oh, it's, you know, it's aspirational.
It's something that hasn't really been
done on the scale of the United States
before. I want to see if it can work."
But I don't think it's like inherently
correct. I'm talking about America right
now. Um, Kathy, I'm not talking about
Canada.
Canada was already a multi-thnic country
by like f like the fabric of the country
is multi-thnic, multicultural to begin
with. So, I already live there. Okay.
But like I'm I'm fine with that. I just
don't think it's bad to begin with.
These guys would argue that ever talking
about the United States and and the
ethnicity of the United States being
something that should be protected, they
think that is neo-Nazi language. And
then they just flip they they totally
kill their own principle for Israel.
It's bizarre. And they like Destiny
consistently has this anti-immigration
like anti-anti-immigration rhetoric
except it all goes away the second he's
talking about Israel instantly.
And he he makes it existential. It's not
existential, has it? It's It's literally
not existential. Oh, although I will say
it starts to become closer to
existential when you consistently allow
them to ethnically cleanse, to kill, to
absolutely obliterate the people around
them and all of those people start to
hate them
>> and death.
>> Yes. Yes. No, I agree. Because they
protect their
space in time. Yes. That's that's the
dichotomy because for the one stator for
all the lefties now that are pro
Palestinian they want Israel to be a
single state that accepts every single
Palestinian as an Israeli citizen and
then all of the diaspora Palestinians as
Israeli citizens so that they people be
like 30% of the population there
>> and then they will
>> um even less if you if you think this is
an argument that this is what the civil
war was about which I'm pretty sure it
isn't. I'm pretty sure you're saying
something totally insane but I'm not
going to argue American history with
you. I'm pretty sure that was not the
argument of the Civil War. But in any
case, I will say you should at least at
the bare minimum say it's totally good
for America to never pay them $1 ever
again and to strip them of their
qualitative military edge that we are
never going to give you advance more
advanced technology than the people
around you ever again. Both of these
things seems pretty obvious, right?
>> Vote to have a theocracy that will
likely want to
>> wipe them out. So walk me through this
then.
>> I oppose Israel's ethnic cleansing.
>> I acknowledge that there is a world in
which the population gets to a point
where Israel would uh that in Israel be
ethnically cleansed by the population
that hates them that they allowed in
that both of these things are like
potentially completely plausible, right?
Why is it bad for me to oppose the
ethnic cleansing if I believe there
could be even if I can't give you the
solutions ways to get around this that
are not let's just keep ethnically
cleansing people and support ethos
supremacist. you have a better solution.
I'm all ears. Well, the issue is that
people seem to be the solution is don't
give them your tax dollars. Right? If
you if you're just going to agree that
it is ethnic cleansing, but you don't
see a better solution, then at minimum
you could say, "Well, I we shouldn't
give the money, right? I listen, if you
want tax dollars, you guys are the
chosen people. You guys are the the
genius intellects. You guys have the
highest IQ's, right? Come up with a
reason and we'll give you the money
back. Come, sorry. Come up with a way.
Okay, I'm putting that on the the people
of Israel. All right, these are the most
entrepreneurial, inventive people on the
planet. I've been told. All right, come
up with some some way to not kill
everybody around you and still exist.
And then once you figured that out, that
and I don't mean by killing all of them
so you don't have to kill anymore. Then
we could start giving you money again or
weapons again.
Super easy, man. A hardcore against the
Zionist project. So you call yourself an
anti-ionist. But then the what the on
the flip side of that, if you if the
anti-ionist were to have it their way,
you'd probably see my guess is another
like mass expulsion, mass uh if not a
genocide, then at least some kind of ma
mass ethnic cleansing of the Israel
state. But I don't think anybody would
be any of the Wait, what's the problem
with that? Would that be like a horrible
thing to do? Wait, wait, what? Would you
say that's like a monstrous thing to
consider?
Would you say that's a anti-semitic
THING TO CONSIDER?
OH, SO IT'S LIKE a racial supremacist
thing to Oh, I
>> pro Palestinian people are not going to
stand up to say anything about that. So,
they're basically just like expelled
from their country.
>> But this is why it's frustrating because
the project of Zionism said we're going
to establish this country here and it
caused all these downstream effects.
>> Israel has the right to exist. What does
it need to do to exist? And and
ethnically cleanse millions of people.
Well, that seems like a problem. You got
a better solution?
I don't know. You kind of killed and
ethically cleansed a lot of people
already. They might not really be that
cool with you guys anymore. I don't know
if I have a better solution. Well, I
guess we get to just keep doing it then
forever.
Is Is that how that works?
Damn, son. If that's how that works,
then I don't know. I guess maybe you do
just get to kill as many people as you
want, as many kids as you want. You get
to starve them to death. You get to
them. You get to execute them if you
have them p imprisoned. Okay, you get to
do all of these things. you, Israel, you
got me. You're like a sphinx. I couldn't
solve the riddle and so now you get to
and kill everybody.
Damn. And I have to pay for it. What
that are now putting us in this
position. We're in a between a rock and
a hard place. And I'm saying this
position sucks. I hate that you are now
making me choose between ethnic
cleansing or not and death of every or
ethnic cleansing of of Israel and all
the Jews out of Israel and therefore I
oppose the project that established it
this way in such a way that would give
us all these problems. Like
>> no, no one is saying when you say you're
anti-inist, that doesn't mean you
opposed the project. That means that you
oppose the state of Israel today.
>> But I still because of the way they're
doing it. Like it's like, yeah, I don't
think this is like, okay, is the
solution just forever we're going to be
this, you know, ethnically cleansing
thing and we'll never ever not be at war
with everyone around us. I don't know
what the solution is today, but when
when lefties say that they oppose
Israel, they oppose Israel with their
chest. They want to defund it. Maybe
they want military action for regime
change there. That's their type of
opposition. But if Arabs were to become
the majority in the state of Israel and
then were to start massively expelling
maybe I'm just going to hypothesize that
you would want to go to war with Israel
immediately. I'm just going to
hypothesize this. Not if they stop doing
war crimes. If they want to keep doing
war crimes, maybe you do eventually get
there, but I would imagine economic
sanctions would come in first. Before
that, it would just be denouncements in
like in international courts or
international bodies, right? There's
like a whole bunch of things you do
before you get to to actually military
militarily intervening people. I don't
think lefties would have to say about
it. Also have a problem with ethnic
cleansing if Arabs did the
problem.
>> It seems as if the Zionist project right
now though is specifically and hinging
on, correct me if I'm wrong, ethnic
cleansing, right?
>> That the what
>> the Zionist project necessitates ethnic
cleansing right now. It cannot exist
without them continuously ethnically
cleansing people. It depends on if you
consider the existence of Palestinians
in the West Bank of the Gaza Strip
ethnically cleansing because the land
was literally promised to them by
Yahweh. Okay? The land was literally
listened
to them. Come on, man.
>> Technically, it depends right now on on
an indefinite uh occupation of the West
Bank of the Gaza Strip. But
>> occupation, ethnic cleansing, kicking
people out based on their race,
>> not kicking people out, but keeping them
in the West Bank and the Gaza Strip.
>> Okay.
>> There's 2 million Arabs that live in
Israel proper. like that that aren't in
the West Bank or the Gaza Strip.
>> So yeah, the the aparttheid this is this
is another thing that's not necessarily
ethnic cleansing. It would rely on you
keeping those populations there and
never giving them the right to vote. It
would rely on the apartheid,
right? It it relies on not giving these
people rights. You don't have to
ethnically cleanse them so long as
they're not getting dangerously close to
having rights. I believe this was a
significant portion of why Israel pulled
all settlers out of Gaza in 2004, right?
Or 2006.
2008, one of those one of those three
years. Okay, this is a significant part
of it was because I believe people were
starting to argue that if you have
settlements there, you actually need to
incorporate the Gaza Strip into Israel.
Like people were starting to make that
argument in international circles. And I
think that had some amount of pressure
there. There were a lot of factors. That
was not the only factor at all.
Obviously, obviously Hamas was like
bombing them. Obviously, there's a lot
of stuff going on. But I think that was
a part of it was they they didn't want
to risk Oh, we have settlements here.
Well, you should roll it into your
country.
>> Not even a little bit.
>> Yeah. That that they're not getting
kicked out of Israel.
>> Okay. Gang.
>> Um Phil, can I ask you one last
question?
>> If the people wanting to come into your
country or like have political power in
your country all want to kill you and
you if you don't want those people
around, is that supremacist?
Listen, if these people want to kill
your culture by promoting
and degeneracy broadly, is wanting to
kick them out supremacist really? Or is
it just wanting to like preserve the
identity of your people?
Erodite, could you answer that for me?
What if they're like trying to What are
they trying to do when they promote
these? They they they Oh. um if you're
doing it on a race-based like
uh
discrimination thing like yeah like yes
but no if you're just like hey well I I
don't know do we ideologically test
>> all of the dominant ethnic groups
wanting to move in want to kill you so
you don't want any of those dominant
ethnic groups is that supremacist
>> uh in this very specific um this
hypothetical
>> I thought I thought we were all okay
guys call me crazy but I thought we were
against painting people with such a
broad brush not all support Israel. Not
all are Zionists. Not all Jews. So you
can't say you can't equate Judaism and
Zionism because that that catches good
well-meaning people in the crossfire.
All of these disgusting bloodthirsty ape
Arabs want to kill Jews. Every single
one of them wants to kill you. They are
disgusting Islamic Islamic radical
terrorist freaks and they will do
anything any depraved act to if they
can. Okay. I
just zero principle. Zero principle
here. Nothing. No. No. No leg to stand
on at all. Okay.
>> Technically, yes. Because by necessity,
your race is the one that doesn't want
to kill your race. And your race is
better. But not in the same way that
it's like, I think white people are
superior to black people.
>> Wait, you you deciding that your race is
better is not them being supremacist.
That's kind of you being supremacist,
right?
>> No. But yeah, if you think every other
race is awful and they all want to kill
me, I'm the good one. Then I' like it's
just by necessity
>> requires a an ethnosupremacist outlook
from the beginning. This person's
Islamic. This person's an Islamic Arab.
They want to kill me by definition. How
is this not the same as conflating
Zionism and Judaism? How is that not the
same thing that like obviously just
because somebody's an Arab doesn't mean
they want to kill all Jews? You don't
think there are any Arabs who don't want
to kill don't want to kill every Jew?
But that is what she's saying. And
there's no concern in the in the exact
way that they would expect us to be very
very and they I mean aerodite destiny
they would expect us to be incredibly
careful about all the things we say
about Israel so as to not cause any
anti-semitism right but in the opposite
direction they have no such concern
zero concern they will do it repeatedly
and they accept it is good and just to
do so okay I'm not going to watch this
I'm going to go over to soy pills thing
his retrospective
>> I felt like they were giving like white
nationalist ass talking points but like
in defense of Israel and it's like okay
like what the like you know you can be
you can be pro like I don't want to
ethnically cleanse like Israel without
saying like oh like the people of this
ethnicity are a threat to us inherently
don't you understand well like white
supremacists argue about blacks yeah but
like really really like the Arabs are
just ethnically a threat to us
>> necessity It's a necessity that we do
this or we'll die. And it's like, is it
are there no other solutions? Can we do
nothing else? Like, and if it is, like I
I we need to do something about it.
Like, and it seems like the the only
prescription is I don't have a solution.
We just have to do this like
indefinitely. And I don't know, man. Oh,
that's not what I wanted. How do I flip
horizontally? I don't know how to flip
horizontally. I'll just be backwards.
Wait. Oh, transform
>> basket lotion. Thank you for the primer.
I appreciate it.
>> Flip horizontal. There we go.
Um, Dryan, think for the five. God, the
Zionism, the Dems is so insufferable.
Supporting a state that violates human
rights and a far right ethnost state is
misguided. Yeah. And it's like it's
like, oh, if you don't support it, you
want to ethnically cleanse Israel,
right? Because you realize that like by
existing there, they're always going to
be doing this. I'm like, well, no, I
don't want to ethnically cleanse Israel,
but I also think the manner in which
they're maintaining their state in the
name of Zionism is bad, and I don't know
how to stop that. And and I I would
prefer if there was like more
integration. And I think there could be
like a idea of a one state with
assimilation. And if you're saying
that's impossible, then what you're
telling me is that it necessitates
perpetual ethnic cleansing. And the only
way this can stop suffering is if we
>> No. No. No. It doesn't necessitate
perpetual ethnic cleansing. Everybody be
fine. Just stay in your pen. Just stay
in your We built you a nice pen. Stay in
the pen.
>> Take a bunch of the people and just move
them somewhere else, which is ethnic
cleansing. That's like the ultimate
final e and the cleansing or final
solution if you will. And it's like I
don't think that's good. I don't want to
displace everyone from Gaza. I don't
want to displace everyone from Israel.
So like what the what do you do?
Look at us when you're talking to us.
Soy pill. I'm not happy. Destiny not
happy. As a Destiny fan, he's gone off
lately. He's been clever enough to
understand the issue. But him constantly
saying you're being bad faith is the
biggest red flag. Like I get that
Destiny like doesn't know me so he's
like not sure about it and he's prone to
like people backstabbing him but yeah I
dude ah
what's the backstab when was he
backstabbed
bro when who was he backstabbed by who
is not correct
who is not correct who is not just
totally correct about this guy literally
you what was I wrong about Shuya
Is this guy this guy saying cuz I I was
pretty clear. I was not hiding at all. I
was like, "Hey, you hey, you did the
things. Well, you and again, the way you
argue this is not that you were
backstabbed or betrayed, Destiny. You
betrayed everybody else by not living up
to your principles, by not being a good
person. You are the person who betrayed
people. Do not show empathy to the
person who betrayed everything they
stood for, all of their friends. Do not
do that. Never accept the propaganda.
>> I am uh I'm I'm happy I'm tolerant and
I'm not constantly getting upset at the
bad faith thing. I'm just like, buddy, I
don't [__] know who you're talking
to. You got to stop assuming the worst.
Why no live and learn? It's on. It's
tomorrow. Although Hutch said he might
not be able to make it because of family
and it's like Hutch, dude, I get it.
Your family's dying. Well, maybe maybe
they can just leave him alone, man. to
say your e anti-thnic.
>> Are you a surgeon? No. Then get on the
podcast
>> cleansing I guess. Hey Kilo, thank you
for the five. Even the bizarre
hypothetical that opting out of Zionism
will lead to them getting genocided. Why
do the Jews get perpetual pre? Yeah.
Yeah. That's the other thing. Like if
you have a whole debate about it, it's
like because God decided that. Don't you
know? That's literally they're the
chosen people. How many times do I have
to teach you this lesson, old man? never
go against God's chosen.
>> All right, your two options are Jews get
to perpetually ethnically cleanse or the
Arabs do and you got to pick one. I'm
like, well, yeah, this rock in a hard
place thing is is not something that has
a preference at the end. It's like
something that's just bad. And I
>> By the way, you gave them all the
weapons and the money that they needed
to carry out the ethnic cleansing to
carry out all the war crimes, right?
You're the you're the people who enabled
the war crimes. Sorry, I'm muted.
>> I don't know how things at the end. It's
like something that's just bad in either
sense. You have to find a way to solve
it. I don't know how to solve Israel
Palestine, but this exists because of
the Zionist project, the perpetual need
to say we need to exist in this spot.
And I'm anti that. Like I I don't think
that your desire to exist in this
country and it like because of some
religious dogmatism is justification to
keep doing what you're doing. I'm sorry.
This gives me too much of the Vimar
Republic type. Uh so they want to do the
SPD triangulating with the nationalist
fry course. Uh, maybe.
Good job. Hey, Mind Waves. Good job
calling out Destiny's lack of
understanding would differ to the
different farright factions and their
feelings on Israel. Yeah, I can't
believe he said that. Like just want or
uh neo-Nazis.
>> Dude, Nick Fentes totally. He He's like
just good as long as the as long as the
aren't here. Getting a combo with Lunder
Box. Yeah, I could talk to him about it.
I think I I trust Lunderbox, but I I
trust Destiny who's read about it. Like
I I don't think he's like
>> Hold on. Hold on. I have to go back.
Where was that chat message?
Who sent that?
>> He said that like just want or uh
neo-Nazis just want to go to Israel and
off like this is just not true. Like
maybe a Richard Spencer might say
something but like Nick Fuentes like
>> get in a conversation with Loner Box.
Who said it?
>> How Hassan bad?
>> That was in Twitch, wasn't it? Nazis
aren't as bad as Hassan. Like I don't
know. Get in a combo with Lunder Box.
Yeah, I could talk to him about it. I
think I I trust Linder Box, but I I
trust Destiny who's read about it. Like
I I don't think he's like he's way more
informed than I am. I don't do debates
on Israel, Palestine. I don't know if
she say trans rights. I just did. Get
the combo. Oh, do you understand that
these liberals are the ones actually
period testing? Well, they are. Hutch
flakes out when Taylor's going beyond.
Yeah, I'm going to try to reschedle.
We'll see. Remember when you made a huge
effort to post about dark money and you
were totally wrong about everything? Oh,
you're talking about Kilo. Um, private
property is the divide. Did this guy
suggest that Kilo was wrong? What was
Kilo wrong about?
Kilo, were you super wrong about
something or is that guy just Is that
guy just um is he misinformed? Some guy
called you out. Were you wrong?
>> Line between liberals and leftists. I
think that is the definitive difference
between the groups. Yeah. And I'm not
anti-private property. I got to stop
saying Democ. I'm a sock Dem. Destiny's
not getting Destiny's got more rhetoric
than he has. Good faith in my years of
seeing him. He puts up some real good
fights against right-wingers. And yeah,
and like that's why I try to bring it
up. Like obviously I don't think that
Hassan's politics um are uh less harmful
than like Destiny's personal beefs that
have caused so much baggage. But
associating with Destiny, it comes with
so much
My haters follow me. Sorry,
Dude.
Dude, why why would you come to like
Zoyill's chat to Gungard?
Wow. Wow. Backage. There's all sorts of
[__] you'll get just for mentioning him
or being on the same poster as him or
being an org that he's in. Um I've known
people that like lost donors that are
because of the org that he's in. And you
know what? Like that's something I'm
like, "Hey, but you do good fighting and
you have good politics and you promote
usually good things,
>> dude.
So I build Dude, that was really funny.
I forgot about that from early on in the
conversation. Desi was arguing that
Hassan harasses people. Hassan tries to
destroy people out of spite and that's
what makes Hassan uniquely bad and that
you can't accept being anywhere around
Hassan. And Soy Pill was sitting there
like, "Bro, that's why that's why I
can't I I say that doesn't matter to me
so I can like collab with you. What do
you mean? What are you saying right now?
You're you're literally giving me a
prescription where I'd have to stop
talking to you completely. What are you
trying to do? Is this a test? Are you
saying something intentionally?
And I want to work with that and I want
to promote people to get involved. And
the idea that like I'm going to throw
that all away because like oh like you
got cancelceled for this thing. Like I I
don't know. Like obviously there's a
line to draw like if it turned out that
someone was like an actual like a
murderer or whatever and it's like okay
like there's definitive proof that you
just like are poison and you do more
harm than good. That's when you stop.
But like
does Soyel not think there's definitive
proof of this? I'm just curious like
what does he what does he think
happened? I I just would wonder what he
actually thinks happened with regards to
the leaks and stuff
>> like what what cuz people say this and I
I'm going to give him the benefit of the
doubt and say that okay he um like Soy
Pill doesn't know but then they don't
want to know either. That's like the
that's the weird thing to me is like he
just doesn't want to know probably.
Well, I feel like it's not hard to find
the information and if you can find the
information, it seems pretty easy to
understand. But I don't know. Pisco does
the same thing. Yeah. But Pisco I think
has a possible literal actual conflict
there. Like I think for for Pisco
specifically, I would never judge him
because if he's ever for some reason
given Destiny legal advice on anything
and then he starts like talking about
Destiny's legal case, I would be very
very very concerned that Destiny would
do the same thing he's doing to Lauren
de Laguna. Like if if Pisco went through
all the stuff and found out he disagreed
or thought Destiny was harmful, I think
he would be really concerned or Pisco
could be really concerned that that's
somehow a conflict. that's somehow like
a thing he could get reported for. I
that's if I don't I don't even know if
he would think that. I don't even know
if he would think that. So, but I'm I'm
saying with him specifically, I don't
know that
I don't know that he is not conflicted
out there in a way that you wouldn't
expect.
Um, let's see here. What part of wanting
to bury your head in the sand is
complicated? It's It's not complicated.
It's just when he says like basically
when people when he says what he just
said that's what's complicated right
>> was like an actual like a murderer or
whatever and it's like okay like there's
definitive proof that you just like are
poison and you do more harm than good
that's when you
>> there's definitive proof that you just
are poison you do more harm than good
right he's like he is doing the Jimmy
Savile thing this is this is prime Jimmy
Savile comparison territory right here
but we don't do this anymore we don't do
this anymore
but it is it is prime I'm Jimmy Savile
comparison territory. Okay. How many
kids How many kids do we feed to Jimmy?
He just built a hospital. How many kids
does he get soy bill? How many kids?
>> Stop. But like I don't know this it's
you can't draw the equivalence to that
in the Hassan politics because his it's
all about subverting the Democratic
party. It's not just like oh he did bad
stuff. He behaves
>> why why does Soy Pill think that
Democratic politicians talk to Hassan
then?
Like if it's all subversion, why does he
think that like some does he think Roy
Roana is like a
I'm I'm curious what he thinks those
people think. Gavin Newsome said he
would go on the broadcast, right? Gavin
Newsome said, "Yeah, I'd be open to
going on the broadcast,
right?
>> Is that cuz Gavin Newsome's like a total
or what?"
>> Guys, I think we're five subs away for
another hour on the stream if you guys
do want to do that. 12 minutes left.
I've got the stuff and there's probably
I've got some other stuff in my docket
here. Hold on a second. Yeah, I've got
some other stuff on the docket here if
we want to go through a couple other
things.
So you guys you guys can make the call.
We'll see what's going to happen.
>> Similar with PCO, he held a position of
allying with people who aren't allied
completely. I couldn't quote him. Yeah.
>> Does he mean co-opt? Maybe. Maybe he
means co-opt. Yeah, it's like maybe it
means co-opt.
>> Do you realize that socialism and
communism are both acceptable if people
want it? And the reality is it's just as
fine as liberalis and fascism by force
and thus not acceptable. I don't know if
you the problem is like you can't I
don't know how you get everyone on board
with socialism communism and in so far
as like well then we wouldn't have to
force it like oh well if everyone just
agreed with me it wouldn't we wouldn't
have to
>> yeah but it's the you go slowly in a
direction see what works see what
doesn't work force it but that's usually
not how it plays out. Yeah. Yeah.
Commies don't get how they can think
it's anything but supremacy want to
protect your ethnic majority. Yeah. No
that's the questions. It's like I felt
like I was talking with neo-Nazis. Like
I know they're not. I know I agree with
these people's politics, but the
argument is being brought up. Like, how
is it supremacist if they just want to
protect their ethnicity from the ones
that want to kill them? And it's like,
dude, that's what Nazis say. They're
like, well, black people just, you know,
are more dangerous and we just have to
get rid of them. It's not about like we
don't hate them because of their skin
color. It's just they're inherently more
dangerous and they're attacking the
white race and there's a white genocide.
We just get all the brown people out.
It's like like
my haters follow me. Sorry. It's okay.
Kilo Destiny was sounding super fun.
Just like a little bit. I'm glad I know
these people. If that was my first
introduction to Kyla and uh Steven, I
would I would have some questions.
What's preferable?
>> Shouldn't you have some questions?
Shouldn't you be wondering why they have
like an edge case where they suddenly
sound like Nick Fentes? Doesn't that
like not make any sense? Shouldn't you
have questions now? Shouldn't you be
like, "Wait,
>> so like we could do this in America?"
No. No, we can't do it in America. So we
could do this in Germany. No, no, you
can't do it in Germany. Well, like but
what if what if like the population
started to get to the point where
Germans were no longer the ethnic
majority there? No, you can't do it in
Germany. You can only do it in Israel.
Wh why? Because everybody hates them.
What if the what if the Germans are
hated by the Syrians who are there and
the the population that's like going to
become bigger? Well, what? Hold on.
No, it's it's different because
everybody all the people around Germany
like Germany. Like it's different
because actually all the Arabs
surrounding Israel want to kill the
people in Israel.
Well, hold on. Right. It just It just
keeps going. It just keeps going and
going and going. It just keeps going.
Wait. Uh, yeah. Polls infamously huge
fans of the Germans. Okay. Infamously,
what is best? Mind waves. You're a
failed streamer. Actively is being quite
the snarker. I've seen you in here. No
one should talk to Hassan. Also, I got
waffles and chicken with Fentus.
Yeah, I think he was too friendly with
Fentes, but like I don't Was there any
ever a point in his I didn't watch this
whole discussion. Was there ever a point
in that like Destiny Nick thing that
people always try to like use to call
him out like, "Oh, you promoted Nick."
It's like, isn't he like pushing back on
him the entire time? Or is it because
he's not like screaming at him? I don't
know. Talk to Beast Go about what I'm uh
I probably agree with that that I don't
think the chicken waffles thing is that
weird if it's like you disagree. I don't
think it's like bad to have
conversations with people like that, but
I don't know. It's tough now because
Nick is massive and I don't I don't
necessarily think it's good. So,
>> telling you Destiny's not acting in good
faith to certain other libs. Talk to
Pisco. I'll definitely talk to Pisco. I
joined Richard. Oh, hey Dal. I joined
Richard Spencer's substack to see behind
the curtain. He's honestly pretty lid.
Uh, I wouldn't talk to Pisco if I were
whoever that is.
I'm sorry. Love Pisco from a distance.
Okay. But I would not talk to Pisco
about it. Pisco has total derangement in
the opposite in the opposite direction.
I wouldn't be shocked if Pisco is like
totally back to thinking Desi is just
like a good faith actor he would love to
argue with again.
Pisco is
he will infinitely
infinitely fall for it again. Okay, I'm
sorry that that's the them's the facts.
He will fall for it again and again and
again and again. Love peace go from a
distance though. Okay, love peace go
from a distance. He will fall for it
again and again and again. Get him a
fell for it again award cuz he fell for
it again. But I will say it doesn't seem
like at least from what I've seen he
necessarily wants his reputation tied.
It's like if they're going to have a
contentious conversation or if it's a
debate then he'll do it. I think I think
the doubt no I think he's hiding his
power level at this point. He's trying
to like capitulate. He's doing like the
Glen Beck. Destiny is deep in the right
wing Zionist information sphere. Yeah.
Maybe I it was so weird that he's like
trying to convert people to religion.
Like this is like I it was so weird like
Jews explaining this to me are going
it's like dude like I'm in communities I
like the the there are explicit like
projects from synagogues that like will
do outreach to secular and try to pay
them money to go to synagogue teaching
and make them more religious like this
just exists. They do this to people on
birthright. They do this to people
synagogues in California like constantly
try to convert people. No, don't get me
wrong. They're not like Mormons. They're
not like missionaries to the same extent
and they don't Why don't they try to go
and convert like black people? soy pill.
Could you tell me why they don't like
try to go and convert random black
people to Judaism? Is there like a
reason that they wouldn't go to like
black communities and just be like,
"Hey, I think you guys would really like
Judaism."
Is there is there something wrong with
the black communities that they don't go
and try to convert those people to
Judaism? Get them to come to synagogue,
>> you know, go around dropping Watchtowwer
flyers in your uh front door, but they
do. They try to convert people.
>> I'm not talking about Ethiopian Butts
up. And you know, I'm not talking about
Ethiopian. I don't know why you would
try to pull that up as if that is an
argument. I'm asking you why when they
go to get people at synagogue in
California, why are they not going to
Compton to grab people and say, "Hey,
why don't you come to synagogue?" That's
what I'm asking. That's what I'm asking
you.
Ethiopian Jews are explicitly like
closer Hapla group wise to actual like
semi Jews than other people. So you guys
can keep saying this, but genetically
they're sorry to say you guys don't it
doesn't actually work there.
I'm talking about something else. Oh,
whoops. Really enrages me soy that
people like Destiny are like remember
Mag America far bad but then Alli care
waterfare is really far right. Um does
he I don't think Destiny's like pro
Netanyahu is he? I don't I mean it
sounds like he was caring a little water
for them there. Difference between
acknowledging the pro Netanyahu. Oh god
this guy is deep.
This guy's going to require Okay. A
little re-education for soy pill. Some
soy pill re-education at this point.
>> Dark creation of Israel and wanting
Palestine to get their own state and
wanting Israel to disappear today. Yeah,
there is a difference. He's going nuts
during the Zionist.
>> Doesn't he disavow Netanyahu?
Doesn't he disavow Netanyahu? Guys,
wouldn't he just Come on, man. Couldn't
he disavow Netanyahu?
>> Conversation. How much he misrepresents
your opinion? Well, don't be Look,
Destiny is not just fighting me, right?
He's fighting me and then there's like
60 stands from Jojo and they're all the
lefties that are like super insane and
anti-semitic and he's punching all of
them too and like you know his punches
might be missing me and hitting them but
like it sure does feel like they're all
coming at me all these.
>> It's almost like he's having a
schizophrenic meltdown. It really is. It
is. It's almost like he's having a total
schizophrenic meltdown. Yeah.
>> That I don't have. Norman Finkelestein
is well read. Destiny has troubled has
precision to talk fast. I don't know
that debate with him and Finkelestein.
Uh Finkelestein looked pretty awful in
it. He didn't really substantively
contest what the things Destiny was
saying. Uh Benny Morris was
>> where the large contingent of insane
anti-semitic leftists. Well, in
Destiny's mind, he is seeing them. He's
making them up. Okay. And trust me, he's
winning a lot of those fights. Okay,
he's totally winning a bunch of those
fights. He's really doing well. He's
doing terrific.
>> Is much more relevant. He's literally a
scholar and he seemed to be agreeing
with Destiny on things. Like, I don't
know if I trust Norman Finkelestein.
Slaveholder said the same things about
black people that Israelis do about
Palestines. It was called surviile
insurrection. Yeah.
You might not want to cut him off, but
he wants you to cut off people he
disagree with. Destiny is toxic. I mean,
sure, but I I can deal with him telling
me to cut people off and not doing it as
long as he's not going to like dox me or
something. Maybe he will. It's literally
a stone sore away from Nazism. And
that's why Hey, Soy Pill, you want to
have a conversation? See what happens.
Hey Soy Pill, you want to join my
Discord? See what happens? Soy Pill, I'm
Hold on. What is Soy Pill's Discord? I'm
sending him an invite right now. The soy
pill
invite principal. Yeah,
>> seems pretty crazy to me. But don't get
me wrong,
>> you have to warn him. I He's very aware.
He has to be super aware. See you later,
Kio. He has to be so aware.
>> Understand the concept. Can I Hold on.
I'm gonna actually ask. Sorry. It was
like instant. It was like instant the
response. Okay.
Welcome, friend. You trying to get me
killed, you crazy son of a [__]
>> On the impetus of Zionism.
>> Good times.
>> Good times. Today, if you try to
establish a state today, I would say
like, okay, clearly this is going to
cause a bunch of problems and there are
plenty of countries that accept you. And
like even in America where like
anti-semitism is on the rise, it's still
incredibly safe place for Jews. This is
silly. But like back in the end of the
40s and like right after the Holocaust,
like I get it. It's just a really bad
decision. So I and I hate religion and I
hate the the way that religion justifies
it's like, "Oh, this is our religious
homeland, therefore it's okay." Destiny
was too friendly with Fentes, but he was
debating him. Yeah. Like he might have
been a little too buddy putty, but I've
done that with neo-Nazis before. Like,
hey, what's up? Hah. I'll shake your
hand, you piece of racist. Still to this
day, Nick isn't that racist. He had
black. I That's an interesting comment.
I defended the Fentes thing back then. I
think you can talk to some You can talk
to somebody if you disagree with them.
You're gonna have like contentious
conversations. I will say it's tough to
have that conversation with Fentes. Like
when he says when he asks that guy in
the middle of the street, "Hey, are
you?" It's a little hard to push back.
>> Friends, just tip $3.
>> That'll catch you off guard.
>> I joined your Discord. Come on. Have no
fear.
>> No, you don't get to join the Discord,
DF. Sorry. You're out. I'm sorry.
Unlucky, man. I'm just I'm just telling
you, okay?
It's tough to with Plantas. It's tough
to know, okay? You got to have your head
on a swivel at all times. Just be ready
to push back at all times. What did DKF
do? He's like a turbo energy vampire
type. Sorry. Not a not a horrible
person. Just everything's always about
how he's having a rough time. You know,
you know how it is.
>> Black friends. No, Nick is a neo-Nazi. I
know he acknowledges that. You messed up
by saying we just don't let Nazis in.
Yeah, but that's the thing is we do let
Nazis in. Right now, I wouldn't say we
could have to ideologically test
immigrants. There's plenty of like
Europeans that probably immigrate to
America that are probably Nazis that I
prefer not be here, but I don't want to
like ethnically or like even like
ideologically test people. Um, it's so
weird. It was funny that he was trying
to juice blame the I I do think it's
very weird to me though how Eerite and
Dest are totally fine implying that all
Arabs are bloodthirsty and want to kill
all Jews, right? But if you ever made
that same conflation of of Zionism
and Judaism,
right, that saying like, "Oh, all you
know, all want to kill people or
something, people would lose their
minds. All all Israel, even if you said
all Israelis just want to kill all
Arabs, they'd probably still lose their
minds." Well, there are some Israelis
who really like Arabs. It's It is
because Islamophobia is allowed. And I'm
just like, dude, like it's just kind of
crazy to me that it's just allowed. It's
just part for the course. It just is
what it is.
>> Gummy verse, you pushed it to the utmost
limit.
And we grabbed
Let's go. 1 hour on the stream. 1 hour
11 seconds. 1 hour 10 seconds. Let's go.
Pretty sure if you're applying to be a
US citizen, you have to affirm you're
not a communist or not affiliated with a
communist party of any kind. Red scare
stuff left over. What do you think?
Straight. Would you straight away could
you immigrate to America if you'd been
born outside of America or would you be
would they just be like nah nope you
said you're a communist online once
you're out bye-bye
>> importance of birthright well I think he
might have assumed my position was like
the reason they do birthright is to
convert you to Judaism which is
obviously not true
is Spencer citing his power level he's
not hiding it in his private paid
community he's not about he's he's
trying to sanewash himself he's not
hiding his power level obviously he's
still neo-Nazi I don't think actually
we're openly calling for the mass
killings of Germans Probably not. I've
seen Destiny saying Netanyahu is a bash
and save war criminal needs to go. Yeah.
True. Finlestein is a [__] You
ignorant [__] He pretends not to be,
but then never covers how Israel has
messed up and currently I can't do the
voice. I'd say try to do the line. You
fantastic [__] I can't do the voice.
It's like not quite. You fantastic
[__] I can't do it. I just sound like
I'm racist. I'm sorry. I tried my best.
I tried. I failed. I'm hit and play on
the screen.
>> Crashed out on Miss Rachel for being pro
Palestine. To be fair, I saw Miss Rachel
say some uh some actually anti-Semitic.
She was like liking some anti-semitic
stuff. Uh so, you know, people are like,
"Oh, she's just saying like don't kill
kids." But I'm like, "Well, Miss Rachel,
you like this comment that says like
don't want you to know this or some
weird like that." I was like, "I hope
you did that one on accident." Dude, I
swear to God,
just stop killing kids. You liked
something that said the don't want you
to know this. That's like where the line
is. Like literally there's a comment
that you liked on a post about kids
getting killed and people are like way
more than they're outraged about the
kids getting killed. They're like you
you liked a comment that said that don't
want you to know this. Are you not
concerned about your attitude? ARE YOU
NOT CONCERNED ABOUT YOUR ATTITUDE AND
THE THING YOU'RE FOCUSED ON RIGHT NOW?
You seem pretty inhuman to me. Okay. You
seem like you are not a person.
How in the world did I tell you a bunch
of kids got killed and then I liked a
comment that said, "Oh, don't want you
to know this." instead of the Israelis
don't want you to know this and now I'm
the monster. Are you serious? Are you
for real? There's got to be some There's
got to be some name for this pattern
that unfolds, right? There has to be
somewhere out here. What is this
barbarism critic thing to buy? I would
like to buy
a burrito.
And in that burrito, I would like
ketchup.
I would like chocolate chips
and if you have them some grapefruit
and if you do not
>> bro I remember watching
>> I can't pause this Twitter's broken
>> with ketchup
>> with chocolate chips.
>> We're stuck here now
>> and with pieces
>> we're stuck here.
I will not be supporting your
establishment
in the same way I will not support the
apartheid
genocidal regime of the Israeli
government and the way it treats its
Palestinians
both in and out of Gaza and the West
Bank.
No,
>> dude. It's It's actually just taking
like as long as Norfinkle scene. That's
how I know it's accurate. I just like
come on today, man. Today.
What are we doing? Dan and Destiny have
an inside joke about Miami chasing Dan
to convert him. The point is they don't
try to convert non-Jews. Uh, okay,
that's fair. They're usually chasing the
secular Jews. That's because it's so
much easier than getting anyone else on
board. Yeah. Fent for a
>> Is that why they Is that why they do it?
Because it's way easier getting secular
Jews on board than anyone else. Is that
Are you sure? Do you Do you think that's
why? Do you think that's it?
>> Holy war against Jews and supports
imperialism.
>> I don't know. There's so many people who
are in total denial about it being an
ethnore religion. And I it makes no
sense to me. Like yeah there are like
edge cases to where the ethno religion
stuff doesn't necessarily apply 100%.
And they are willing to take with like
significant devotion people from outside
of the ethnic group but it is by and
large and the way it is by and large
propagated is as an ethnore religion.
They don't have any problem saying it.
Are you?